Wir brauchen auch noch am Anfang bei Mobamex so wie bei Lost so. Vielleicht sollten wir mal wieder über Max reden.
Hier abends einen Parkplatz zu finden, das ist ja wirklich ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal wieder über Max reden.
Hallo, IT.
Dann hab ich aber auch gelesen, dass die neuen MacBook Pros Probleme mit diesen SATA 3 Anschlüssen haben.
Schon mit Ein-
und Ausschaltenversuch.
Da paaren sich gerade wirklich die Debile mit dem Nutzen.
Zwölf Monate später.
Ich wollte überhaupt in meinem Leben immer nur einen einzigen Computer.
Den besten.
Wenn Apple der Meinung ist, wir müssen den jetzt nicht mehr bauen, dann ergibt sich da eine Opportunity.
Die Enttäuschung ist ja für alle natürlich jetzt so groß.
Dazu wird seit mittlerweile 40 Episoden die Sendung durch ein sogenanntes Previously eingeleitet.
Aber das Mikrofon klingt doch blecher, da findest du nicht auch? Ja, so ein bisschen Lachen einspielen und so.
Ich denke, also ping ich.
Möchtest du noch weitere Songs eigentlich zur Verfügung stellen?
Das musst du David fragen, ich hab ja keinen Song gemacht. Ich bin echt vollkommen schockiert, die Leute twittern mir, dass diese Nummer jetzt in die Plätze gekriegt ist, gegen den Eichhörn schafft ist. Bist du rasch in einem Radio gelaufen?
Das ist einfach kaputt. Dann ist es einfach funktional kaputt. Ich bin jetzt zufrieden. Läuft die Aufnahme. Haben die schon uns das mitkriegen?
Dann sollen sie doch gefälligst eine neue Datei schreiben. Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Wir gehen weiter. Rainer Farb.
Du hast die Arschbacke wechselt.
Für all die Leute, die immer fragen, kann ich denn ein ASP werden? Geht so, du machst an deine Leitung, zu deinem Peering-Partner machst du einen Tacho dran, beziehungsweise zwei Tachos dran.
Und das ganze Teil wird eingeschoben.
Ja, ich habe nie gesagt, dass es kein Starkbier ist.
Ist es ein Starkbier?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe es nie gemessen.
Und auf Platz 1 bei hier lacht der Freak.
Aber wenn du jetzt sagst, man geht nicht zur Republika, weil die riechen ja alle nach Lulu.
Die riechen mir alle zu wenig nach Lulu.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Wie auch immer.
Wie oft hast du das heute schon gesagt?
Noch nicht genug.
Sie machen dort ein Produkt in 2014 basiert auf Glasfasertechnik. Was schlechter ist als das von der Telekom. Und teurer. Unglaublich! Ich dachte echt, ich spinne. Das ist schleif.
Wollen wir nochmal anfangen?
Schritt für Schritt übernehme ich die Metaebene. Irgendwann gehört der ganze Scheiß-Laden in mir.
Denn äh, ich nehm's gleich mal vorweg, David ist da. Hallo David, willkommen und Gratulation zur 100.
Ja, ich möchte zu meiner eigenen Sicherheit was rausschicken. Weiß ich, irgendjemand wehgetan hat in einem der Previouslys. Es war nicht so gemeint ins Show-Business.
Was, jetzt von uns oder was?
Ja, ja.
Das hättest du schon gemerkt noch.
Wir sind uns allen des Risikos bewusst.
Mittlerweile.
Alles, was wir sagen kann und wird gegen uns zu Ende werden.
So sieht's nämlich aus. Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Freak Show, das ist die 160. davon. Das heißt, da gehen wir jetzt schon doch ganz schön viel gemeinsam im Weg. Hättest du gedacht, dass das mal 100 werden?
Nee, ne? Ich hätte nicht mal gedacht, dass ich es bis zur 100 schaffe. Also bis zur Meter Mobile Max 100.
Hättest du dann gedacht, dass du es bis zur 100 schaffst, Timme?
Was? Diese Sendung zu machen? Klar, warum nicht? Was meinst du, warum ich dreistellige Sendungsnummern von Anfang an habe?
Ja, weil du Hacker bist und schon eine Weile dabei bist.
Wenn wir 999 durchhaben, dann können wir überlegen, wo wir es sein lassen.
Dann ist es auch schon egal.
Ja, dann ist es auch Rente oder so, keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt.
Diese Zeit, wo man angeblich keine Lust mehr hat, irgendwas zu machen.
Also noch 840 Sendungen geteilt.
Wie lange haben wir jetzt gebraucht dafür? 2008?
Zwei Wochen geteilt.
Das wird schwierig bis 999.
2008 haben wir jetzt 2008 angefangen, nein, wir haben nicht 2008 angefangen.
Also 840 Sendungen alle zwei Wochen, das ist noch 32 Jahre. Ich gehe dann aber an Rente.
Pff, echt zu früh.
Bist ja sonst nicht so dafür bekannt, dass du so früh die Segel streichst. Du bleibst doch meistens immer dran an dem Thema, bis es ordentlich durchgnudelt ist.
Das hat dann auch nichts zu bremsen.
Aber ich wollte das auch nicht ablenken, du warst ja beim David so.
Genau, also du hast das erste gemacht und war dir dann schon klar, dass du weitere machen wirst oder war das eigentlich nur ein Gag fürs erste?
Na, ich hab dann ein zweites gemacht und dann ist das tatsächlich auch gesendet worden.
Tatsächlich?
Dann hab ich das dritte gemacht und das war eigentlich so irgendwie, hat sich dann so eingebürgert. Das war jetzt gar nicht so geplant. Ich hab auch nicht gedacht, dass das so lange läuft und...
Und wir können das ja jetzt mal aufklären.
Was keiner gemerkt hat. Was du einmal aussetzen musstest.
Liebe Zuhörer, da könnt ihr jetzt mal rätseln.
Einmal gab es kein Previously, aber es gab dann trotzdem eins.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr welche, das war jetzt.
Ich auch nicht. Wir haben es ja nicht dokumentiert.
Nee, es ist nur so indirekt dokumentiert. Dadurch, dass es nicht dokumentiert ist, hör ich das richtig sehr...
Ich war auch...
Was war mit dem Urlaub?
Ich war todkrank, glaube ich. Und konnte nicht... Ich weiß gar nicht, wann das war. Ich glaube, dieses Jahr?
Nein, das ist eine Weile her.
Ein oder zwei Jahre her.
Ja, ich hab mich neulich selber, oder ich hab jetzt im Zuge dieses 100. Previouslys selber gestaunt, dass es schon vier Jahre läuft mit Previouslys.
Ja, ich staude gerade, dass diese Sendung seit über sieben Jahren läuft.
Sieben Jahre. Und das hast du gesagt, jetzt müssen wir noch 32 Jahre dranhängen. 39 Jahre. Das ist eine Laufzeit. 32 Jahre, bin ich dann? Helmut Schmidt ist 96 und ist jetzt erst ins Krankenhaus geschoben worden. Also da geht schon noch was.
Und sag mal, du hast doch bestimmt einen Ordner in deinen Aufzeichnungen mit allen Previouslys, die durchnummeriert sind. Das heißt, du würdest jetzt, wenn du da mit bloßem Auge draufstehst, schon die Lücke finden, wahrscheinlich, wo das Previously fehlt.
Das gibt es auf SoundCloud. Also gibt es auch auf Freak Show, der Strahlerladen, wahrscheinlich wird...
Oder hat David fortlaufende Numerierungen gewählt? Nee, die sind immer befreundet.
Die sind ja nicht selbstnummeriert, weil die sich ja immer auf die letzte Sendung beziehen, obwohl natürlich manche sich auch nicht wirklich auf eine Sendung beziehen wie auch immer. Das hat sich alles so entwickelt. Auf jeden Fall gab es eine Sendung, da war es kein Prerecorded Previouslys, sondern wir haben das Previously Freestyle hier eingesprochen und keiner hat es gemerkt.
Ich würde das jetzt auch tatsächlich gerne mal wieder hören wollen.
Und das waren ja auch nie Auftragsarbeiten, sondern du hast das ja immer so freiwillig hierhin gesendet, oder?
Genau, genau.
Und es hat aber auch noch nie jemand anders mal die Idee gehabt, das irgendwie an dich zu senden, oder? Also an Tim? Weil es hätte ja auch passieren können. Eigentlich, das war ja jetzt nicht, dass du da den festen Deal hast, oder?
Den hat er sich halt selber, hast dich ja selber eingekauft in die Show sozusagen. Also bis ja, weiß nicht, das war das dann auch gleich die nächste Sendung schon, wo du das gemacht hast? Ja, ne? Ich glaube, ja.
Ich glaube, wir haben die 59. einmal ausgesetzt, jetzt die 160. Sind so 100 Stück. Genau, dann haben wir es einfach weiter gemacht.
Vor The Greater Good.
Ich wollte die mäßig gleich so hoch angesetzt, da hat sich gar keiner getraut, noch irgendwie was Ähnliches zu machen.
Ja, nee, war ja auch bisher immer total Suppi und so. Ich bin ja immer ganz froh, dass wir auch ausreichend Vorlagen liefern.
Ja, also bei Lichter betrachtet muss man auch sagen, da gab es ja ein paar Sachen, da muss man sagen, na gut.
Ja, war schön, dass du da warst.
Wir waren jetzt nicht so...
Aber es ist natürlich auch so ein zweischneidiges Schwert, also die besten Sendungen der Freak-Shows, wo wirklich intensiv an so einem Thema mal diskutiert wird und in die Tiefe gegangen wird und mal alles strukturiert läuft, bieten relativ wenig für Previouslys. Also viel besser ist es für mich, wenn alles durcheinander geht und Leute sich hier anspannen.
Da müsste doch eigentlich jedes Mal super sein.
Es gibt wirklich ein, zwei Sendungen.
Doch, so viele.
Das ist dann immer, wenn so diese Specials kommen, die sich nicht wirklich auf die Sendung beziehen. Du hast ja immer so zwei, drei Ideen in der Hinterhand, so für solche Fälle, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also die Hinterhand ist relativ leer. Also es gibt so manchmal Dienstagabend, da denke ich, heute Abend muss ich noch was machen. Also morgen ist die Sendung und ich hab noch keine Idee, so gegen 18 Uhr wird es dann langsam.
Dienstagabend, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, das Privileg jemals später als einen Tag vorher gehabt zu haben.
Genau, dann muss ich mich ansetzen und dann irgendwie in der Nacht auf dem Mittwoch liegt es dann in der Dropbox. So und manchmal...
Na ja, also im Wesentlichen hast du mich zuverlässiger daran erinnert, dass es eine Sendung ansteht als mein Kalender.
Ja und es gibt so Sachen, also wenn man sich nicht auf die letzte Sendung bezieht, ich habe ja auch so ein paar Adaptionen von anderen Podcast-Intros gemacht und das war zum Teil relativ aufwendig. Ich erinnere mich an die Mikrodeletaktionen.
Die haben gestaunt.
Die haben gestaunt?
Ja, die haben gestaunt, weil, wenn ich das richtige in Erinnerung habe, quatschen die ja immer in ihr Intro rein.
Ja, das war ja auch komplett reingeniert. Das war ja nicht gesampelt.
Du hast mehrere genommen und dann immer da, wo sie nicht reinquatschen, das zusammengeschnitten oder was?
Zum Teil, aber zum Teil auch selber neu einkomponiert. Also das war wirklich so eine 8-Stunden-Arbeit. Und ich war total stolz, dass es funktioniert hat. Und dann wurde es ausgestrahlt. Es gab auch kein Feedback irgendwie aus diesem Internet. Es gab nichts.
Gar kein Feedback, also niemand hat das gerafft oder was?
Niemand hat das gerafft.
Wie viele haben wir jetzt gehabt? Drei, glaub ich jetzt. Einschlafen, das und dann war da noch einer.
Kolinas Erben war noch einmal.
Stimmt.
Oder war das bloß geplant? Weiß ich nicht.
Doch, ich glaube, Kolinas Erben war auch dabei. Die drei waren das. Gibt es da noch mehr? Oder findest du, die Intro ist der anderen nicht so...
Na, sie müssen sich ja anbieten irgendwie für eine Adaption. Also, wenn irgendwie bloß jemand eine Melodie hat, da kann man nichts draus machen. Das ist jetzt schwierig, dann da anzusetzen. Mal gucken, mal gucken. Die Podcast-Landschaft entwickelt sich ja auch weiter. Da gibt es auch viele neue Vorspanne, die man adaptieren könnte.
Ja, das stimmt. Die Qualität ist da auf jeden Fall gestiegen.
Und wie oft wurde jetzt der Funktional-Kaputtsong tatsächlich über die Ladentheke?
Genaue Zahlen weiß ich gar nicht mehr, aber ich glaube, es war diese Spendenaktion dahinter. Das gesamte dadurch eingenommene Geld wurde ja gespendet an die digitale Gesellschaft. Und da muss man dann abziehen. Apple, 30% wurde da abgezogen. Die Spendensumme war irgendwas um 850 Euro. Dann kann man das ja hochrechnen. Also ein paar, ein bisschen über 1.000 Mal, denke ich mal, bevor der Song verkauft war.
Und gestreamt auf Soundcloud wahrscheinlich 100.000 Male.
Ne, weiß ich gar nicht. So oft war das, glaube ich, gar nicht. Aber der läuft immer noch ganz gut. Das war ja, die gesamte Aktion war ja ein Glücksfall, dass das so passiert ist. Das war ja auch so ein bisschen peak previously. Danach hätte man schön aufhören können. Das habe ich leider verpasst.
Nein, das war schon ein Highlight. Aber da kamen ja dann noch so einige Highlights hinterher. Also das wäre nur echt schade gewesen. Auch gerade so dieses Mt. Gox-Ding. Das fand ich auch, ganz großes Kino.
Ja und hier dieser Ableton-Un-Ableton-Rand-Song, der war auch super.
Das war das mit dem, der bricht einfach ab anstatt ein neues Pfeil. Genau, er hört einfach auf. Was er jetzt nicht mehr benutzt.
Ne, Ableton ist raus.
Schon auch lange eigentlich, oder? Ist das schon ein Jahr her oder wie lange?
Mindestens, seit Ralf hier mit dem Ultraschall aufgefahren ist. Und ja, seitdem hab ich halt hier meine Hassliebe zu Ableton durch eine Hassliebe mit Reaper ersetzt.
Aber zumindest nimmt die neue Hassliebe so lange auf wie du willst.
Genau. Und vor allem auch relativ stabil und relativ gut eigentlich. Also es hat halt andere Probleme. Aber die Probleme, die ich mit Reaper habe, sind halt nicht so schlimm und so grundsätzlich und so furchtbar und so grauenhaft, wie jetzt mit Ableton Live. Also keine Ahnung. Es steht sicherlich auch nochmal an, dieses Thema, man nimmt einen Podcast auf, auch mal vielleicht mit irgendwas anderem zu erschlagen, als ein Tool, was halt für so Gitarrenschrammler und Techno-Artisten gedacht ist.
Also Live und Gitarrenschrammler, da bist du aber wirklich in der falschen Ecke. Das ist ja nur so Live-DJ-Club- elektronische Musik-Loops-Abspiel-Ding. Zusammen mit eigenen Synthies aus dem Baukasten zusammenklicken und so.
Na ja, halt so Leute, die halt komponieren und quasi Musik damit erzeugen. Das ist ja ein bisschen mehr so, ist ja so ein bisschen wie Word für Musik.
Mehr Excel für Musik, aber ja.
Genau, und dieses, also dass man damit überhaupt aufnehmen kann, eine Live-Situation aufnehmen kann, ist ja eher ein Abfallprodukt bei diesen ganzen Programmen. Es ist ja nichts dafür gebaut, dass es tatsächlich, also nichts geht davon aus, dass es wirklich live ist, im Sinne von radio-live. Und das merkt man dann halt doch immer wieder an bestimmten Stellen. So, und bei Ableton ließen sie sich halt auch überhaupt nicht überwinden. Und naja, bei Reaper lässt es sich überwinden, aber man muss halt die ganze Zeit unter dem Stacheldraht durchklettern und holt sich da Schramm und böse Nasen.
Schramm und Schrabnell.
Ja, also wenn ich hier allein schon dem Ultraschall-Team den ganzen Tag so beim Chatten zuschaue, was für Wände da, die am laufenden Meter laufen, das ist kein Spaß. Also das ist schon Frontkampf. Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Da fragt einer im Chat, gibt es was, womit Tim keine Probleme hat? Ja, manchmal hat man den Eindruck...
Wenn es das gäbe, würde es hier wahrscheinlich nicht erwähnt.
So Spülspämme, ne?
Also keine Probleme.
Na ja, Spülspämme, da gibt es auch Licht und Schatten.
Ich meine, wenn etwas jetzt besonders gut funktioniert, dann treibt man das ja dann auch meistens so weit, bis man dann eben an dessen Grenzen stößt.
Gibt es irgendein Produkt, was dir einfällt, was dich einfach total, immer wenn du es benutzt, oder das erste Mal benutzt, hast du einfach gedacht, ja, endlich, jemand hat nachgedacht und alle... Irgendwas, womit du rundum glücklich warst, direkt von Anfang an.
iPod 5G.
Ahja, iPod stimmt.
iPhone, eigentlich finde ich nach wie vor ein verdammt gelungenes Produkt, so.
Jetzt auf das OS, weil da warst du ja bei iOS 7 nicht so glücklich.
Ne, 7 nicht, aber 8 ist schon wieder okay gewesen und ich würde jetzt auch nicht unbedingt alle meine Kritikpunkte von damals nach wie vor unterstützen. Also manchmal weiß man es ja dann später auch besser. Mein MacBook Air finde ich nach wie vor top. Das ist mit Abstand der beste Rechner, den ich je hatte.
Na, immerhin.
Also so sehr, dass jetzt nichts mich im aktuellen Lineup reizt, gerade.
Ja gut, das ist aber auch besonders schlecht momentan, habe ich das Gefühl.
Findest du? Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt keinen Computer hätte, würde ich nicht sagen, dass ich damit unglücklich wäre. Also da irgendwas zu kaufen, oder?
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, welchen ich jetzt kaufen würde.
Also ich finde den Mac Pro nicht pro.
Waren wir mit dem David schon fertig, bevor er jetzt hier schon wieder abkommt vom Thema?
Nee, nee.
Aber jetzt ist doch genau das Richtige, hat er doch gerade gesagt.
Wir müssen auch jetzt ein bisschen Futter liefern.
Und dann um 11 Uhr fängst du dann an, wieder die Themen irgendwie durchzuschreiten, weil wir keinen Zeit mehr haben.
Ihr wolltet ja den Chat hier mit rein.
Den Chat habt ihr mit rein geholt.
Mac Pro.
Schande.
Mac Pro ist nicht Pro, der Mini ist totale Gülle und viel zu teuer. Ein iMac, ja gut, der ist eigentlich nicht schlecht, aber es ist halt ein Rechner mit eingebautem Display, den man nicht rumtragen kann.
Also kann man schon.
Kann man schon, aber der Akku ist ein bisschen klein. Weiß ich nicht. Und die ganzen Laptops mit ihrem festgelöteten Speicher, da komm ich nicht drauf klar irgendwie. Also es ist vor allen Dingen auch immer so wenig.
Kann ich rausfallen?
Was mich eher spürt ist...
Solange da genug drin ist, ist ja okay.
Ja, ich meine, in manchen Laptops lötet sich sogar der Grafikchip aus. Also ich meine, von wegen nicht rausfallen, das wollen wir mal noch sehen.
Ja gut, aber derzeit ist da so viel Ramm drin, wie der Prozessor überhaupt kann. Also was willst du da noch reinstehen?
Ja, das ist der Wechsel zu Intel. Die Grafikchips, also die Mainboard-Chips werden immer so designt, dass sie die nächste Generation wieder verkaufen können, weil die Leute halt Speicher-Update nur mit einem Prozessor-Update machen können.
Wir können uns ja nachher noch über Skylake unterhalten, da wird ja jetzt irgendwie auch alles besser. Skylake, die neue Prozessor-Generation von Intel. Wurde gestern, glaube ich, offiziell vorgestellt, oder war es heute?
Ich will Ports, ich will Ethernet. Ich will mein Ethernet zurück.
Ich schreib mir mal das Thema mal auf. Kommst du mal gestern, oder brauchst du ein Hockey? Aber wir sollten noch mal zu David kommen, glaube ich. Weil wir müssen ja erstmal den Gast abklopfen hier, ne? Genau. Du bist ja dann auch unter die Podcaster gegangen.
Genau. Lange danach gesucht, lange irgendwie überlegt, einen Podcast machen zu wollen, und irgendwie nie so das richtige Format gefunden, weil man auch mal überlegen muss, was kann man denn so, was passt so zu einem? Und dann gab es, ich glaube, es gibt immer noch dieses Tumblr-Podcast-Ideen, und da hat einer gesagt, man müsste doch eigentlich mal einen Podcast machen über Crowdfunding-Projekte. Und das war sofort überzeugend, fand ich, bei Geschmack mit Leuten ins Gespräch zu kommen, die Crowdfunding-Projekte machen. Und es gibt ja diese ganzen Plattformen, und da haben ja die Leute immer so die Möglichkeit, irgendwie so ein 3-Minuten-Video einzustellen über das, was sie machen wollen. Und eigentlich hab ich immer gedacht, bildet das eigentlich gar nicht das ab, was da wirklich stattfindet. Man müsste sich mal ausführlicher über so ein Thema unterhalten. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein trojanisches Pferd. Eigentlich ist es immer dieses Projekt, was die Leute machen, ist eigentlich bloß ein Anlass, mal ein Thema tiefer zu besprechen. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Leute eine Wasserflasche herstellen, eine Trinkflasche, dann kann man sich mal über Wasser unterhalten, was das heißt, welche Bedeutung Wasser in unserem Leben hat. Das ist ein knapper Rohstoff und so weiter, solche Geschichten. Und da sind ja viele Projekte dabei, bei denen Leute schon das Ziel haben, die Welt zu verbessern. Und sich mit solchen Leuten mal zu unterhalten, ist es schon ganz interessant, welche Vorstellungen die so haben. Also es ist weniger ein Podcast darüber, das große politische Thema aufzumachen und zu sagen, ist denn jetzt Crowdfunding gut oder böse? Chancen und Risiken? Sondern es geht eher darum, die einzelnen Geschichten zu präsentieren.
Mehr so ein Kanal für Macher und Denker, ne?
Ja, genau. Weil dieses gesamte Crowdfunding-Thema ist ja sehr ambivalent. Also das ist ganz interessant. Ich rede ja auch mal mit den Leuten darüber, warum machen sie denn ein Crowdfunding? Und häufig sind sie dem Thema selbst gegenüber sehr kritisch eingestellt. Also ich hab neulich, oder das ist schon eine Weile her, eine Sendung gemacht mit Bernadette Hengst, eine Sängerin hier aus Berlin. Und die hat gesagt, naja, im Grunde ist das neoliberale Scheiße. Die ganze Geschichte. Weil es Crowdfunding gibt und die Politik, die Politik sich zurücklehnen kann und sagen kann, ja, da gibt's doch Crowdfunding, wir müssen jetzt keine Künstler mehr unterstützen und alle Kunstförderungen geht jetzt irgendwie in den Staatsober und alle, die hier prekär leben, sollen sie eben Crowdfunding machen. Und für sie hat das funktioniert. Aber im Grunde ist das schon möglicherweise auch eine Ausrede für Verantwortliche, die eigentlich Unterstützung leisten müssten.
Ja, ja, also erstens finde ich das jetzt... Also erstens habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass das jetzt wirklich schon so ein Hauptlied ist, was in der Politik gesungen wird, so nach dem Motto, wir müssen jetzt die Kunst einstellen, ich glaube, das ist eher eine Angst.
Ja, sicherlich.
Also sehen tue ich das jetzt noch nicht unbedingt. Nein, das würde ja voraussetzen, dass die Staatsoper auch Crowdfunding machen müsste.
Ja, oder dass dieses Thema auch in der Politik mal ankommt, dass es so etwas gibt, dass überhaupt die Existenz von Crowdfunding wahrgenommen wird, das sehe ich ja nicht. Unbedingt auf allen Ebenen gegeben. Aber das ist so die eine Sichtweise, die andere Sichtweise ist, naja, damit werden im Grunde kapitalistische Strukturen untergraben. Das sind wieder andere Leute, die ich auch in der Sendung hatte, die gesagt haben, naja, es gibt immer die Labels, die sagen, irgendwie man darf eine Platte rausbringen oder nicht. Und übers Crowdfunding organisiert man sich eben selber Leute, denen Kunst etwas wert ist, unabhängig von irgendwelchen Strukturen. Das ist so die andere Richtung, die da existiert. Und von daher kann man das von vielen Seiten betrachten. Es gibt ja auch schwierige Projekte, wo ich auch immer hoffe, dass ich die nicht in der Sendung drin hab, wo irgendwelche Truthers sich zusammensetzen und dann irgendwelche Dokumentationsfilme machen. So war es wirklich mit den Ägyptern. Und sind sie nicht doch schon eigentlich rumgeflogen? Ja, solche Geschichten und Nazis-Geschichten.
Das heißt, du hoffst immer, dass du dir nicht eintrittst?
Genau.
Obwohl du meinst, das wäre eigentlich was?
Genau, das weiß man ja vorher vielleicht nicht immer. Also so ein bisschen recherchiere ich da schon. Was sind das da Leute für?
Aber du sendest ja auch nicht live.
Nee, also im schlimmsten Fall würde ich das dann eben nicht ausstreuen.
Oh, Sauri hat nicht aufgenommen.
Ja, die Leitung ist ganz schlecht.
Ja, Elbeton live hat leider die Datei einfach zugemacht.
Es hörte einfach auf.
Der Hund hat die Datei gefressen.
Oder alles, wo es eigentlich Projekte gibt, wo die genug finanziert sind, was aber bloß noch irgendwie so eine Promo-Geschichte ist, damit man auf einer weiteren Plattform noch ist. Sowas ist natürlich schwierig. Und auch alles, was sich im Umfeld von Crowdfunding-Beratern tummelt.
Ach echt?
Das kann ja auch helfen.
Vielleicht für Multimillionenprojekte, die man gut aufziehen muss. Aber für die kleinen netten Projektchen, die sich in der Sendung haben. Ich hab ja nicht die großen Projekte drin, sondern die kleinen.
Warum?
Es geht nicht darum, wie groß ein Projekt ist, damit es in die Sendung kommt.
Das muss ja auch nicht unbedingt uninteressant sein, nur weil es groß und erfolgreich ist.
Richtig, genau. Meine Erfahrung ist aber, dass solche großen Projekte versuchen, andere Kanäle zu wählen, als so einen kleinen Underground-Podcast aus Berlin-Lichtenberg.
Na ja, kann ja mal groß rauskommen. Wie viele Sendungen hast du jetzt zusammen?
44 oder so.
Wir haben noch gar nicht gesagt, wie das Projekt heißt. Schwarmtaler. Das war nicht der erste Name, oder? Den du erwogen hast.
Genau. Schwarmkohle war der Vorschlag in dem Tumblr. Aber der, der das vorgeschlagen hat, hat gesagt, oh, das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee, den Namen reserviere ich manchmal selbst. Und hat dann irgendwie einen Blog aufgezogen mit dem Namen und dann musste ich irgendwie ausweichen. Und Schwarmtaler gefiel mir eigentlich auch besser.
Ist auch besser, finde ich auch. Hat mehr Sound drin. Und Tala hat ja auch immer sowas von Dagobert Duck.
Ja, und von Sterntaler hat das ja auch so ein bisschen.
Und von Sterntaler, genau.
Man macht so ein bisschen das Kleidchen auf und plötzlich...
Ja, du hast ja auch gleich das passende Video dazu produziert. Das fand ich ja schon so ein bisschen Sterntalermäßig. Ja, nee, ich hab... Weiß nicht, habt ihr das schon mal gehört? Ich hab ja da häufig...
Wir haben das doch schon mal in der Sendung hier gehabt.
Ich hab tatsächlich eine Fehlwahrnehmung gehabt dazu.
Ach, was denn?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es eher um die Projekte geht tatsächlich.
Als Crowdfunding, als solches.
Und die ganzen Plattformen und so weiter.
Also das war auch mal ein Thema, aber das sind eher die Specials.
Genau, es gibt so ein paar Folgen über die einzelnen Plattformen. Ich hab irgendwie mit Startnext gesprochen und der Spieleschmiede.
Und dann hat es ja glaube ich auch der Republika gleich mehrere beisammen. Das finde ich auch eine gute Gewichtung, dass man halt sehr viel mehr über das Thema geht. Immer wieder lustige Sachen dabei. Was fällt mir jetzt als erstes ein? Hier die Vögel, die dann dieses Blumenwachstum ohne Erde, was war das noch gleich?
Genau, diese Hydro-Crop. Die habe ich auch gleich geklickt und verschenkt.
Also ich habe den selber gefundet und jetzt der dritte Salat wächst aber nicht. Also ich habe jetzt aus 20 Euro zwei Salate rausbekommen.
Das ist aber auch nicht Sinn der Sache.
Da gab es auch einen Vortrag auf dem CCC-Camp über die Hydroponics und so, ne?
Genau, genau.
Der war aber nicht besonders zu kurz.
Aber da in dem Umfeld sind die Leute ja unterwegs. Die prüfen ja, wie man das erreichen kann, dass auf einer möglichen Mars-Mission man irgendwie Salate anbaut. Wenn man das nicht alle von Erde mitnehmen kann, ne?
Sehen wir ja bald in einem neuen Kinofilm. Genau, aber mit Captain Toffin.
Der kommt jetzt bald, ne?
Ich setze mal kurz eine Zeitmarke.
So Dieter verwurstet.
Hast du da ein Tool beim Hören? Ich meine, womit hörst du?
Downcast, ganz normal.
Und kannst du dir dann Stellen merken? Hat Downcast so eine Markerfunktion?
Ne, sowas gibt es ja alles nicht.
Du kannst Buchmark setzen. Während der Sendung. Also während du hörst kannst du sagen, jetzt bitte Buchmark.
Und die kannst du exportieren?
Die kann man auch, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht genau, linker Fuß gerade, aber du hast zumindest diese Liste.
Weißt du, wie wir das früher gemacht haben? Ich habe gestern zufällig den Anfang von Cinema Paradiso gesehen, da gibt es so eine Szene, da sitzt der Pastor oder wie auch immer vorne im Kino und hinten ist der Filmverführer und immer wenn die dann 1940 oder so, wenn die vorne knutschen, dann klingelt der Typ vorne, der Religiöse und der hinten hat er so ein Stück Papier und hat es einfach in die Rolle, wo sich der Film wieder aufrollt, einfach so dazwischen gesteckt. Das hat dann die ganze Zeit zwar mitgedreht, aber das Papier war genau an der Stelle, wo gerade geknutscht wurde und dann hat das später dann nach der Aufführung rausgeschnitten. So haben die das früher gemacht.
Aus dem Film. Stimmt. Vielleicht gibt es ja hier beim iPhone irgendwo.
Auch eine Rolle.
Wo steckst du da das Papier rein?
Sind gar ein Slot oder so.
Also ich mach das im Grunde mit einer ganz normalen Notizen-App. Schreibt mir den Zeitcode auf und wer was gesagt hat. Und das ist dann alles durchsuchbar. Und jetzt mittlerweile seit 100 Sendungen habe ich da ein ordentliches Archiv.
Unsere Stasi-Acken quasi.
Das heißt du hörst nicht noch mal nachträglich rein, sondern hast mehr oder weniger alles schon immer da.
Ich hör das einmal und bei dem Einmal hören mache ich mir Notizen.
Hast du da so einen Suchkatalog? Irgendwas Dennis?
Das ist auch nicht möglich. Alle zwei Wochen, vier Stunden.
Ja, also man kann bei Instacast diese Zeichen setzen und sie sich als E-Mail schicken oder...
Du verzeihst hättest sparen können.
Direkt in Dropbox speichern. Das mache ich jetzt mal kurz und dann gucke ich mal, was dabei rauskommt. Das ist eine.xpff-Datei.
Hat bestimmt xml in it.
Ja, Instacast ist schon herber Verlust irgendwie.
Allerdings.
Das ist echt bitter. Hat der irgendwas da gemacht von wegen hier, mach doch mal Open Source und so, und dann könnt ihr weitermachen oder so?
Also, sicherlich hätte er sich es noch von irgendjemand abkaufen lassen. Keine Ahnung, ob es da Gespräche gab, aber zumindest ist da meines Wissens bisher noch nicht viel dabei rausgekommen.
Naja, aber so eine App dann zu Open Source ist ja auch eine ganz erfrocken Arbeit.
Das geht irgendwie auch alles nicht so richtig. Das ist klar, weil du kannst ja nicht ohne weiteres den Code verstehen und Software ist ja zunächst einmal ohne die Programmierer selten was wert.
Vor allen Dingen sind wir mal ehrlich, du hast ja doch irgendwo irgendwie was reingekopiert und pastet, was du dann nicht Open Source kannst, weil es vielleicht dann doch nicht die richtige Lezenz hat.
Genau, all diese ganzen Sachen, das ist alles problematisch. Also nicht, dass ich das jetzt unterstellen will, dass das bei Instacast der Fall ist, aber das sind natürlich so Sachen, wo man sich dann extrem sicher sein sollte. Selbst wenn es nur zufällig ist, eine Bibliothek, die du mal ausprobiert hast und danach nie benutzt oder so.
Ja und dann die ganzen Four Letter Words, die du rausmachen musst.
Warum läuft dieser Code nicht? So, ich versuch gerade mal diese Datei hier zu öffnen.
Aber irgendwie bin ich gerade nicht in der Lage, sie zu öffnen.
Diese Bookmark-Datei. Du hast auch noch Aufmerksamkeitsspanne wie...
Wie unser Hörer.
Jetzt macht doch kein Hörer-Bushing.
Na die warten jetzt.
Jetzt doch noch nicht.
Kannst du in der 999. Sendung...
Ja, gibt's auf jeden Fall. Könnte auf jeden Fall helfen. Das ist aber auch so, ich meine, wir sollten... Lass uns mal über Podcasting-Apps reden. Das ist, glaub ich, jetzt auch mal... Wie so was heißt das schon wieder? Na ja, ich meine, seitdem das Ding jetzt mit Insta-Cards, mich fragen natürlich alle Leute...
Mich nicht.
Du machst was falsch.
Ich bin ein- oder zweimal gefragt worden.
Aber du bist ja auch der Podcast-Papst.
Ja, ich bin gefragt worden und selbst wenn ich nicht direkt gefragt werde, ich sehe viele Leute, die das halt fragen. Weil sie sich halt fragen und ich...
Du siehst die Fragezeichen auf den Gesichtern der Menschen.
Ich frag mich das ja auch. Ich frag mich das ja auch, was ist eigentlich die Podcasting-App, mit der ich gerne arbeiten möchte. Um ehrlich zu sein, mir gefällt...
Keine.
Das war so klar.
Also nichts. Ich hab eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, wie ich eigentlich möchte, wie sie funktionieren. Und keine funktioniert so.
Jetzt führe, stifte und vampire bereit halten.
Nee, das kann ich jetzt nicht alles erzählen. Alle haben irgendwas, alle machen irgendwas richtig. Alle machen irgendwas falsch. Und keine Ahnung, manchen fehlen halt einfach ein paar ganz grundsätzliche Sachen. Bei manchen bin ich auch einfach so grundsätzlich so ein bisschen skeptisch. Das, was ich so ein bisschen, was man so ein bisschen ohne viel Schmerzen empfehlen kann, ist sowas wie Pocketcast, was vor allem den Vorteil hat, dass es halt so das einzige ist, was so auf anführungsstrichen allen Plattformen, also allen Mobilplattformen läuft.
Und auf allen synkt, ne?
Und synkt halt. Kommt natürlich dann auch wieder diese andere Problematik dazu. Ich meine, wenn man heute in der Podcasting-App State of the Art entwickeln will, dann muss man auch ganz schön in die Tasten hauen. Also das ist jetzt mal nicht so mal eben gemacht. Das fängt halt schon damit an, dass man eigentlich eine gute Syncing-Infrastruktur bieten sollte. Klar, es gibt auch so kleinere Apps, die sagen, ich mach hier nichts mit Cloud. Das ist jetzt hier alles auf dem Device. Das reicht vielen wahrscheinlich auch, die halt auch einfach nur auf dem Phone oder so, oder Pad oder wo auch immer die Podcasts dann konsumieren und die jetzt auf so ein Syncing nicht angewiesen sind. Aber für mich wäre das schon extrem wichtig. Und du willst natürlich heutzutage auch ordentliche Push-Notifications bekommen. Und dazu brauchst du halt einfach eine Backend-Struktur, wo diese ganzen Notifications überhaupt erst mal generiert werden. Und dazu musst du halt dann auch mehr können, als jetzt nur ein Mobilgerät programmieren. Sondern dann musst du halt auch noch das Backend machen und hast diesen ganzen Rattenschwanz mit Support und 24-7 und die Server müssen laufen. Und was ist, wenn es mal nicht läuft? Das ist auch, glaube ich, das, was Martin an der Stelle so ein bisschen das Genick gebrochen hat. Er hat ja diese ganze Infrastruktur aufgebaut. Aber das kommt halt einfach nicht rein über diese App-Store-Welt, die wir derzeit haben. Weil einfach da zu wenig, zu viel über kostenlos geht und später kaufen und so und freischalten. Gut, könnte man vielleicht noch einen Weg finden. Aber was ich schon immer so ein bisschen arschig fand und immer noch finde, ist, dass es halt einfach keinerlei Upgrade-Pfade gibt. Also wenn du halt wirklich mal sagen kannst, hier Major-Version kostet zwei Euro, zack, boom, geklickt, fertig ist die Laube, aber so musst du das dann immer wieder von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge da rein, schnitzen und das ist halt einfach ungeil. Dazu kommt natürlich, dass man jetzt so mit Overcast so einen weiteren Elefanten in den Raum gelassen hat. Einfach durch den Reach, die der Marco Ament hat. Mal schauen, wenn er irgendwann mal Kapitelmarken unterstützt, dann guck ich mir das auch nochmal an.
Wann war das? Vorletztes Mal in seinem eigenen Podcast, wo sie irgendwie am Anfang ewig über Kapitelmarken gesprochen haben und dass sie so viele Leute angesprochen hätten, aber die wären alle aus Deutschland. Er wüsste gar nicht, was die Deutschen mit den Kapitelmarken hätten. Das ist ein schönes Thema. Wir müssen ihn da weiter nerven. Das macht vor allem Spaß.
Du weißt ja, sie haben sich ja deshalb drunter gehalten, weil sie ja selber auch Kapitelmarken jetzt eingeführt haben bei dem Exodus Tech Podcast und das auch sehr ordentlich machen. Also ist ja auch alles so handnachgehört und handgeschnitten. Und das ist natürlich dann eine gute Voraussetzung, um auch Qualitäts-Bookmarken zu machen. Wie es ja übrigens hier auch in der Freak Show angeboten wird, um das nochmal zu betonen. Ja, hier wird Millisekundengenau markiert. Und ich weiß, es gibt eine Menge Leute, die sagen, hm, das benutze ich irgendwie gar nicht.
Aber so Millisekundengenau sprechen wir doch gar nicht.
Nicht? Nein. Na ja, also auch 50 Millisekunden oder sagen wir mal 100 Millisekunden.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Gewöhnungseffekt. Und ich merke halt, dass ich zum Beispiel Podcasts mit Kapitelmarken häufiger benutze und lieber ansteuere und sie vor allem besser zum Nachhören, Nachschlagen von bestimmten Sachen benutzen kann. Das, finde ich, macht einfach die Attraktivität aus. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich das jetzt einfach überall eingeführt habe.
Es hängt so ein bisschen vom Podcasten natürlich ab. Also wenn es so ein monothematischer Erklärbeer-Podcast ist, so a la CAE, dann will man ihn sowieso von vorne bis hinten hören. Und dann gibt es so episodische Podcasts mit Wir Shoutout of the Week. Wir erzählen euch jetzt erstmal 5 Minuten lang, wer alles irgendwie uns in einem Tweet erwähnt hat. Dann willst du es natürlich skippen, das ist klar.
Ja, aber auch drauf linken oder andere Leute auf bestimmte Teile eines Podcasts verweisen, um sie dann überhaupt erstmal reinzuführen. Wir hören gerade hier so Freak-Show, wenn dann halt so, ja, hier, golle Podcast, musst du mal hören. Nee, irgendwo in der Mitte ist es auch lustig. Aber wenn du halt weißt, hier ist so ein 15-Minuten-Segment, das hat jetzt einfach mal gefetzt, und da steht dann einfach die Zeitmarke und kannst auch noch drauf linken, dann ist alles total supi. Also ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, es gab auch in letzter Zeit eine Menge Meldungen, was sind denn jetzt eigentlich die Podcast-Apps, die jetzt häufig verwendet werden, und dann stehen so ein bisschen die Behauptungen im Raum, dass ja sowieso 95% durch den Podcast-Client von Apple abgedeckt werden, was wahrscheinlich sehr podcastabhängig ist.
Kann der eigentlich Kapitel marken? Also ich meine, Apple hat mit dem ganzen Kram mal angefangen.
Je nach Wetterlage allerdings.
Je nach Wetterlage.
Ja, also gefühlt hat das schon so ein bisschen was mit dem Luftdruck zu tun. Also ich hab jetzt auch wirklich die Schnauze voll gehabt und es nicht mehr weiter überprüft. Ich hab Kapitel marken, ich schreib sie damit auf Phonik rein. Jede Scheißsoftware auf diesem Planeten kann die lesen, die irgendwie Kapitel marken kennt, kommt damit klar. Und dieser Apple Podcast-Client ist so je nach Betriebssystem update, schwankt das immer so zwischen, es gibt gar keine, es gibt welche, aber sie haben keine Titel. Dann hast du so Kapitel 1, Kapitel 2, Kapitel 3, Kapitel 4. Oder es geht dann halt auch mal richtig.
Vielleicht schreiben wir denen mal ein paar Unit-Tests oder so. Dass sie es nicht immer wieder kaputt machen.
Ja, ich versteh's auch nicht. Ich hab auch da schon mal versucht reinzufühlen, aber wie auch immer ist es unklar. Aber ich glaube, dass Kapitelmarken nach wie vor das Thing sind. Man sollte das anstreben. Es war ja mal ein extremer Aufwand, die Dinge überhaupt zu erzeugen. Also jetzt vor allem Indie-Medien-Dateien reinzukriegen. Richtig extrem. Das ist mit der Nutzung von Awfonic hinfällig geworden. Da ist es irgendwie einfach. Dem Publisher ist es halt auch einfach, ins Web zu kriegen und dem Player. Und bleibt halt sozusagen noch eine eigene Strategie dafür, wie macht man sich eben diese Marken. Aber ich hab halt auch gelernt, wenn man sich dessen bewusst ist und wenn man so ein bisschen mit dem Podcasten so weit gekommen ist, dass man weiß, was man tut, also dass man irgendwie Vertrauen hat, dass die Software auch aufnimmt und dass man das sozusagen im Blick hat. Also wenn es mal ein Problem gibt, das so weit... Nö, da muss man auch nicht mehr so weit sein wie ich. Das ist einfach eine Erfahrung, die kommt dann. Und wenn man das will, dann geht das auch. Zum Beispiel war das für mich am Anfang total schwierig, bei meinen Interviewsachen Kapitel zu finden überhaupt. Also überhaupt sozusagen eine Vorstellung davon zu haben, wo ändert sich etwas so sehr, dass es jetzt einer Kapitelmarke würdig ist. Das muss man ja überhaupt erstmal definieren, gerade wenn man so von Thema zu Thema immer so in kleinen Schritten mir andert. Mittlerweile mache ich das halt während der Aufnahme schon, während des Gesprächs. Weil ich halt entweder so an Stellen, wo ich weiß, jetzt stelle ich eine fundamentale neue Frage. Dann setze ich halt erstmal eine Kapitelmarke und später beim Abhören merke ich dann schon, ob das dann gegriffen hat oder nicht. So eine Sache. Geht also alles und ich finde, das sollte auch noch mehr unterstützt werden. Und zwar nicht nur unterstützt werden im Sinne von, da ist dann so ein Haken im Datenblatt, sondern dass man das eben sozusagen als integralen Bestandteil dieses Timeline-Modells ansieht. Das fand ich zum Beispiel gerade jetzt bei Instacast 5 zuletzt sehr gut gelöst. Weil wenn du halt den Podcast hörst und du scrollst so das Podcast-Icon, das Cover so nach oben, dann siehst du halt so die Kapitel und siehst auch, wo du da gerade im Kapitel bist und hast auch nochmal einen Verlauf, also einen Progress Bar innerhalb des Kapitels. Und also ans letzte Kapitel schließen sich dann die Sendungen an, die du schon so per Upnext dir quasi als nächstes zum Phras vorwerfen wolltest.
Da hat auch Podcasts einige ganz gute Ansätze zu zeigen, wo ist man gerade im Kapitel, welchen Podcast hat man wie weit gehört und so. Da fehlen aber noch ein paar andere Features und insbesondere, glaube ich, gibt es noch keine iPad-Version, keine Syncing-Infrastruktur und so. Deswegen, da ist noch ein bisschen featurearm, aber da gibt es sehr gute Ansätze, finde ich. Aber ansonsten darüber hinaus ist doch Stillruht der See, oder? Da gibt es doch jetzt nicht groß Bewegungen.
Kann ich dir jetzt gerade nicht so richtig beantworten. Downcast hat doch auch Kapitelsupport, oder? Ist das da gut?
Man kann einzelne Kapitel anspringen, das funktioniert. Aber zu sehen, wo man gerade im Kapitel ist, gibt es da so Fancy-Geschichten.
Ich denke, wenn man ein gutes Konzept am Start hat und was kann, dann kann man da auch noch was reißen. Mein Hauptwunsch ist, ich bin immer verwirrt mit diesen Programmen, die kommen mir mit viel zu viel Konzepten. Vormerken, Playlisten. Playlisten finde ich, sorry, aber ich verstehe nicht, was alle mit Playlisten haben. Also ich brauche eigentlich nur eine. Und zwar die, in der alles, was ich zuletzt gehört habe, drin ist, das was ich gerade höre und das was ich als nächstes hören will. Das ist eigentlich eine einzige Timeline, die komplett alles enthält, was ich schon gehört habe in der Reihenfolge, wie ich es gehört habe. So eine ewige Liste quasi. So ein Logbuch.
Scrollbar.
Und zwar...
Butterweich. Ja, weil ich das am laufenden Meter habe. Ich höre was.
Das musst du in Vatikal schreiben.
Dann höre ich was anderes. Und dann will ich auf das zugreifen, was ich gehört habe. Weil das ist noch in meiner Erinnerung. Da will ich gegebenenfalls nochmal reinhören. Oder das will ich empfehlen, merken, wegsichern, Bookmarken, posten. Wenn die letzte Sekunde erreicht ist, dann ist das Ding aus dem Sinn. Und bei Overcast am besten gleich gelöscht. Da gibt es auch Optionen, mit denen man das verhindern kann. Aber das finde ich irgendwie blöd. Podcasts können sich von alleine löschen, wenn man ordentliches Memory-Management am Start hat. Wenn es nicht mehr reinpasst, wird es gelöscht. Aber das muss irgendwie smooth gehen. Einfach eine Timeline für alles mit den Kapitelmarken. Meiner Meinung nach könnte das super funktionieren. Na ja, maybe it's just me. Mal gucken, was sich da noch so tut. Eine richtige Empfehlung habe ich jetzt nicht, wo man jetzt hinmarschieren sollte. Mir gefallen natürlich die Podcast-Developer, die so ein bisschen Podlauf-affin sind, automatisch gleich ein bisschen besser. Da könnte auch noch ein bisschen mehr passieren. Da gibt es ja auch eine Android-Welt, diverse Podcasts, die zumindest die Checkmarks haben, mit wir unterstützen das und das und das. Aber es ist noch ein bisschen dünner. Da müssen wir schon noch ein bisschen mehr Erfolge erzielen. Also hier, Proamirai da draußen. Ich finde, eigentlich ist es eine super dankbare Zielgruppe. Wir wissen alle, wie Podcast-Hörer involviert sind, wie wichtig ihnen die App ist. Das ist ja so wirklich wie eine Brille eigentlich.
Engagement heißt das heute.
Engagement, genau.
Oder bei euch auch.
Wir gucken gleich auf die KPIs hier und so.
Die mögen nicht leicht zu fassen zu sein. Jeder geht natürlich immer erst mal von seinen Hörgewohnheiten aus. Manche hören halt nur drei Podcasts und brauchen diesen ganzen Quatsch nicht. Andere, so wie ich, ich brauche einen Podcast klein, der nicht anfängt zu stottern, wenn da 200 Subscriptions drin sind. Wozu brauchst du denn 200 Subscriptions? Natürlich höre ich nicht 200 Podcasts. Aber nur weil ich einen mal nicht höre, will ich den noch nicht gleich komplett vergessen. Und es gibt zum Beispiel keinen einzigen Podcast klein, wo du sagen kannst, leg den mal in mein Archiv. Also ich will den aus der Liste, der holt dir da immer das Neue und zeigt mir, dass da was Neues, mich rausnehmen. Aber ich will den ja nicht komplett vergessen. Weil es kann sein, dass ich ja in einem Jahr Bock hab, da mal wieder reinzuhören. Aber kein Podcast klein hat eine Vorstellung davon, dass man halt auch mal was nicht hört.
Du meinst auf Eis?
Auf Eis, genau. Auf Eis legen. Also entweder weil die sich selber auf Eis legen, das kann man zum Beispiel auch ganz gut feststellen, dass irgendwo nichts mehr kommt und so. Nee, aber ich finde ja auch die Podcast mit der App. Und das ist ja wieder das alte Internet-Problem. Ihr wisst ja, finden ist einfach, wiederfinden ist schwierig. Du hast halt mal einen Podcast mal reingehört, fandest den mal ganz interessant, hast aber jetzt gerade nicht die Zeit oder Lust, nervt so oder keine Ahnung, hast dir die falsche Episode angehört. Und später stellst du dann fest, oh, das ist aber der, über den jetzt alle reden. Und dann, wie hieß der, was war das nochmal, keine Ahnung. Klar, wenn du dich an jedes Detail erinnerst und jede URL sofort parat hast, sofern sie noch dieselbe ist, alles wunderbar. Aber es wäre sehr viel einfacher, wenn ich in meiner Archivliste einfach nachschlage, was sind denn hier die zuletzt von mir abbestellten Podcasts? Ah, hier der, zack, bumm, den schalte ich jetzt einfach wieder ein. Womit ist er da, ohne dass ich mich durch irgendwelche Podcast-Verzeichnisse durchlullen muss? Wär doch mal ganz nett. So, gibt's aber nicht. Alles so Sachen, die noch gemacht werden können. Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, das ist eine große Herausforderung, eine gute Podcast-App zu machen. Das ist wirklich eine der schwierigsten zu lösenden Probleme, wo auch noch so viele Probleme ungelöst sind. Allein das User-Interface eines Podcasts. Keine zwei Podcast-Clients haben denselben Ansatz. Das ist alles irgendwie anders. Das macht ja auch diesen Wechsel so schwierig. Kennst du das nicht auch, dass man von der einen Podcast-App auf die andere geht, da ist alles irgendwie anders gedacht. Das ist auch verständlich, weil jeder einen anderen Weg dahin hat und andere Lösungsansätze hat. Aber es ist jetzt auch noch nicht so wie eine Twitter-App oder so, wo irgendwie klar ist, wie so die grundlegende Präsentation ist. Und der Rest unterscheidet sich in Nuancen. Es ist noch nicht so wie so ein Auto, wo man gesagt hat, ja klar, hier Auto, hier ist Lenkrad und zwei oder drei Pedale und vielleicht noch so ein Hebel. Und damit kannst du dann das Auto halt fahren und der Rest ist eigentlich nur Schmuck und Luxus.
Hebel? Ach so, für Autos, die sowas haben.
Haben eigentlich alle.
Ja, nicht alle.
Welche nicht?
Aber ich meine, wir sind ja alle fit im Kopf und würden glaube ich so einen Wechsel der Podcast-App von einer App auf die andere irgendwie schon überstehen und auch das neue Bedienkonzept lernen. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so das Problem, aber ich glaube, sonst reden wir jetzt drei Stunden darüber, wie eine Podcast-App aussieht. Also für mich ist ja das gesamte Thema Feedback nicht gelöst. Das ist für mich sowohl als Hörer wichtig, zu sehen, was finden denn andere besonders interessant oder wo reagieren sie wie. Aber auch als Podcaster will ich ja wissen, was hat denn gut funktioniert im Podcast. Podcasts leiden ja darunter. Ich glaube, das wurde ja auch schon mal besprochen, oder? Mir kommt das gerade irgendwie sehr bekannt vor. Oder wir haben es auf einem Workshop gemacht. Da hatten wir auch mehrere Diskussionen zu dem Thema. Das eine ist natürlich die Feedbacks unter den Episoden. Das funktioniert ja für manche Podcasts ganz gut. Huckel, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es bei dir ist. Gibt es da was?
Ja, da kommen Kommentare immer wieder. Nicht viele, aber doch, doch.
Also das ist ja das eine, aber das ist schon eine Zugangshürde, weil man unterwegs ist, podcastet im Auto gerade und kann irgendwie gerade etwas nicht machen. Man muss sich auch überlegen, was schreibt man denn jetzt da und möglicherweise einen Bezug nehmen auf eine bestimmte Stelle. Und da mal so ein schnelles Feedback zu geben, das fand ich jetzt gut, über ein Emoji oder irgendwie so. Das wäre eine interessante Geschichte, was zurückgespielt wird und mit irgendeiner Cloud anderen präsentiert wird. So, das wäre vielleicht nochmal eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Also es gab mal irgendwie eine Diskussion auf einen der Podlauf-Podcaster-Workshops. Für die Uhr.
Nein, für sowas.
Ja, aber es wurde überlegt, wie müsste sowas aussehen? Man müsste eine Podcast-App haben, einen Podcatcher, der eine Uhr-Extension hat. Wo man dann bloß schnell mal klickt. Ah, das ist ganz interessant. Ich mache jetzt hier einen Smiley, hier mache ich irgendwie einen Blitz.
Da gibt es unter anderem den Vortrag von Claudia und Ralf auf der letzten Republika. Denen hast du jetzt gerade ein bisschen mit reingemixed, weil da haben sie besonders diesen Emotion-Aspekt nochmal mit reingebracht. Und auf dem letzten Workshop, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau in welchem Rahmen, es war glaube ich jetzt keine richtige Session, aber das war auf jeden Fall ein Thema. Hab ich auch mit der Jeanette viel darüber gesprochen, die das hier einbauen will. Da sind wir jetzt bloß im letzten halben Jahr nicht so richtig vorangekommen, wegen bekannten Gründen. Aber dass man halt einfach in den Feed diese Information mit reinbaut. Das ist ja so ein bisschen auch so unser Ansatz. Wir würden halt gerne mehr über den Feed machen und da ziehen irgendwie noch nicht so viele Leute mit. Obwohl es eigentlich der allerbeste Ort ist. Also meiner Meinung nach muss man einfach den Feed ausbauen, weil der ist einfach perfekt. Der ist eh da, der ist maschinenlesbar, er ist erweiterbar, da kann man alles reinschreiben, was man will und wenn man sich dann halt einfach nur darauf einigt, hier diese Feedback-Extensions zu erkennen, dann kann man halt im Feed genau kommunizieren. Feedback bitte hier per E-Mail, wir nehmen Text, wir nehmen Audio, Pipapo und fertig ist die Laube. Ist eigentlich alles schon fertig spezifiziert, aber wir kommen gerade nicht so richtig vorwärts als wegen anderen Baustellen. Und weil uns natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen die Implementatoren-Seite weggefallen ist. Mit Martin in Sarkas war das immer super, weil er eigentlich immer alles gleich so eingebaut hat. Wenn man sich grundsätzlich mal darüber einig war, dann hatte man eben auch sofort so diesen Zyklus geschlossen. Man hatte einen Standard, man hatte eine Anbieter-Seite mit dem Publisher und man hatte auch den App, wo es rauskommt, und dann konnte man auch gleich das durchspielen. Das geht sicherlich jetzt zum Beispiel mit Podcast, vielleicht auch mit ein paar anderen, aber so viele App-Developer haben sich jetzt bei uns auch noch nicht unbedingt vor die Tür gesetzt. Wäre eigentlich super, weil dann kommt man einfach super schnell voran und wir sehen ja an dieser Kapitelmarkendiskussion, dass sie Germans sogar populäre amerikanische Tech-Podcasts mit Werbung dazu bringen können, Kapitelmarken zu setzen, obwohl die von ihnen selbst programmierten Programme das noch nicht unterstützen. Das finde ich insofern schon mal ziemlich bemerkenswert. Da können wir durchaus was bewegen, weil Deutschland ist ohnehin anders. Merkt man immer wieder. Jetzt gab es hier gerade die Übersicht, welche Browser benutzt die Welt? Was ist der populärste Browser in den Ländern? Ich stellte fest, die Welt benutzt Chrome. Da dachte ich mir so, hoppala, interessant. Nur Deutschland nicht. Da ist halt Firefox vorne. Wir wissen auch warum.
Warum wissen wir das?
Weil wir Angst vor dem Google-Mann haben. Die Linux-Community ist ja in Deutschland extrem stark. Im Vergleich zu dem Rest der Welt. Hier ticken die Hürden teilweise anders. Zumindest ticken die Hirne teilweise anders. Ich meine, weißt du, wie Deutschland ist? Das macht einen manchmal fertig, aber irgendwie ist es auch geil.
Die Susse-Jungs waren bei Linux schon relativ früh am Start. Oder es gab es noch für andere Boote. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es Red Hat schon gibt. Diese Susse-Distribution Linux-mäßig.
Die waren richtig weit vorne.
Das macht es vielleicht auch aus.
Ja klar, das ist auch ein Symptom davon. Linux-Industrie, auch Linux-Tag war ein Riesenevent. Das hat jetzt ein bisschen an Fahrt verloren. Aber grundsätzlich ist das Thema nach wie vor da.
Wieder Firefox starten.
Ja, und so bei den Podcasts ist es halt genauso. Weil, weiß ich auch nicht, ich mag das ja irgendwie, dieses Ordnungsding. Hast du diesen Tweet-Dialog dann noch mitbekommen? Dieser Casey Liss von diesem Exzellent Tech Podcast meinte ja dann irgendwann, wenn die USA und Deutschland mal wieder in den Krieg ziehen, dann bestimmt wegen Kapitelmarken. Woraufhin ich ihm antwortete, don't mention the war. Und wer den Podcast kennt, weiß, dass er immer sehr schlecht ist mit popkulturellen Referenzen. Hat er natürlich dann auch nicht verstanden. Da hab ich darauf hingewiesen, dass es eine ist. Ich hab ihm irgendwie die multiple Video geschickt und war da lustig.
Das war's jetzt genug mit Podcast und Kapitelmarken. Setz mal eine jetzt.
Wollen wir nochmal aufs Camp zurückkommen? Weil da hatten wir ja gerade eine Sendung gemacht. Bitte wie?
Ist da noch was? Kann man da nochmal zurückkommen?
Möchtest du wieder heim ins Camp? War's schön?
Ja, sicher.
War schon schön, oder?
War sehr...
Bisschen wenig Schlaf, aber...
Das liegt an dir. Ich hab auf dem Camp so gut geschlafen wie noch auf keinem Festival vorher.
Besser als zu Hause.
Fast? Wirklich?
Zu Hause auf meinem Bett hatte ich so ein bisschen mit dem Rücken immer morgens und da nicht. Obwohl ich ja Angst hatte, ein bisschen vor dieser Luftmatratze, aber die war super.
Ich hab neun Stunden da einmal geschlafen.
Vielleicht aber auch, weil man sich ja schon so ein bisschen die Kante gegeben hat.
Wenn man müde war, war man auch wirklich richtig müde.
Man konnte nicht genießen, dass man müde ist. Was ich ja sonst eigentlich immer cool finde. Ich geh jetzt ins Bett und ich schlaf sofort ein. Das wurde da gleich übersprungen, gleich so hingelegt und weg.
Ich hatte ja am ersten Abend, als ich ankam, war ja schon dunkel oder es dunkelte, als ich irgendwie aus dem Bus ausgestiegen bin. Und dann hab ich einfach, da war noch eine Lücke, hab ich mein Zelt hingestellt. Und als ich dann ins Bett gegangen bin, wusste ich, warum da die Lücke ist. Es war nämlich genau schräg gegenüber vom Generator. Und ich hatte auch keine Ohrproppis dabei und nix. Dann hat mir aber Clemens irgendwann diese Oropax-Weichohrproppis mitgebracht. Und die haben echt Ruhe gemacht. Also es war wirklich...
Da sollte man nicht auf Veranstaltungen ohne gehen, wenn es nur ansatzweise droht, dass es eine Belästigung geben könnte.
Also In-Ears helfen auch bei sowas, finde ich.
Ach, in-ear-Kopfhörer.
Die rutschen aber noch eine Weile, oder?
Ja, man muss sich dann gewöhnen. Also irgendwann tut es weh, ja. Dann war aber auf der BER-Bühne, war ja auch extrem gute Musik. Die ganze Nacht bis morgens um 5 Uhr, glaube ich, lief das. Und ich war dann irgendwann so müde. Man hatte dann irgendwann das Gefühl, man schläft auf der Tanzfläche. Und dann bin ich irgendwie nachts wach geworden und sagte, oh, geile Musik, ich bin auch so müde, aber geile Musik.
Ich hatte in der ersten Nacht tatsächlich die Apple in ihr Kopfhörer drin. Aber das tat dann schon arg weh. Also ich bin dann morgens um 6 Uhr aufgewacht, weil mir die Ohren unglaublich wehgefahren haben von den Dingern, das geht irgendwie gar nicht.
Eigentlich bräuchte man diese super weichen Oropax und dann passende Kopfhörer, die man da so reinsteckt.
Ja, es gibt ja...
Also zum reinstechen.
Als Kopfhörer sind die auch okay, aber halt nicht zum Schlafen, besonders wenn man so wie ich gerne auf der Seite schläft und dann drückt sich dieses Teil noch extra ins Ohr rein. Das war also extrem unangenehm.
Man kann sich ja Kopfhörer auch direkt an seine Ohrmuschel anpassen lassen.
Ich hab mir Ohrschutz machen lassen für Proberaum und so, weil diese, es gibt ja auch so zum Reinstopfen verschiedenste Formen, aber die sind halt immer, die fluppen raus und dann passt es halt nicht richtig.
Nein, diese Tannenbaum-Dinger gehen aber.
Ja, die gehen, aber wenn du mal schwitzt oder so im Sommer, dann flutschen die halt auch raus. Und da hab ich mir auch mal welche machen lassen. Und die sind eigentlich so, gegen einen geringen Aufpreis kannst du dir dann noch ein Loch da reinmachen lassen, dass du dir halt auch quasi Kopfhörer mit reinmachen kannst. Und es gibt zwar auch die richtig ganz tollen In-Ear-Monitore, die dann diesen Tropfen für dich noch anfertigen. Die kannst du dann bestimmt auch 169 oder 269 oder noch mehr für bezahlen. Aber ich glaube, du kannst schon unter 100 Euro einsteigen mit Kopfhörer.
Es funktioniert übrigens nicht mit jeder Gehörgangform. Also es gibt Leute, die haben massive Probleme damit, dass die Teile immer wieder rausfallen. Das ist aber irgendwie Ausnahme.
Ja, Ausnahme, wie es immer war. Also ich hab auf dem Camp tatsächlich mit Oropax gepennt, aber tatsächlich da hinten, ich war ja an der Grenze zum Family Village hinter so einer Hecke. Jetzt oute ich mich als Nicht-Family, da gepennt zu haben, aber das war so ein geiler, weicher Boden hinter der Hecke, unterm Baum. Soll ich heute schlafen? Und ich bin auch nicht so spät ins Bett irgendwie. Ich wollte mir einfach nicht die ganze Zeit die Kante da geben, weil ich ja auch noch andere Verpflichtungen hatte. Freak Show zum Beispiel. Und dann bin ich einfach immer früh ins Bett und bin total super aufgewacht.
Was ist denn für dich früh ins Bett?
Freak Show wurde es fünf und dann wurde es jeden Tag eine Stunde länger, bis auf den letzten, da konnte ich dann nicht mehr, da bin ich auch schon früh ins Bett gefallen. Aber es war richtig cool. Also dank BR Village endlich eine ordentliche Basisstation auf dem Camp, hatte ich ja sonst immer nicht. Da war das schon ganz geil. Früher waren die Berliner immer alle so verteilt und man hat seine Homies nicht gefunden, weil einer war da, einer war da, einer war da hinten arbeiten. Und deswegen wusste du nie, wo du nur irgendwie hingehst. Und jetzt mit BR war super.
Zum ersten Mal auf dem Camp, ja.
War das so, wie du gedachtest, dass es das ist?
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall bunter, als ich erhofft hatte.
Noch bunter als gedacht.
Ja, das ist schon unglaublich, was da an Energie und Aufwand reingesteckt wird, um da irgendwie den Abend zu erhellen. Also von der C-Base diesen Fernsehturm aufgebaut. Ich kann dir das mal vorstellen, den Fernsehturm aufgebaut. Das war richtig cool. Ganz toll fand ich ja, wenn man auf diese kleine Erhebung gelaufen ist, wo auch dieser Ausguck da war, und dann aufs Camp runtergeguckt hat. Und abends hat ja alles geblinkt. Und die Fahrt war wirklich super.
Das war früher aber auch anders. Früher, das erste Camp, da war Zelt und dann war relativ dunkel.
Jetzt kommt wieder der Erinnerungs-Battle, Tim versus Dennis.
Das ist eine der Grundlinien des Camps, es ist schönes Licht. Das hatten wir auf dem ersten Camp. Da gab es Linien, da gab es die Leuchtröhren.
Aber die Zelte waren alle dunkel. Aber jetzt hat ja jeder noch...
Ach so, die Leute, das selber, das meinst du.
Das hat sich geändert. Heute machen alle auch noch selber Licht. Diese Linien, von denen du redest, haben die Leute ausgemacht, weil die Diskokugel sonst nicht ordentlich leuchtet.
Auf dem ersten Camp gab es ja noch keine LEDs. LEDs gibt es erst seit 2000, erst seit zwölf Jahren, 13 Jahren. Das macht man sich gar nicht klar, dass die LED erst seit zehn Jahren ein Thema ist. Es gab nur eine Form von kleinen roten Lampen an Fernbedienungen. Aber nicht so, dass man Licht und kein Buntes machen kann.
Heutzutage ist jeder Reserveakku irgendwie auch eine Taschenlampe.
Ja, leider. Warum leuchtet das in meiner Tasche? Also war schön bunt, das stimmt.
Was ganz schön ist jetzt so langsam...
Der Fernsehturm war übrigens in Originalmaßstab 1 zu 42.
Und er hat auch noch in die richtige Richtung gedreht.
Ich hab mich immer gefragt, ob es die richtige Richtung war.
Ein bisschen flott, aber er hat gedreht.
Gegen den Uhrzeigersinn. Ich war mir nicht mehr sicher.
Da hatten wir ja jemanden ganz stolz von der Sea-Bank-Propert.
Also gegen den Uhrzeigersinn, wenn man von unten guckt, aber wenn man von oben guckt, dann stimmt's ja. Also mit dem Uhrzeigersinn.
Wann guckst du denn den Fernseh-Dunk von oben an?
Das abstrahiert mein Gehirn automatisch für mich, weil ich ja von unten gucke.
Guckst du dann von oben?
Weil du immer anders rumguckst.
Ich würde dann sagen, dass der in den Uhrzeigersinn dreht, weil ich ja eigentlich von unten gucke. Aber gut, der ist zu komplex für euch.
Warte mal, der hat sich doch, wenn man von oben guckt, hat er sich entgegen dem Uhrzeigersinn gedreht.
Auf jeden Fall hat ja einer von den Seabays gesagt, der würde sich so richtig drehen. Und wenn das ein Nerd von den Seabays sagt, der ein Antenne der fucking Fernsehturm ist, dann wird es wohl stimmen. Aber das ist halt Nerds, weißt du? Nicht glauben, was einem erzählt, sondern immer erst mal selber nachgucken. Jetzt zoomen wir auch noch ein Video raus, zum besten von dem Fernsehturm auf der Camp, um zu überprüfen, ob der sich wirklich in die richtige Richtung gedreht hat. Also wer hat den Wikipedia-Artikel offen?
Ich frag jetzt erst mal...
Info at Fernsehturm alexanderplatz.de Ich hab jetzt einfach mal den Google gefragt.
Wie rumdreht der Fernsehturm?
Genau. Mal gucken, wie weit das Internet so ist.
Aber aus welcher Sicht? Von oben oder von unten betrachtet?
Links drehende Zimtschnecke, wenn das der Fernsehturm ist. Ja, ist ja links drehend. Also von unten betrachtet links drehend, wenn man von oben guckt, im Uhrzeigersinn. Ach, ist mir auch egal, ich hab gewonnen.
Ich würde doch immer die Perspektive einnehmen, wenn ich in diesem Café sitze.
Aber ist denn links drehend nicht der Uhrzeigersinn?
Also ich würde auch sagen, wenn du in dem Café sitzt und dir das Uhrenblatt quasi flach als Querschnitt vorstellst, ja dann geht's halt in die Richtung gegen die Zeiger. Fertig, Bums, aus, Feier an.
Also wenn man drin sitzt, dreht man quasi...
Wenn man drin sitzt, guckt man ja von oben.
Was kommt zuerst? Erst kommt das rote Rad aus und als nächstes kommt das BCC.
BCC.
Also so war's auf jeden Fall. Ich war noch nie da oben, muss ich gestehen. Ich war da irgendwann da, aber... Ich bin noch kein Tourie, was soll ich auf dem Fernsehturm?
Freak Show, Team-Ausflug, Team-Bilder...
Hörvertreffen auf dem Fernsehturm.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Aber es steht nicht in der Wikipedia. Das Projekt kann im Prinzip auch eingestellt werden jetzt, oder? Es steht schon was von Drehen, aber nur, dass es 360 Grad ist.
Wahrscheinlich streiten die in die Wikipedia auch.
Vielleicht wechseln die ab und zu, um es richtig schwer zu machen.
Als ich ganz klein war, war ich auf einem Fernsehturm. Meine Mutter hat ihre Handtasche da quasi auf Fensterbrett gelegt, um dann festzustellen, hoch Handtasche weg, weil die sich wegrotiert hat. Und wenn ich mich recht in Sinne, dann in welche Richtung wir haben uns, genau, die Außenhöhle ist ja fest, und wir haben uns nach da bewegt. Und die Tasche war dann sozusagen hinter uns. Ja, doch, genau, so rum muss das schon sein.
Jetzt hat der Hörer voll gesehen, in welche Richtung, welche Richtung.
Ich hab mir das jetzt gerade nochmal vergegenwärtigt. Also, glaubt mir einfach. Nee, Gott, es muss doch im Internet stehen. Lieber Chat, jetzt.
Also am besten hätten wir Beweis, Video, weil Text sagt gar nichts, ne?
Ah ja, wir suchen dann noch ein Video aus dem Café, aus dem Fernsehturm.
Der braucht 20 Minuten für eine Umdrehung. Das ist relativ langsam.
Na ja, natürlich. Also die sind alle so langsam.
Ja, aushalt eins mit, wie sagt man, Zeitraffer, Full HD, 1080p, Rundfahrt im Café, Berliner Fernsehturm.
Gibt natürlich alles.
Kannst du es mal auf den Hauptschirm werfen.
Warte mal.
Der braucht drei Sekunden pro Grad.
Okay, jetzt wird es aber kritisch, weil ich glaube, es dreht sich nämlich genau andersrum.
Nee, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Doch.
Hat die C-Base gelogen?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht erinnere ich mich auch jetzt falsch.
Vielleicht ist das gespiegelt, das Video.
Das ist im Uhrzeigersinn.
Das ist im Uhrzeigersinn, wenn man von oben guckt.
Genau, wenn man oben drin sitzt.
Dann hat sich das aber auf dem Camp falsch rumgedreht, oder?
Wobei, ich meine, die haben ja die Außenkugel rutzieren lassen, ne? Und die, und wenn man das...
Achso, du meinst...
Wenn man hier quasi infix machen würde, dann würde sich die Außenkugel...
Stimmt, das hat sicherlich... Außen bewegt sich das ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Also, für die Betrachter innerhalb des maßstabsgetreuen Fernsehtums war alles richtig.
Ich glaub, wir kriegen das nicht aufgelöst.
Sagen wir einfach, es war richtig.
Der Münchner Fernsehtum dreht sich sogar außen. Also da drehen sich die Fenster tatsächlich mit. Ja, aber ich glaub nur ein Teil davon. Also, ja, der Fernsehturm hat gebrochen.
Wir hätten es uns natürlich auch leichter machen können. Das hätten wir aus dem Fenster geguckt.
Ja, die Kugel dreht sich ja von außen nicht.
Nein. Gar nicht? Genau. Du wolltest gerade erzählen, dass so schön beleuchtet war alles.
Die war hinter dem Pizzazelt. Das war so geil. Also da dieses Birkenwäldchen und dieses Diskokugelwäldchen, was ja so als Standardinstallation eigentlich schon etabliert hat.
War das, wo die irgendwann Musik damit gemacht haben? Genau, das hab ich nur gehört, aber ich war nicht vor Ort, aber man hat's gehört.
Ja, ich war dann nämlich da auch so in diesen Wäldchen, hab so geguckt und dann plötzlich hört man so Bratzeln und so weiter. Und dann, ja, da doch. Weil ich hab, als wir die Freak Show gemacht haben, da war dieser Vortrag, Tesla-Spule zu, mit Tesla-Spule Musik machen, oder Make Tesla Calls More Musical.
Also hier gibt's irgendwelche Videos, ich find grad nix vom Camp, aber hier gibt's irgendwie singende Tesla-Spule schon, vom 26C3.
Ja, der hat halt, ähm... Äh, was... Ja, der hat, aber genau, jetzt kommt der Knaller, ja, kommt der noch. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt's das auch schon vorher, aber...
Ja, guck mal.
Das war einfach großartig. Äh, und da gab's halt auf jeden Fall einen Vortrag.
Also das ist nicht wirklich neu.
Nee, nee, also es gab das schon vorher. Also was der ja erzählt halt in dem Vortrag war, dass er halt ein MIDI-Interface dazu gebaut hat, was man in Ableton halt als Musikinstrument benutzen kann. Und der hat halt auch dann Polyfone-Songs gespielt. Also es klang zumindest Polyfone, ja. Und das weiß ich nicht, weil da stand jetzt überall Single-Voice. Auf jeden Fall hatte der da so Songs dabei. Das klang einfach wirklich extrem fett. Und als besonderes Bonbon an einem Abend hatte er dann halt auch so tatsächlich ein MIDI-Keyboard angeschlossen und hat dann so gemeint, so alle Leute, die jetzt mal was spielen wollen, bitte mal ransetzen und dann konnte man live auf der Tesla-Spur spielen.
Hier ist der Vortrag, den hab ich jetzt hier gerade.
Ach, er hatte dann doch einen.
Genau.
Wo ist die Demo? Das ist ja nicht so geil, aber... Ja, die Polyphonen, die waren wirklich die Knaller.
Da passiert ja noch was hier.
Ich hab den Vortrag nicht gesehen, da war grad Freak-Show.
Ja, du hast schuld, dass wir den nicht sehen konnten.
Aber das Schöne war halt, dann hat er auch zum Beispiel einmal das Pink Panther-Themen gespielt und das Saxophon klang einfach so großartig. Also ich hab ein paar Videos auf meinem Telefon, aber die sind natürlich nicht so tolle Qualität. Und dann noch das besondere Highlight war, irgendwie waren auch Arbeitskollege von mir da, oder Arbeitskollegen, und der eine hatte dann auch Frau und sein kleines Kind mit dabei. Und die Kleine, die ist sowieso, die wird so ein Hardcore-Nerd, die hat irgendwie schon, die ist drei Jahre oder so, und hat immer so geile Fragen gestellt und auch nicht sich mit einfachen so Kinderantworten oder so zufrieden gegeben. Und da waren wir dann gerade nachts, sie waren dann kurz vorm Gehen, um so 22 Uhr, dann sind wir an der Tesserspule vorbei, und das kleine Mädel steht dann auch so da so, wow, was denn da, ne? Und dann, die steht halt total auf dem Imperators-March, oder das Imperial-March. Und dann, genau, als sie da so hingeführt wird von Papa und Mama, spielen die halt genau das auf der Tesserspule, das kleine Mädchen steht da so, wow, das war echt super. Das war auf jeden Fall eine der cooleren Installationen, die hätte ruhig noch ein bisschen mehr Center Stage verdient gehabt. Vor allen Dingen, als die Leute dann mal anfingen zu spielen, ein paar Nerds konnten natürlich auch richtig gut Klavier spielen, und dann haben die da so voll in die Tasten gehauen und irgendwas Klassisches gespielt auf der Tesserspule.
Das Fussballspiel fand ich auch sehr schön. Habt ihr das Fussballspiel gesehen?
Nur Video-Stream.
Welches Fussballspiel?
Na das Roboter-Fussballspiel. Das war so geil, weil die Leute sind echt abgegangen, jedes Mal wenn ein Tor fiel.
Fielen den viele?
Na es geht so, aber es war auch relativ kurz das Spiel. Also so ich sag mal so in einer Viertelstunde vielleicht drei, vier Tore oder so. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Das war für ein normales Fussballspiel schon eine ganze Menge.
Ja, das Ding war, dass der Boden von dem Zelt war nicht richtig gerade und in der Mitte von dem Zelt sind die. Die haben sich die Roboter immer lang gemacht. Und dann waren sie ganz verwirrt. Wo sind sie denn jetzt und so.
Was ich auch insgesamt sehr schön fand, war so wie der Ziegelei-Park genutzt wurde, um Installation zu machen. Also die ganzen Gebäude, die irgendwie angeleuchtet worden sind und die ganzen Geräte und Fahrzeuge da rum standen, die dann entsprechend angeleuchtet wurden und dann oben dieser Kran, der dann auch so eine Lichterkette bekam, der dann abends so aussah, als würde er wieder baggern und so. Das fand ich schon.
Und natürlich der Party-Zug.
Der Party-Train.
Der Party-Train, der meint Gleistes.
Ah ja. Train-Qualizer. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, hatten wir das irgendwie schon in der Sendung? Wie fand's denn die Sendung eigentlich?
Das Camp insgesamt fand ich ganz gut.
Wäre ich jetzt die Freak Show Sendung oder was? Ja. Ja, diese Live-Events, das ist doch nur für das Publikum so zum Hey, ich seh sie jetzt mal live.
Ist doch schön.
Aber da kommt ja nie so ein richtiger Sendungsflow auf. Du bist ja schon im Publikum quasi in der Situation mehr gefangen. Als jetzt hier, weißt du, wir sitzen hier in Unterhose, Pulle Bier auf den Tisch, irgendwie Popel in der Nase.
Kannst du auch alles auf der Bühne haben.
Ja, aber da traut man sich ja nicht.
Wieso? Ich hab immerhin ein Bier mit einem Notebook aufgemacht.
Das war aber auch schon radikalste, was man raus hat.
Okay, zugegebenermaßen, das war eine Afrikola und kein Bier.
Immerhin hat's nur eine Afrikola.
Die hatte Clemens. Echt?
Das fehlt, der Pizza fehlt.
Doch, Bier gab's. Da kam einer an kurz vor der Sendung.
Ach so, auf dem Dings.
Oder wenigstens ein Eis.
Hab ich nicht drüber nachgedacht, hätte man im Prinzip bestellen müssen. Aber ich wusste ja nicht, ob ihr schon gegessen habt.
Aber wir essen ja auch immer vor der Sendung.
Ja, eben.
Und nicht während.
Ja, das wäre auch nicht so gut gekommen.
Deswegen hab ich den Frühstücks-Podcast auch erledigt, den du mal vorhattest.
Bitte?
Du hattest doch mal so einen Frühstücks-Podcast vor. Kannst du dich erinnern? Irgendwie am Kollwitzplatz in so einem Laden, der so ein erhöhtes Ding ins Daht hat. Hast du mal irgendwann erzählt?
Ja, das ist schon ein sehr altes Konzert.
Aber dann ist dir eingefallen, dass Schmatzen im Podcast keine gute Idee ist.
Ja, das war jetzt nicht der Hauptgrund, dass das nichts geworden ist. Aber war das ein Aspekt, über den ich nachgedacht habe?
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Und dann hast du lieber NSFW gemacht.
Ich habe noch viel mehr Ideen für irgendwelche Formate gehabt. Ich glaube, ich habe mehr Formate verworfen als umgesetzt.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz würde ich definitiv sagen. Dass das die besten und schlechtesten Freak-Show-Episoden zusammengruppieren müsste. Dann wären schon die Live-Shows auch die vom Kongress. Das hat zwar Spaß gemacht und ist ganz lustig mit Publikum, aber zum Nachhören bestimmt nicht die allertollste Sendung.
Ja, ich glaube, dass es ein komplett anderes Format ist, wenn man auf der Bühne ist. Das ist nicht vergleichbar mit dem, was wir hier machen. Und wenn man das einmal verstanden und akzeptiert hat, dann wird aus der Live-Show auch wieder was anderes.
Ja, ich finde das einfach auch viel geiler, wenn man das mit den ganzen Leuten zusammen macht. Da ist einfach auch eine ganz andere Stimmung. Ich meine mal, auf den Camps am zweiten Tag sind alle schon auf der Gratwanderung. Und dann ist es einfach so lustig aus der Situation heraus.
Ja, ich sage ja auch nicht, dass das an sich jetzt ein Fehler wäre.
Ich habe zum Beispiel einen Tag vorher ein Logbuch Netzpolitik Live gemacht. Und das ist dann irgendwie auch so eine inhaltsschwere Sendung geworden, was ich dann wiederum gar nicht so passend fand. Die ist zwar jetzt zum Nachhören als Podcast dann verhältnismäßig solide, aber so in dem Moment, weil da ist ja dein Video dabei. Du schaust es dir an, also nicht jetzt Video im Sinne von der Aufzeichnung, sondern Video im Sinne von wo du es betrachtest. Und da kannst du das halt einfach nicht so lange verfolgen. Das ist ja genau das gleiche Ding, warum man eben so Audio-Podcasts stundenweise wegschaufeln kann. Aber wenn du das halt jetzt auf YouTube schaust, dann schaust du dir nichts vier Stunden lang am Stück an.
Gibt es von unserem Video hier auch bei der Freak Show?
Ja, doch, doch.
Wo ist denn das verlinkt?
Auf Freak Show FM.
Ah, da, weiter runter scrollen.
Ja, scrollen Sie einfach weiter.
Bitte weiter scrollen.
Bitte weiter scrollen, hier ist nichts geschehen.
Ja, das ist schon was anderes, aber vielleicht ist es auch so ein bisschen wie so eine Silvester-Party, wo man sagt, das muss jetzt die allergeilste Party des Jahres werden. Und dann ist das so mit Erwartungen überladen, dass man die wohl dann kaum erfüllen kann.
Ach, naja, ich hab mir einfach, also, ne, also...
Also wir können ja sicherlich noch ein bisschen üben, aber ich hab ja einen Tag später...
Das war auf jeden Fall eine der fetzigeren Sendungen.
Ich weiß, wie ich mich vorbereite. Ich weiß, wie ich mich auf dem Kongress vorbereiten werde. Zwei Margeritas vorher, einen währenddessen.
Einen Margerita während des Kongresses.
Zwei davor der Sendung und einen währenddessen.
Ja, Alkohol ist auf jeden Fall ganz passabel.
Apropos Alkohol, das war übrigens auch ein sehr schöner F-Nord, als du hier die betrunken Filter previously Action gemacht hast und die Stimmen so variiert hast, dass... dass Roddy... das war echt cool.
Ja, das war glaube ich einfach nur ein Drittel langsamer abgespielt.
Echt?
Einfach völlig betrunken.
War auch halt so schön subtil irgendwie, weil es war so, naja, es ist schon Roddy, aber irgendwie... Was Stanktier was erzählt hat.
Ja, ist der Ruf erst ruiniert.
Um nochmal auf die Tesla-Spulen zurückzukommen. Es gab ja dann auch noch die große Tesla-Performance auf dem Camp. Nämlich mit dem Gewitter. Ja, hatten ja einen Gewitter. Was zwar ganz interessant war, aber leider einen Podcast getötet hat. Ich weiß nicht, nicht unseren, aber...
Ach, die haben es auch gar nicht mehr nachgeholt?
Nee.
Echt nicht?
Die haben am nächsten Tag noch ihren Flüssig-Stickstoff verbraucht.
Also kurz zu den Hintergründen, methodisch inkorrekt, sollte am letzten Tag noch live auf die Bühne kommen. Und ja, das lief dann, glaube ich, eine Minute oder zwei.
Nein, nein, nicht mal zehn Sekunden. Sie haben gerade das Intro angefangen, das fand ich so schade, weil die haben ja auf dem Kongress ihre erste Live-Show gemacht. Das war ja der absolute Knaller. Und haben sich eigentlich schon das gesamte Jahr darauf gefreut, wir fahren aufs Camp, da können wir richtig mit Explosionen machen und keinen Brandschutz und so. Die ganze Bühne war vollgestellt mit irgendwelchen Koffern, wo irgendwelche Experimente drin waren. Und haben sich auch noch flüssigen Steckstoff liefern lassen, am Samstag oder so Sachen, die man nicht haben darf. Und ja, dann ging es ja los. Irgendwie die Gewitterwolke kam und alle sagten, das sieht nicht gut aus und alle die ganze Zeit auf dem Regenradar. Na ja, wird schon an uns vorbei. Ne, sind da lauter Seen um uns rum. Die werden die Wolken schon abhalten. Und dann ging es los, 10 Sekunden, wirklich?
Und dann fiel der Strom aus.
Und dann fiel der Strom aus, alles dunkel.
Das ist jetzt so bitter.
Wirklich, das hat mir so leid getan.
Ja, mir auch.
Es war dann auch nicht wiederholbar, weil dieser Montag auch gefühlt gar kein richtiger Veranstaltungstag mehr war. Da sind alle nur noch aufgewacht und sind dann früher oder später von dieser Abbaupanik, die dann ausbrach, eingeholt worden, weil das Camp so enorm schnell abgebaut werden musste. Das hast du ja dann auch noch befeuert da bei deiner Abschlussveranstaltung.
Und jetzt müsst ihr auch noch alle eure Stühle zu Sankhya.
Das wurde uns dreimal vorher gesagt. Das ganz normale Chaos, dann kommen wir zu dem Punkt rein. Wer hat euch das denn erzählt? Fragt euch, woher kommt diese Idee?
Ein bisschen unglücklich, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt, als der Camptermin festgelegt wurde, gab es schon so viele Rahmenveranstaltungen, die schon länger gebucht hatten, sowohl jetzt auf dem Gelände, als eben auch um unsere Veranstaltung herum, an anderen Orten, wo eben die Ressourcen benutzt wurden, die wir brauchten, Zelte vor allem. Aber auch Hands, also spezielle Leute, die auf anderen Veranstaltungen schon eingeplant waren und die wir unbedingt brauchten. Und deswegen ging halt nur dieser eine schräge Termin mit diesem überlappenden Montag. Ein Tag früher wär nicht gegangen, ein Tag später wär alles nicht gegangen, hätte mit dem Aufbau nicht hingehauen, etc., Naja, nun war's so, wie's war und so war's.
Zum Aufräumen gibt's ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Fälschung ist oder nicht, es gibt ja dieses Bild, wie sieht das Geländer aus nach dem Camp und wie sieht das Geländer aus nach dem Wacken?
Ja, das war nicht Wacken, sondern das war das Sonder-...
Stand Wacken da.
Achso, dann gab's auch noch mal Wacken, ja, es gab auch noch mal ein anderes.
Obwohl das noch ein relativ ordentliches Wackenbild war.
Aber lass den ja am Ende erklären, sonst wüssten die Leute, die das nicht gesehen haben, gar nicht, was es war.
Ich kann's ja mal in den Chat pasten. Also da ist irgendwie, ja, Wacken sieht aus als...
Das Bild war doch ein Fake, sagt dir gleich einer.
Ja, wahrscheinlich kommt es einem sehr fakeig vor, aber...
Zeig mal das Bild.
Oben ist das Wacken.
Also...
Und unten ist das Camp. Ein Datenklo auf einer sauber geputzten Wiese.
Wo ist denn das?
Ja, wo ist denn das?
Das ist doch... So sauber das ist. Das ist ein Bleipark. Das kann sein, dass das hinten dieser Karawahn-Bereich außerhalb des Geländes.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist an dieser Zufahrtstraße.
Aber es sah trotzdem ganz schön sauber aus, als ich ab Dienstagabend abgefahren bin.
Da war es. Aber das war ja auch nur ein Gelände, wo die nur standen und von da weg zum Hauptgelände gegangen sind. Das ist nicht der Ort, wo jetzt alle rüber marschiert sind. Aber stimmt schon. Es war natürlich viel abgewetzter alles, aber es war nicht dreckig.
Ich muss noch was beichten. Da gibt es bestimmt eventuell Eltern, die keinen Spaß hatten an Dienstagabend. Weil als ich abgefahren bin, da kamen mir so zwei Kids entgegen. Und denen habe ich erzählt, dass wir beim Aufräumen, da haben wir noch so eine 1 Liter Flasche Jim Beam übrig gehabt, wo noch so ein Viertel drin war. Und den beiden Kids habe ich gesagt, Jungs, da auf so einer Tonne, da steht noch eine Flasche Whisky, da ist noch was drin. Meine Fresse war nicht schnell. Und dann sind die dahin und ich weiß nicht, was die damit gemacht haben. Also wenn da zwei Kids ziemlich besoffen waren, dann tut mir so ein bisschen leid. Aber nur ein bisschen?
Aber nur ein bisschen.
Ich mach mir da mal eine Kapitelmark.
Jugendschutz steht gleich vor der Tür. Aber dieser Sturm, auf jeden Fall, der war auch echt ein witziges Highlight.
Genau, es hat ja dann auch noch richtig eingeblitzt, also vor und hinter oder vielleicht auch auf dem Gelände. So genau, weiß das glaube ich keiner.
Einmal hat es ziemlich nah.
Es hat wohl den LTE-Turm von der Telekom getroffen.
Ach echt?
Angeblich.
Ich glaube, wenn ich neben dem saß.
Ich war dort, ich war im Hinterzimmer, das ist ja da vorne, wo die Kasse ist, und wir standen da schon die ganze Zeit und war auch trocken. Ich stand ja unter den Raum und da war diese Unterdachung auf der anderen Seite, wo die Leute sich alle drunter gestellt haben. Also, wer da was eingeschlagen hat, das hätte ich nicht bekommen.
Ja, und da ist ja auch ein Schornstein direkt daneben.
Ich glaube, der Telekom-Turm war schon höher als dieser Schornstein, oder zumindest gleich hoch. Und wenn dann auch besser geerdet das Telekom-Ding, würde ich mal behaupten als diese Steine da oben. Aber da hat nichts eingeschlagen.
Das ist ja bestimmt. Vor allen Dingen haben die wahrscheinlich einfach das Ding ausgemacht. Dann haben alle Leute gedacht, oh, LTE ist aus. Hat bestimmt die Telekom getroffen. Aber wir haben die das wahrscheinlich einfach pro forma ausgemacht und hinterher wieder angeschaltet.
Das war ganz lustig. Wir waren in unserem Muckel-Village. Da in diesem... Wie heißt das? Pavilion? Ich nenne die immer Zeltling. Diese Teile, die im Herbst nach Süden fliegen. Also diese viereckigen. Und da prasselte natürlich der gemeine Garten-Zeltling. Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Einfach diese weißen Pavillons, diese Pillow...
Die sind dann nicht richtig festgemacht.
Und wenn dann die ersten Winde kommen, dann werden die Dinge einfach entsorgt.
Ich hab mir auch dieses tolle Bild in die Abschlussveranstaltung eingefallen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir standen unter dem Ding und da prasselte der Regen rauf, dass es halt relativ laut war. Und dann kam da einer an, so ein Engel, und... Wir haben ihn nicht verstanden.
Ja, die Evakuierung, die war etwas...
Und da gab er frustriert auf und ging wieder.
Ich saß halt unter so einem schönen Chill-Zelt mit musikalischer Bespielung. Und dann hat er da auch gerade so eine wirklich sehr entspannte Dame aufgelegt und dann meinte ich so zu ihr, jetzt wäre doch eigentlich Riders on the Storm irgendwie total super. Und dann meinte sie, ja, wollte ich auch grad spielen. Und dann hat sie das so aufgelegt und die Disco-Kugel drehte sich langsam und die schwarzen Wolken kamen hinter dem Gebäude und es fing an zu regnen und zu gewittern. Und währenddessen lief das Intro von diesem Song und alle saßen da total situationsverliebt mit ihren Tütchen in der Hand.
Die Engel haben einfach nur versucht, da umzusetzen, was noch umzusetzen war. Letztlich muss man feststellen, dass dieser ganze Evakuierungsplan etwas zu spät gestartet worden ist. Warum, weiß ich nicht. Aber das war auf jeden Fall nicht falsch, das zu tun.
Ich war da gerade im Zert kurz vorher tatsächlich. Und da war gerade der Power-Mensch und so. Und die haben sich da gerade darüber beraten, in wie vielen Minuten sie das machen wollen. Und dann hieß es halt so, wir warten jetzt bis die Einschläge so und so viele Kilometer weg waren. Aber ich glaube, das kam einfach viel schneller, als das Radar es hätte erscheinen lassen. Also die waren glaube ich selber so ein bisschen überrascht, dass das dann doch recht flott ankam.
Genau. Also es ist einfach etwas unterschätzt worden. Und dann gab es halt noch die Entscheidung, den Strom wirklich dann zu kappen. Und dadurch wurde dann halt auch alles runtergefahren. Das war dann der totale Härtetest.
Das fand ich aber spannend.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen war doch noch eine Stunde vorbei.
Ja, dass sie relativ schnell dann auch die Generatoren ausgemacht haben, alles entkabelt. Und dann war es vorbei und dann dauerte es aber irgendwie auch nur Minuten, dann war alles wieder angesteckt, Generatoren fuhren hoch, alles war wieder bunt.
Und dann dachtest du, eine Stunde war schon dunkel.
Ja, es war schon eine Weile dunkel, aber als die Entscheidung kam, jetzt ist es vorbei, jetzt machen wir wieder an, da war dann so...
Man hat mal so gehört, wo gerade WLAN wieder verfügbar war, indem Leute irgendwo auf dem Campus dann immer gesagt haben, ich hab Netz!
Und das Beste war danach, als das Gelände so ein bisschen geflutet war, hat doch tatsächlich immer so eine Multisteckdose in eine Pfütze reingelegt und einen Scheinwerfer dran und dann ist man da so vorbeigegangen und die Nerds standen mit ansprechend Respekt von dieser Steckdose, dieser in der Pfütze qualmte und dann haben die auch so ganz bedenkliches Gesicht gemacht und dann irgendwie nach fünf Minuten kam ein Nerd daraus und hat neues Trockeneis in die Pfütze gelegt, weil das natürlich nicht eingesteckt war und es einfach nur so ein kleiner Fnord war, um die Leute zu schocken.
Ah, die Steckdose!
Ja, wir haben eine Weile diskutiert, ob es jetzt echt ist oder nicht.
Naja, also wer es noch nicht verstanden hat, Chemt war schön. Chemt war schön und wer auch immer der Meinung war, er würde da nicht hinpassen, würde da nicht angenommen werden oder so eine Ausrede wie Zelten ist ja nicht so meins, wäre irgendwie cool.
Und ich habe ja jetzt tatsächlich auch, also ich spreche ja schon öfters mal vor Leuten, aber bisher waren es maximal so 200 oder 300 und diesmal durfte ich ja mit der 400 gleich vor. Weiß nicht, wie viel es hält.
1200 passt da glaube ich schon.
1200, das war auch auf jeden Fall mal eine neue Bestmarke. Und?
Fühlt sich aber eigentlich auch nicht anders an, oder?
Nein, tatsächlich dachte ich, es wäre ein Unterschied, aber es ist gar nicht so groß.
Hast du auch Scheinwerfer im Gesicht und hast die alle gar nicht mehr gesehen?
Nö, doch, man sieht die schon noch, aber...
Ja, aber das skaliert eigentlich smooth. Also wenn man überhaupt erstmal Ansprache hinkriegt, dann ist eigentlich die Zahl der Leute ziemlich egal. Man darf sich da bloß nicht Kürre von machen, weil im Prinzip bist du auch nicht anders dadurch.
Also das ist eigentlich immer dasselbe.
Ja, das ist eher einfacher noch, weil es wird immer anonymer, die Masse.
Ja, sag mal, es hat eigentlich sehr viel mehr damit zu tun, dass du verstehst, wer vor dir sitzt. Und da glaube ich, musstest du dir jetzt eh keine Sorgen machen.
Ja, aber einerseits war das schon, also, sagen wir mal, bei einer Konferenz, wo ich keinen kenne, und wenn ich da irgendwelchen Stusslaber, ist mir das halt wurscht, weil...
Ja gut, aber wenn du versuchst, die zum Lachen zu bringen, dann hast du natürlich bei einer Konferenz, wo du nicht weißt, wie die so drauf sind, und machst dann irgendwie deinen ersten Politwitz und alle kucken dich so an mit so einem KKK-Gesicht. Da ist das dann natürlich dann so... In der Homebase dann doch viel einfacher. Und du wusstest ja auch, wie sie nehmen mussten, dein Bild hier mit dem Thunderstorm vom Camp irgendwie.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es halt... Also gerade weil es im CCC gibt es ja schon auch... Also es ist ja immer sehr viel Schicht. Es gibt ja auch so eine immer verschiedene Fraktion der Bedenkenträger. Es gibt nicht nur eine Fraktion. Und vor allen Dingen jedes Thema wird auch... Und das ist ja sowieso eigentlich der Grund, warum ich im CCC das so Mindset eigentlich ganz cool fand, weil irgendwie jeder so einen anderen Blick auf die Welt hat und die Blicke auf die Welt sind aber ineinander auch teilweise komplett unterschiedlich oder auch gegensätzlich. Und auch wenn so ein Thema besprochen wird, egal was es ist im CCC, Mailingliste auf intern gibt es beliebig viele Beispiele, dann hat man so seine eigene Meinung, dann gibt es so Leute, die sind links und rechts so ein bisschen daneben. Und dann gibt es aber auch immer wieder so Meinungen, die einfach so komplett aus einer anderen Richtung kommen, wo ich aber auch oft denke, ja, okay, so habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen. Und deswegen jetzt zum Beispiel vor so einer CCC-Masse zu sprechen, da war eigentlich so mein Hintergedanke, ja, okay, ich weiß schon, dass es da einige Leute gibt, da weiß ich schon, wie ich den Nerv treffe, aber ob das jetzt für die ganze In-Homogen, am wenigsten das Gegenteil von Homogen, In-Homogen, Interogen. Also ob ich da sozusagen auch für die anderen, die ich nicht kenne, den Nerv treffe, das war eigentlich quasi da eher noch der Bedenken oder habe ich so als Hintergedanken immer gehabt noch so. Hat mich nicht jetzt gestört oder hat irgendwas verändert, aber zumindest dieser kleinen Vorbühnen-Aufregung, die man doch immer noch ein bisschen hat.
Und denkst du, das sollte jetzt so Wanderpokal bleiben, dass wir jetzt sozusagen für jede CCC-Veranstaltung ein Hacker-Pärchen des Jahres finden, was sozusagen die Eröffnung macht?
So die Weinkönigin und den...
Weinkönig Huckel.
Hackerkönig.
Also auf jeden Fall, ich muss sagen, bei den meisten CCC-Veranstaltungen war ich eigentlich auch in letzter Zeit besonders nicht so wahnsinnig happy mit den Abschluss- oder auch teilweise mit den Eröffnungsveranstaltungen. Es lag auch teilweise daran, dass die Leute halt selber sehr in der Orga von der ganzen Veranstaltung schon involviert waren und auch teilweise hatte ich so das Gefühl, dass ich schon ein bisschen mit ausgebrannt war und dann am Ende der Veranstaltung auch irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig den, weiß nicht, irgendwie kam so für mich immer nicht so die Stimmung oder der Vibe der Veranstaltung dann am Ende eigentlich wirklich rüber. Und das war auf jeden Fall mal, glaube auch bei Fiona, schon so die Motivation, da jetzt mal so ein bisschen vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr lächeln und Schwung da reinzugehen. Und weiß nicht, ob es jetzt nur daran liegt, dass zum Beispiel bei den letzten Veranstaltungen die Leute auch selber involviert waren und schon auch auf dem letzten Akku da noch saßen oder so.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es was mit Akku zu tun hat.
Weil...
Also ich meine, ich war jetzt nur Teilnehmer. Ich habe ja sonst quasi nicht an der Orga mitgewirkt. Und bei vorigen Veranstaltungen habe ich auch zum Beispiel ein Kassensystem gehabt oder was auch immer. Und war dann auch total durch.
Das machst du gar nichts gemacht.
Na zumindest war ich da ganz unbefangen. Es ist ja auch immer so bei so einem Veranstaltungen, das ist alles ehrenamtlich und so weiter. Die Leute investieren da viel Herzblut und dann klappen halt teilweise Sachen nicht. Dann gibt es auch schon zwischendurch ja auch öfters so viele Enttäuschungen oder Frust und so. Das löst sich zwar dann während der Veranstaltung auch wieder auf, aber irgendwie kriegt man das ja schon immer wieder mit, dass wenn irgendwas chaotisches abläuft und so weiter, dann das nicht ideal ist. Und wenn man da dann in so einer Situation, zum Beispiel, jetzt wäre es jetzt ein total theoretisches Beispiel, dann kriegst du vielleicht auch jetzt nicht mehr so den ganzen Schwung dann noch auf die Bühne. Und sagst du, ja, geile Veranstaltung, wenn jetzt gerade zum Beispiel angenommen die Leute, die diesen tollen Podcast da vorbereitet haben, ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr. Und dann irgendwie kurz vorher ist da eine ganze Show, macht so puff und du bist einfach, hast einfach so den mega Propfen sitzen. Also das jetzt mal so als ein konstruiertes Beispiel. Und ich glaube, zumindest geschadet hat es jetzt nicht. Also ich meine, Fiona hat ja noch einen Talk gehabt, aber wir waren jetzt beide nicht in der Orga der Veranstaltung mit den allen Abhängigkeiten und Verantwortung sozusagen involviert. Und das ist bestimmt nicht schlecht, aber ja. Auf jeden Fall kann auch gerne ein neues Pärchen sein, aber ich würde auf jeden Fall auch gucken, dass man da Leute nimmt, die nah dran sind, aber auch nicht zu involviert, dass man da einen schön lockeren Blick hat.
Es ist interessant, dass du das sagst. Ich habe ja mehrere Jahre hintereinander diese Eröffnung gemacht. Und erst als ich nicht mehr involviert war, aber dann trotzdem noch mal gefragt wurde, die Eröffnung zu machen, ging mir das dann irgendwie gegen den Strich.
Na gut, das hat aber dann wiederum andere Hintergründe vermutlich auch.
Nee, das war einfach, weil ich nicht mehr so am Ball, ich konnte nicht mehr so gut fühlen, was lief, was schwer war an der Veranstaltung, was relevant war, welche Gruppe sich besonders eingebracht hat, was wichtig ist, dass man es erwähnt, betont im Vorfeld, wo man auch noch über selbst gar keinen Überblick hatte, was es an coolen Sachen neu gibt. Klar, du kannst ja irgendwelche Listen machen, die das von anderen Leuten aufschreiben lassen, aber dann fehlt dann halt was. Oder du kriegst einfach die Bedeutung nicht in die richtige Reihenfolge. Und das ist so der Moment, wo mir das so mental so ein bisschen entglitten ist. Wo ich dann auch danach gesagt habe, so jetzt mach ich das aber auch nicht mehr, weil das, gut, vielleicht geht es nur mir so. Also ich kann das besser machen.
Du hast ja auf jeden Fall noch eine andere Vorgeschichte. Ich meine, wir haben ja, also Fiona und ich, haben ja zumindest die Tage davor irgendwie die ganzen Leute mal so beschnackt und befragt und so weiter. Also war jetzt nicht so, dass wir da komplett irgendwie...
Ja, nee, klar, das muss man auch machen. Und mir gefällt es aber auf jeden Fall, dass das jetzt immer zwei machen und dass da immer eine Frau dabei ist, das ist einfach total wichtig, weil sonst wird das ja von vornherein schon alles wieder verzerrt.
Das war übrigens auch ein Nummer-1-Kommentar von den Kollegen. Das war ja auch so meine Geschichte. Letztes Jahr, äh, letztes Camp, allen Kollegen, da war ich gerade neu in der Firma, hab denen gesagt, ja, ja, hier, Camp, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch. Und dann, ja, da hatte ich jetzt noch nicht so die Trust Base, dass die dann mir das alles so einfach von den Lippen abgelesen haben und mitgekommen sind. Dann, der Klassiker, hinterher die ganzen Fotos gepostet. Und dann so, ja, boah, ja, geil, ich will auch. Wann ist das wieder? Und dann, vier Jahre. Und dieses Jahr haben sie sich aber wirklich nicht lange bitten lassen. Da hab ich den Link gepostet und dann haben sich alle da, Firma hat's ja auch bezahlt, Tickets geklickt. Und dann kam auch tatsächlich so, erstens, irgendwie, genau, Kollegen meinten auch, ja, krass bunt. Ein Kollege meinte, okay, hier sind ja doch erstaunlich viele Frauen tatsächlich. Also er hat jetzt auch mit so einer reinen Stinken-Nerd-Veranstaltung gerechnet eigentlich. Und was war das dritte? Essen wurde auf jeden Fall auch immer hochgelobt und diese ganze selbst organisierte Wahnsinn. Weil ich glaube, einige haben auch erwartet, dass halt so von der Veranstaltung selbst der Hauptteil kommt und haben irgendwie komplett unterschätzt, was sozusagen von den Teilnehmern noch sozusagen auf die Veranstaltung gebracht wird. Das war ja auch im Vergleich zum letzten Camp-Gefühl auch noch mal eine Steigerung, was so an Workshops ging, diese selbst organisierten Küchen. Da gab es ja vier oder fünf so eine Zelte, die haben einen Essenswahnsinn abgefeiert. Das war ja überhaupt nicht mehr zu beschreiben. Und auch so installationstechnisch und so. Also überall war was am Britzeln und am Bratzeln. Auch was hier an 3D-Druckern, Laser-Cuttern und so zum Selber basteln und bauen da noch aufgefahren wurde. Das hat die Kollegen auf jeden Fall auch ganz gut so beeindruckt.
Dieser eine 3D-Drucker, der so gefühlt einen Kubikmeter drucken konnte. Da guckst du so ins Zelt und denkst dir so, äh?
Wo stand der?
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Irgendwo auf dem Camp. Du gehst halt so am Zelt vorbei, hältst inne, gehst drei Schritte zurück, guckst links im Zelt und denkst dir, das ist jetzt nicht wahr, oder?
Das ganze Zelt war ein 3D-Drucker?
Nee, der 3D-Drucker, der war halt so mannsgroß. Damit konntest du halt so einen Kubikmeter bedrucken. Also hatte ich so das Gefühl. Keine Ahnung, wo der jetzt genau war und wie, aber irgendwie so.
Ich glaub, der war irgendwo in der Nähe von der Sea-Base.
Ja, irgendwie. Also, ja, ich nehm zum Zelten meinen 3D-Drucker mit.
Na, aber es war ganz cool in der Firma, unser Finance-Team eigentlich sagen dir ja nichts, aber also ich lass auch den Kongress eigentlich immer von der Firma bezahlen und versuch dann auch meistens schon immer ein Business-Ticket zu klicken. Aber irgendwie diesmal wollte ich halt auch, hab ich das 450-Euro-Ticket da klicken lassen, dann hat sie auf die Webseite halt geguckt und hat mich nochmal angeschrieben, aber es gibt ja schon auch Tickets, die günstiger sind. Aber auch nur zu ihr, der CCC ist quasi mein Informatikstudium. Alles, was ich hier zur Anwendung bringe, kommt zu 99% aus diesem Verein und den Veranstaltungen. Deswegen ist das quasi meine Studiengebühr nachträglicher Art. Und dann meine ich so, okay, gute Ansage. Hat sie nichts weiter gesagt.
Ja, das wars, das Camp 2015. Nächste Haltestelle 32C3.
War das das letzte Mal CCCH?
Wer jetzt die Glocken noch nicht gehört hat, dem können wir auch nicht groß helfen.
Zum Indoor-Camp dann.
Und die Leute müssen mal davon runterkommen. Das ist kein Veranstalt, wo man wegen der Vorträge hingeht. Vorträge, wenn man gerade nichts zu tun hat, dann kann man zum Vortrag gehen. Ansonsten Party, Party, Party.
Beim Camp oder was?
Im Kongress meistens.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich bei den letzten zwei Kongressen auch eigentlich keine Vorträge mehr gehört hab.
Die trotzdem alle voll sind. Es gibt halt solche und solche.
Manche haben halt nichts zu tun, die wissen ja nicht, wie man was macht.
Also, ich hab...
Nicht ganz, aber es ist keine trockene Angelegenheit.
Nein, das auf keinen Fall.
Ich hab auch eine Zeit lang im BCC mal bestimmt zwei, drei Kongresse eigentlich kaum Vorträge gesehen, was mir auch einfach immer zu voll war. Das ist ja am CCH jetzt teilweise auch schon so. Aber ich hab einfach echt schon tatsächlich sau coole Vorträge gesehen im CCH. Da war ich doch froh, dass ich die nicht verpasst hab. Also, ich mach das immer so vormittags, so früh nachmittags ein paar Vorträge. Und dann, wenn das Kulturprogramm in der Lounge anfängt, dann...
Wenn die Margaritas gefroren sind, dann geht's ab.
Nee, das Kulturprogramm auf dem Kongress, das war einfach die letzten beiden Male so großartig. Da hatte ich viel Spaß.
Es gibt auch wenig Anlass, zu glauben, dass sich das jetzt bei den letzten beiden Mal groß ändern sollte. Es wird sich gegebenenfalls nur noch steigern, auch wenn einem das ein bisschen schwerfällt.
Die Ansage war ja, dass zum 30C3, da hieß es ja, wir machen jetzt mal besonders viel Party, weil es ist ja der 30. Und ich glaube, das Konzept ist gut angekommen und deswegen wurde es seitdem immer erhöht.
Im Zurückrudern war der Club jetzt noch nie besonders gut.
Ich glaube, es dauert nicht mehr lange, bis wir diese große Halle da nebenan nicht mehr irgendwie in Teile aufteilen müssen.
Naja, also da fehlt noch eine ganze Ecke Leute.
Da fehlt eigentlich jetzt schon eine zweite Halle, die man als Lagerhalle benutzen kann, weil keine Ahnung, wann wir dieses Hackcenter da noch auslagern müssen. Ich weiß es nicht, es gibt auch glaube ich noch keine konkreten Pläne, wie es denn nun wirklich gemacht wird, weil war ja gerade mal Camp.
Wie auch immer, wollen wir nochmal anfangen?
Ich wollte noch mal auf, ja, was wollte ich denn eigentlich zurückkommen? Eigentlich wollte ich vorhin eine salope Überleitung machen, aber die ist schon durch.
Bin ich dir reingegrätscht?
Ja, ist aber nicht so schlimm. Aber Camp ist jetzt durch, oder?
Ja, voll durch.
Camp ist durch.
Durch genug.
So, jetzt können wir uns entweder über Fernsehen und Fußball unterhalten, oder noch mehr über Tesla reden.
Ich würde sagen, Tesla gleich hinten rangeklebt. Von Tesla-Spule zum Tesla...
Zum Tesla-Auto, ja. Eigentlich gibt es gar nicht so viel zu erzählen, aber ich war...
Was glaube ich denn nicht?
Ich war beim Apple Store und als ich beim Apple Store war, habe ich gemerkt, dass irgendwie zwei Türen weiter jetzt der Tesla-Laden aufgemacht hat. Den gibt es wohl schon eine ganze Weile, schon ein paar Monate.
Mir war das neu. Also ein paar Monate, okay, ich weiß.
Auf jeden Fall dachte ich so, habe ich dieses rote Tee gesehen und dachte so, geil. Als ich beim ersten Mal in den Apple Store rein bin und meinen Rechner abgegeben habe, bin ich also hinterher in den Tesla-Laden und habe mir das mal so angeguckt und so weiter und durfte mich dann auch reinsetzen und...
Kein Hebel.
Kein Gangschaltungshebel, nein. Aber man hat dieses, wie soll ich sagen, gefühlt zwei iPad-große Touchscreen neben sich. Und es ist irgendwie, dieses Auto ist unklar. Vor allen Dingen, wenn er hinten aufmacht, riesiger Kofferraum. Dann macht er vorne auf, zweiter Kofferraum, weil da ist ja kein Motor. Die Elektromotoren, die sind ja nur so, jetzt gefühlt so... Dicker Dackel, also mehr ist es ja nicht.
Ganz unten drunter. Am Grundtext hat man erneuert, weil Teile, die auf der Straße lagen, beim Rüberfahren sich unten in die Batterie gebohrt haben. Das waren die Fälle, wo die Teslas abgebrannt sind. Seitdem haben die Magnesiumboden und das kann nicht mehr passieren. Und das ist so ein Riesending. Und du kannst auf den Carport fahren und dann kommt so ein Teil, nimmt die ganze riesengroße Batterie ab. Also wirklich so riesengroß. Zieht die raus und klebt dir eine neue ran. Also schraubt die dran wie auch immer, aber die können halt komplett gewechselt werden.
Also angeblich war das Teil, was das in die Batterie geschafft hat, hätte irgendwie bei einem normalen Auto dann auch den Fahrer irgendwie schwer verletzt. Das ist ja das, was Tesla behauptet hat. Also ob das jetzt so richtig ist.
Das waren ja auch nur so ein paar Fälle. Das waren schon dicke Eisenteile, die sich da durchgebohrt haben.
Nee, und dann hast du in dem Auto ja die Möglichkeit, du kannst ja eine Fahrt quasi planen, so navimäßig. Und da hab ich gesagt, ach ja, dann fahren wir doch mal nach Italien. Ja, so, ja, wen's interessiert, Manchano da unten, wo das Ferienhaus, das mit den Bienen ist, da. Würde man da mit dem Tesla hinkommen, sagt der Tesla, ja, kein Problem, 17 Stunden. Inklusive fünf Supercharger-Stops, von denen der längste nur eine dreiviertel Stunde dauert. Da dachte ich auch so, was? Wie? Also der erste nur 20 Minuten und so weiter. Und dann fährst du wirklich mit dem Teil einfach mal so straight runter.
17 Stunden ist jetzt nicht so viel für so eine Autofahrt.
Ja gut, ich meine, wahrscheinlich hast du trotzdem in München Stau und kommst nicht in 17 Stunden durch. Aber das fand ich...
Also ich meine, was ich sagen will ist, da wärst du jetzt mit einem Benziner auch nicht schneller. Und 20 Minuten verbringt man auch schon mal an der Tankstelle.
Ja, mit anstehen und so, keine Ahnung. Klar ist so ein Aufladestopp, theoretisch dauert er länger. Aber diese Supercharger, da kommen ja irgendwie 110 Kilowatt raus. Also das ist schon völlig unklar und es kostet halt nichts. Weil die Supercharger sind auch in Europa umsonst. Wenn du so eine Kiste hast, gibt es den Strom dazu. Ja, naja es gibt ja nur große Modelle momentan.
Und das kleine gibt es nicht mehr oder wie?
Welches kleine?
Na das mit der kleinen Batterie, das hat diesen Freiladen nicht für umsonst mit drin. Da musst du das extra kaufen für 2000 Euro. Echt?
Das habe ich irgendwie nirgendwo gesehen. Na ja egal, Strom ist auch sonst nicht so teuer. Aber das fand ich dann schon irgendwie erstaunlich, dass du da mal so eben mit diesen ganzen Supercharger-Stops eigentlich auch eine relativ realistische Tour fahren kannst.
Und haben sie dir dann gleich noch ein unverbindliches Angebot für ein Fahrzeug mitgegeben?
Was kostet das Teil? Was kostet das Teil? Und da wird es jetzt interessant. Also es ist halt einfach mal ein teures Auto. Also es geht irgendwo so bei 80 los. Wenn du auf der Webseite guckst, dann geht es bei wesentlich niedriger los. Aber sie rechnen halt das, was du an Benzinkosten sparst, erstmal so vom Preis ab, so mit Sternchen. Unten steht dann, ja, wir rechnen halt pro Jahr 5000 Euro Benzinkosten ersparnest. Nee, 5000 sind es nicht, aber irgendwie 3000 oder sowas. Und das dann über so und so viele Jahre sparst du so und so viel. Und dann steht da also eine Zahl, die klingt irgendwie realistisch. Aber wenn du dann richtig hinguckst, dann gibt's an der Seite, gibt's dann die richtige Barzahlpreis oder so heißt das dann. Dann geht's bei 80 los, sinnvolle Ausstattung bei 90. Und wenn du das Performance-Modell haben willst, bist du, glaub ich, bei 110, 120.
Ja, also dass das so ein bisschen teurer war, wirf mich schon mal.
Aber das Performance-Modell ist halt jetzt momentan das Auto, was von 0 auf 100 in der kürzesten Zeit ever schafft. Also irgendwie so etwas über drei Sekunden.
Muss man haben.
Ich kaufe nicht.
Sonst bist du ja eine andere.
Ich kaufe gleich zwei.
Genau.
Wenn der eine leer ist, steige ich einfach um.
Und was halt dieses Touchscreen-Teil ist halt auch so absurd, weil du kannst halt hinten die Heckklappe auf und zu machen über Touchscreen und kannst über den Touchscreen, so mit Slider, die Öffnungsweite von dem Dach oben bestimmen. Naja, das Dach, das geht natürlich nur mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit auf und zu.
Nein, das User-Interface von dem Touchscreen. Das ist schon snappy.
Die Google-Karte, die braucht ein bisschen, bis sie lädt, aber ansonsten ist schon snappy. Ja, snappy genug. Man hat jetzt nicht das Gefühl...
Also ist es so wie deutsche Bahn-Ticketautomaten?
Nein, nein.
Oder BVG-Ticketautomaten. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Schnack, Schnack, Schnack, Schnack.
Es ist schon snappy.
Könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ja, aber ist es metallisch?
Metallisch? Ja, es ist metallisch. Metallischer Anschlag. Also ich meine...
Der Schnack-Faktor.
Ja, nicht so ein Gummivabbel-Schnack.
Nein, nein, es ist nicht Gummivabbel.
Manchmal hat man das Gefühl, dass man auch eine Gummibärchen drifft.
Es ist auch kapazitiv und nicht Drucksinn.
Die waren dann dafür.
Nein, nein, das passt schon. Das passt schon. Also das Design ist noch so ein bisschen iOS6-mäßig, aber im Großen und Ganzen als snappy ist es schon.
Und Testfahrt war jetzt aber nicht drin?
Also ich hätte da eine Testfahrt ausmachen können, aber die sind irgendwie ein schöne Feld, weil der nächste Supercharger ist in Schönefeld und dann machen die da die Testfahrten.
Der Einzige auch.
Der Einzige in Berlin, ja. Immerhin gibt's den Berlin jetzt einen. Und die meinten, das macht da auch mehr Spaß, weil da mehr Platz ist.
Bei Bär oder was? Auf der Landebahn?
Schon auf die Autobahn bestimmt.
Nee, du kannst bestimmt auf die Autobahn fahren und so.
Aber man will ja auch mal ordentlich beschleunigen.
Aber eigentlich würde sich ein so in Richtung A2 anbieten anstatt so Schönefeld, oder? Ist nicht so ein bisschen die falsche Ecke?
Die Landebahn würde sich vor allem anbieten. Ich meine, da ist wenigstens nicht so viel Verkehr.
Ja, aber die ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht freigegeben.
Naja, meine ich ja. Die, die halt noch nicht in Benutzung ist.
Also es ist relativ kurz, so eine Landebahn. Glaub mir, ich bin mal eine gefahren.
Na, wie kurz ist denn die? Zwei?
Na, vier Kilometer oder so wird die haben.
Kann man schon mal, ja und darf man dann auch diesen...
Der heißt jetzt Ludicrous Mode. Die haben ihn von Insane auf Ludicrous umbenannt, weil er jetzt noch mal krasser ist. Kostet aber auch 10.000 extra. Nur der Modus.
10.000 Euro extra?
Ja.
Für Software?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie da nicht auch noch eine andere Elektronik einbauen, damit die überhaupt so viel Strom in den Motor pumpen können. Also da wäre ich nicht so ganz sicher, ob das wirklich nur ein Schalter in der Software ist. Allerdings kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie halt an der Stelle dann mal die Leute schröpfen, denen das Wert ist. Fände ich jetzt auch nicht verkehrt. Also wer für so ein Scheiß Geld ausgibt, der darf dann auch schon ein bisschen was bezahlen. Aber ja, um die Frage zu beantworten, ich bin nicht testgefahren bis jetzt.
Und was macht dieser Mode?
Der Mode macht, der schaltet alles frei.
Das ist einfach die maximal mögliche Beschleunigung.
Mit diesem Mode schaffst du es von 0 auf 100 in 3 Sekunden.
Und das drückt ja halt irgendwie alle Organe von vorne nach hinten. Das muss man ja mal so YouTube-Videos anschauen. Das haben wir schon verschiedene Leute dokumentiert und übereinstimmend.
Sehr viele F-Worte benutzt.
Hat das, genau, sehr viele F-Worte benutzt. Das ist halt so ein bisschen Astronautentraining.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel. Die meisten Raketen beschleunigen nicht so stark. Es ist eher Sojus bei der Landung.
Die meisten Raketen beschleunigen nicht so stark wie Tesla?
Das sieht vielleicht auf dem Bild nicht so aus, aber von den Zahlen her...
Also eine Rakete hat schon ordentlich...
Also wenn du siehst, wie die so abheben vom Pad, so majestätisch davon schweben...
Du kennst das Phänomen, wenn du so ein Flugzeug im Himmel siehst, das sieht auch so aus, als würde es fast stehen und so. Und wenn du daneben stehst, dann hast du mit 300 kmh vorbei ballert, dann ist das auch was anderes, das bei den Raketen ähnlich.
Die beschleunigen halt relativ konstant über mehrere Minuten.
Ja, aber du hast halt schon so G3, G4, G5, G6, G7-Situationen in Raketen, doch. Also werden die Astronauten auf jeden Fall getrainiert.
Ja, beim Wiedereintritt, bei Isntag. Nein, beim Start.
Da explodiert Shit und zwar viel schnell. Das ist nochmal eine andere Liga als Reifendrehen auf der Straße und so. Hinten raus.
Obwohl, die Beschleunigung von der Rakete wird ja mehr, je länger sie fliegt.
Bevor wir dummes Zeug reden, schlage ich mal im Internet nach.
5G sagen die bei so einem Shuttle-Start.
Also bei 9G ist der Mensch im Arsch.
Das ist mal eine Ansage.
Ja, und dein Tesla hat knapp 1.
Ja, mehr geht auch gar nicht, ne? Weil du hast ja die Reibung nicht auf der Straße.
Haben wir schon gehabt, dass die Leute, die Studenten und so weiter Fahrzeuge bauen, die mit so einem komischen Kleber und so weiter über die Straße ballern, dass die halt schneller schaffen als diese 2,9 Sekunden. Aber so normal, diese 3 Sekunden ist ja knapp über diesen was so theoretisch. Und das ist ja dann etwas weniger als 1G. 1G wäre 2,9 irgendwas.
Lustig fand ich übrigens auch die Feststellung, dass das Auto mit der kleinen Batterie der Allradantrieb eine weitere Strecke schafft als der, der nur den Heckantrieb hat.
Ja, das ist jetzt das neue Modell, das mit dem neuen Motor und so, das sie noch mal optimiert haben. Da können sie wahrscheinlich den Stromverbrauch ein bisschen runterdrehen, dafür auf mehrere Motoren verteilen und das belastet wahrscheinlich die Batterie weniger.
Ja, oder sie rückgewinnen mehr, wenn sie bremsen. Keine Ahnung, das fand ich aber auf jeden Fall irgendwie lustig.
Ist auf jeden Fall geiles Hightech-Spielzeug, wenn man geiles Hightech-Geld hat.
Ja, das Geld muss man wahrscheinlich wirklich... Nee, haben wir alle nicht in der Portokasse, oder?
So direkt jetzt nicht.
Nicht so unbedingt jetzt so.
Man kann ja auch nicht auf die Amazon-Wunschliste setzen und das Beste hoffen, oder?
Verkaufen die da eigentlich auch diese Halmbatterie?
Ja, nee, nicht für Deutschland oder noch nicht.
Nee, für Deutschland gibt es die glaube ich noch gar nicht. Und die hatten die da auch nicht in dem Store. Also die hatten in dem Store einen aufgeschnittenen Motor, den kann man sich mal angucken. Der ist wie gesagt erstaunlich klein. Und sie haben so ein Supercharger-Ding da rumstehen, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht angeschlossen. Und ja, aber ansonsten ist es ein relativ kleiner Laden, da passt halt gerade mal das Auto rein, gut ist.
Die ersten Auslieferungen starten Ende 2015.
Eine Powerwall.
Also, wenn ich ein Haus hätte und eine Solaranlage und zu viel Geld, vielleicht auch ohne zu viel Geld, dann hätte ich auch so ein Powerwall-Ding. Das ist ja mal geil, grundsätzlich sich unabhängig zu machen und nachts dann auch irgendwie weiter den Solarstrom zu benutzen.
Also Ladestationsdichte in Deutschland ist für dich noch nicht sonderlich ausgeprägt. Da fährt man im Prinzip wirklich immer von Ladestation zu Ladestation.
Ja, außer du hast halt ein Haus mit der Ratsche und kommst abends nach Hause, schließt an und bumm, fertig.
Ja klar, aber wenn du halt mal woanders hinfährst.
Ja, na dann parkst du ja auch irgendwo nachts irgendwo.
Na, der mit der großen Batterie ergeben sie an ungefähr 500 Kilometer. Und die Charger-Dichte ist so etwa 300 Kilometer sind die auseinander.
Ja, willst aber nicht, wenn du zum Bäcker fährst mit deinem Tesla, dann 300 Kilometer weit fahren, weil leer.
Nee, du musst schon ein Lade-Ding ins Zuhause haben. Und wenn das nicht irgendwie drei Phasen Drehstrom mit 16 Ampere ist, dann macht das auch keinen Spaß.
Da geht auf jeden Fall noch was. In London haben sie auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Supercharger als in Berlin.
Ja, das wird schon noch kommen, hier mit den Ladestationen überall und so weiter. Das geht schon.
Also ich hab die schon in The Wild gesehen in Berlin. So ist es nicht.
Ja, ich auch. Ich weiß auch, wo einer dauerhaft parkt immer.
Ich weiß, wo dein Tesla parkt.
Also die Saturn V Rakete scheint eine derjenigen zu sein, die wohl am heftigsten Schub gemacht hat und wo sie auch runter regeln mussten. Also die hätte noch schneller können, aber hätte sonst die Astronauten vielleicht... Also ich glaub, die war bei so 5G, wenn ich das jetzt hier so... Und ein Formel-1-Auto. Wenn das Vollspeed bremst, dann kriegt das auch 5G-Bremskraft hin. Hab ich hier gerade gefunden. Formel-1-Autos. Und das ist auch letztens...
Jetzt weißt du, warum die 6-Punkte-Gote haben, oder wie viele Punkte die auch immer haben, weil mit einem Punkt werden deine Rippen einfach alle durch.
Ja, Formel-1-Autos sind wirklich krass. Aber ich hab auch letztens so gedacht, für unsere zukünftigen Generationen, das wird echt schwer, neue Grenzen zu finden, die man so brechen kann. Also Flugzeuge, die physikalische Grenze ist der Mensch. Ohne Mensch im Flugzeug könnten die noch viel krassere Sachen machen. Seitdem diese Jets mit Engine Vectoring, oder wie das heißt, die ihre Triebwerke bei vollem Karacho noch mal drehen können, um noch krassere Kurven zu fliegen und so, da ist ja nur der Mensch der Hinderungsfaktor, um das nicht noch krasser zu machen.
Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt Drohnen, und das ist sowieso bald vorbei.
Autos, also auf dem Land sich schnell fortbewegen, alles schon gemacht. Es sind auch alle physikalischen Grenzen schon geworden. Tiefe auch, überall schon gewesen.
Da fliegen halt möglichst wenig Geräte.
Ja, wenig Geräte ist aber nicht so aufregend. Also hier der Baumgarten, wie er heißt, der fast aus dem Weltall auf die Erde gesprungen ist. Wie weit willst du jetzt noch gehen, um irgendeine Grenze zu brechen? Deswegen gehen jetzt wahrscheinlich so viele Leute darauf ab, auf diese Mars-Missionen, die ohne Return, weil da bist du einfach der Erste. Du bist der schlauste Mann, der schönste Mann, der jüngste Mann, der schnellste und der langsamste Mann oder Frau.
Und der am Wald wächst, begrabenem Mann.
Da kannst du noch so alle Rekorde brechen. Da war noch nie irgendeiner.
Nächster Modertuckel.
Ich weiß nicht, dass diese Wingsuits doch gerade irgendwie schon mal eine ganz gute Vorgabe sind.
Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass es nicht unmöglich ist, aber ich sag nur, die letzten 20 Jahre wurden einfach noch mal so...
Wingsuit mit Rakete auf dem Rücken.
Ich sag ja nur, dass es schwerer wird für die kommenden Generationen. Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Es wird ja auch alles viel verfügbarer.
Vom Mars ist bisher noch keiner zurückgekommen.
Nee, aber einfach so... Letztens ist eine auch von Red Bull gesponsert, hat mir ein Kollege erzählt, freier Fall in so ein Felssee von der Klippe. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Meter das jetzt waren, 100? 100? Ja, es waren noch 50 Meter, dann fällt der Mensch nicht mehr schneller. Er ist dann ungebremst, gerade rein, hat auch irgendwelche Schuhe an, damit ihm nicht die Füße zerpellt beim Eintritt. Und ich meine, auch wenn das dann irgendwann... Jetzt kommt noch der nächste, der die Maximalfallgeschwindigkeit des Menschen in Wasser hat, ist der Drops auch gelutscht. Was willst du noch machen?
Am laufenden Meter gibt es auch irgendwie so neue Sachen. Also jetzt hier so... Kommt jetzt darauf an, geht es ja jetzt nur um reine Beschleunigung?
Ja, so einfach Grenzen brechen oder neue... Also Limits einfach austesten und bis an die Grenze gehen. Also es sind einfach schon extrem viele Grenzen quasi weitestgehend ausgelotet.
Ja, hat man glaube ich vor 100 Jahren auch gedacht.
Es geht immer weiter.
Vor 100 Jahren waren sie nicht an den physikalischen Grenzen des Menschen.
Wir glauben an den Fortschritt.
Na weißt du, Hakaia, womit du die physikalischen Grenzen des Menschen halt noch getunt bekommst? Durch irgendwie Druckanzüge und Pipapo. Also da geht ja auch einiges.
Ist ja nicht so, dass die Dirt-Piloten das jetzt nicht schon hätten, ne? Oder die Weltraum, was auch immer, aber egal.
Ich kann noch kurz erwähnen, warum ich eigentlich überhaupt im Apple Store war. Und zwar mein altes MacBook Pro 15 Zoll von 2011. Hat mitten beim Spielen, wie heißt das so schön? Schwarzen Bildschirm und Lüfter auf Vollgas. Und dann bootete er nicht mehr. Genau den. Und dann weigerte er sich standhaft, sowohl Mac OS als auch Windows zu booten. Und dann war irgendwie klar, das ist die Hardware. Sie hat noch so schöne Streifen im Display gehabt und so. Alles, was man so kennt. Lustigerweise ging Firewire Target Disk Mode noch. Ich hab also mit Carbon Copycloner erstmal einen schönen Backup von dem Ding gemacht und hab dann immer mal wieder beim Apple Store versucht, einen Termin zu klicken. Und dann hatte ich den irgendwie, bin dann dahin, irgendwie nachmittags um drei, geb das Teil da ab. Der hat sich das alles angehört, meinte dann so, ja, ja, da gibt's ein Quality Extended Program, oder wie das heißt, Quality Exchange Program und so. Ja, ja, wir tauschen das Mainboard, kein Thema. Und dann dachte ich so, hm, nicht schlecht, kostet nix. Und ja, normalerweise dauert das drei bis fünf Tage, aber wir haben gerade nicht so viel zu tun, kann sein, dass es schneller geht. Am nächsten Tag um zehn ruft er mich an irgendwie, ja, Rechner ist fertig, können sie abholen. Weiß ich nicht, also ich meine...
Gigahertz haben sie genau das gleiche Board eingebaut, manchmal haben die die alt nicht mehr, dann kriegst du was Neues.
Ehrlich gesagt, das hab ich noch gar nicht überprüft, weil...
Aber das ist der erste, was ich weiß.
Also es war auf jeden Fall damals der langsamere, weil ich immer die langsamere Variante kaufe.
Ja, nicht doof, weil man beim Upgrade, wenn eins kommt, mal den schnelleren kriegt vielleicht.
Nee, ich denk mir halt immer sehr so zum Thema Lüfter Ludicrous Mode. Ich denk mir halt immer, dass das Gerät ist halt auf eine bestimmte Thermik designt für den größeren Chip. Und wenn man dann aber den langsameren hat, dann verbraucht er nicht ganz so viel Strom und dann bleibt der Kühler. Vielleicht Augenwischerei, aber...
Diese These hat sich für mich zum Beispiel widerlegt. Ich hatte nämlich davor von der Firma das kleinere Modell und das hat viel krasser gelüftet als das größere.
Das ist so, wenn die diese Chips machen, die kommen alle vom gleichen Wafer. Dann werden die durchgetestet, wie gut die sind und wie viel Strom die verbrauchen, wie viel Voltage die dabei brauchen. Die guten Geräte sind einfach die, die Chips, die gut performt haben. Wenn du das kleine Gerät holst, dann kriegst du die Chips, die oben nicht mehr so gut performt haben. Deswegen willst du die mit den besseren Chips und die dann selber langsam betreiben. Aber grundsätzlich hast du den cooleren Chip.
Ja, da muss ich mal nachgucken. Vielleicht hab ich tatsächlich einen schnelleren, aber ich meine, diesen 100 MHz Unterschied oder so.
Ja, nee, das war ja auch nur so. Aber es ist oft so, dass, auch wenn die Sachen tauschen, dass sie dann halt, ja, warum sollten sie ein kleines und ein schnelles Board, also langsam mal das untenschnelles Board aufheben, dann heben die einfach nur die schnellen Boards auf zum Tauschen, weil dann freuen sich die Leute. Und Apple kann das ja auch egal sein.
Aber das war ganz lustig, weil der hat das so aufgenommen. Ja, aber da ist das DVD-Laufwerk nicht mehr drin. Ich hab eine SSD eingebaut. Ah ja, mit einer Optibay. Schreib das so auf, meine ich. Ja, und außerdem hab ich irgendwie einen Fusion-Drive gemacht, mit der Platte und dem SSD. Aha, Fusion-Drive, schreib das so auf. Und dann war aber dann irgendwie kein Problem.
Das wüsste ich auch erzählen und dann sagen, ja, das WLAN-Modul hab ich auch gegen Neues getauft.
Und was hat er dazu gesagt?
Nee, ich hab meins ja noch nicht abgegeben. Ich müsste das erzählen, wenn's so wäre.
Ich würde eigentlich schon sagen, sportlich, sportlich.
Nee, aber das war echt eine gute Experience, weil du warst so, ach so, ja, das schreib ich auch mit rein. Schreib ich mal mit rein, dass es ein Fusion-Drive ist, nicht, dass die irgendwie das zusammenbauen, nur die Festplatte anschließen und sich wundern, warum er nicht bootet. Also das war echt super.
Also alles wieder schick?
Alles wieder schick, ja.
Und was war das, dieses Austauschprogramm, ist das, wo die sagen, dass...
Nein, es war der externe Grafikchip. Also der...
Da muss dieses Austauschprogramm auch gibt. Mein Rechner müsste das auch haben, aber meiner läuft wie eine Eins. Aber lief dein Rechner bis zu diesem Moment auch?
Ja, ich hatte halt mal wieder irgendwie Windows angemacht, Spiel angemacht und dann hat er halt irgendwie ordentlich Grafik erzeugt und dann hat es irgendwann Poff gemacht und dann war es dunkel.
Vielleicht solltest du das auch mal probieren. Wie lange ist denn dieses Fenster noch?
Naja, nachdem der Rechner vier Jahre alt ist, ist wahrscheinlich das Programm nicht beschränkt, sondern solange noch Leute kommen, die halt das Problem haben, kriegen sie irgendwie... Die Hardware getauscht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht hören sie auch auf mit dem Programm, wenn sie alle Boards, die sie auf Halde haben, irgendwie eingebaut haben.
Schick, wenn sie keine Boards mehr haben und trotzdem noch tauschen müssen. Hab ich schon gehört.
Ja, ihr habt grad nichts zum Tauschen.
Funktioniert alles.
Ach so, Dennis, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Gut, dass wir mal wieder mehr über Macs reden. Wo schon der Name Grafikkarte gefallen ist. Wo krieg ich jetzt noch eine geile Grafikkarte für meinen Mac Pro her? Weil die letzte, die da mal im Verkauf war, die letzte, die da rausgekommen ist, die ist nirgends mehr zu kriegen.
Also, das, glaube das, vom Firmware-Patchen und so weiter, was das Coolste ist, ist die, die ich habe. Das ist die 7970 von AMD. Aber die hat halt einen Haken und ich glaube, der würde nicht gefallen. Und zwar, wenn ich Safari resize, dann stockt ab und zu mal das gesamte GUI. Und ich weiß nicht, ob bei deinen Tools, wenn du so eine Aufnahme machst, ob das eventuell auch kurzfristig mal alles stoppt. Ich weiß nicht, das ist nur bei Safari resizing, bei anderen Programmen komischerweise nicht. Ich kann dich nicht vertrauen. Ansonsten alles super, aber das ist halt komisch. Ich dachte auch, das fixen wir irgendwann mal, aber bisher ist das Problem immer noch da. Aber das, ansonsten die Karte, du hast den Boot-Screen, du hast die Beschleunigung, die wird richtig angezeigt, du hast auch 5 Gigatransactions pro Sekunde, auf diese I-Boots und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, ich dachte jetzt irgendwie, du saßt mir jetzt hier, musst da hingehen und da kann man die noch kaufen. Du weißt, was ich meine, diese komische, diese Freak-Ethischen, diese Sapphire...
Na, weil das nur eine 79,50 war, die war auch nur nicht irgendwie 5 Gigatransactions, sondern nur zweieinhalb, die hat den Bus nicht richtig ausgenutzt und so und irgendwie, das ist nur so die halbe Wahrheit.
Ich komm ja bei diesen ganzen Nummern immer wieder durcheinander. Jetzt muss mal gucken, was ich habe. Ich hab eine 68,70 gerade drin. Gibt's da überhaupt was besseres? Aber nicht in offiziell irgendwie so. Also gibt's nicht mal für den Mac...
Also 6000er-Klasse hab ich mich nicht umgeguckt, aber so der Stand ist, die, die ich hab, die sind 79,70, aber die hat halt, wie gesagt, diese eine Macke. Aber die ganzen Videojungs und die ganzen...
Das ist niemals von irgendjemand davon eine Variante, die wirklich mit der Macintosh-Förmere kommt, produziert worden.
Von Hause aus, schon zum Kaufen direkt, ohne Patchen und so weiter, ne? Dieses Sapphire-Zeugs, das war die einzige und das war auch eher so eine halbherzige Sache. Also die waren nicht so doll. Und das kann man sich halt jetzt, wie bei der 79,70, da selber machen. Ansonsten schwärmen alle noch von den Nvidia-Karten, aber da ist halt das Problem, da musst du immer deren Web-Drivers oder wie die heißen runterladen. Und es kann sein, dass du halt, wenn du dein OS updatest, dann, also da muss man immer mit den Treibern spielen und so und auf sowas hab ich halt keinen Bock. Ich will einen haben, die halt so von sich, vom OS so unterstützt wird, aber wie sagt das, so dieses Safari-Ruckel-Problem.
Und das haben auch andere schon dokumentiert?
Ich hab jetzt hier El Capitan noch nicht zuhause getestet auf Meinberg Pro, weil die haben ja grafikmäßig schon ein bisschen was geändert wegen ihrem Metal-Kram, vielleicht haben die da ja auch nebenbei, aber es passiert ja oft, dass man so, wenn man sich das nochmal anguckt, den ganzen Code noch einen Bug gefixt und vielleicht war das ja ein Bug, kann ja sein, keine Ahnung, oder die AMD-Jungs mussten den Treiber updaten, damit sie mit dem neuen Metal klarkommen und dabei wurde der Bug irgendwie so nebenbei irgendwie gefixt, da muss ich nochmal testen, aber hab ich noch nicht. Ich wollte auf meinem Produktionsrechner zuhause erst umstellen, wenn da irgendwie das kein Beta mehr ist.
Dein Produktionsrechner, was produzierst du?
Na, das ist hier, mein Laptop ist zu meinem, kann irgendwas mit passieren, das nächste Schlimmrechner geworden, und zuhause, das ist so Tastatur, Monitor, Rock-Solid, das ist so, da kommt kein Beta mehr drauf. Das muss irgendwie, wenn ich da irgendwie anmache, muss das Ding gehen.
So viel zum Thema, pimp my Mac.
Ja, eigentlich wollten wir uns ja bei Fußball unterhalten.
Jetzt wäre ein Intro, äh ein Trenner.
Oh, äh stimmt, aber ist ja vorbei eigentlich, oder?
Und ich hab auch total was vergessen zu erwähnen.
Wir brauchen mehr sozusagen.
The Incredible Herrengedeck. Das ist jetzt ein Pointer nochmal aufs... Ja genau, aber ich hab's vergessen zu erwähnen, weil Kulturprogramm hat man ja alles schon gesagt auf dem Camp. Ich hab die ja schon ein paar Mal gehört, The Incredible Herrengedeck, so vom Namen her. Und ich hab auch mal diesen Yolo-Song, hattest du auch hier mal im Outro mal gespielt, ne? Und dann waren sie auf dem Camp plötzlich live da und dann hab ich ja überhaupt erst mal die ganze Großartigkeit ihres Schaffens begriffen, ja. Und hab mir auch direkt auf Bandcamp gleich zwei Alben von denen gekauft. Also, The Incredible Herrengedeck. Sucht einfach mal auf Google Incredible Herrengedeck Bandcamp. Und es gibt ein Media, CCC. Warte, ich guck mal schnell, meine Shortcut-Historie ist bestimmt da, genau, super. Denn wir haben alles aufgenommen und anscheinend sind die Herrschaften nicht bei der GEMA. Sonst gäbe es vielleicht bei dieser tollen Linkifizierung, die auch in die Show-Notes fließen sollte. Vielleicht anderweitig Probleme. Aber da könnt ihr euch die Incredible Herrengedeck auch live und in Farbe mal angucken. War ein wirklich super geiler Auftritt. Daumen hoch, immer gerne wieder.
Was fandest du am besten?
Weiß gar nicht genau. Also Döner war super. Also was ich vorher nicht so in ihrem Spektrum wahrgenommen hab, ist, dass die, also ich meine dieses Döner-Lied, das hat ja schon relativ eher ernsten und man, also ist ja kein schönes Thema an sich, aber wie sie das sozusagen umgesetzt haben, dass man zwischendurch, also man kann nicht anders als lachen, aber gleichzeitig, wie man sich......das dann auch im Hals steckt, ja. Sie schaffen es irgendwie, also sie hatten so zwei, drei Songs, die so in die Richtung gehen, und das fand ich eigentlich besonders bemerkenswert.
Für Unwissende, es geht natürlich nicht um einen Döner, der mit dem Hals stecken bleibt, sondern es geht um die sogenannten Döner-Morde und genau darüber muckieren sie sich also über den Begriff etc.
Ja, statt CS-Gas nur Soße Schaf oder so, ne?
Heute hab ich mal intuitiv irgendwo hingeklickt und ich hatte sofort Leisepunk.
Mal gucken, wie das jetzt wieder gelingt.
Aber das Geile war auch, dass sie vorher Angst vor Punk gespielt haben und dann Leisepunk.
Das war's nicht?
Nee.
Ich werd jetzt hier nicht stundenlang rumklicken, aber...
Einen hast du noch.
Einen hab ich noch. War's weiterhin oder war's weiter vorne? Das ist das Ansatz von Punk hier in diesem... Was ist das für ein Outfit? Bemützt, das ist hier so, wie heißen nochmal gleich die? Bemützten. Mexikala? Ne, hier die russischen Middles.
Pussy Riot.
Aber jetzt...
Kaputt war's nicht gab......
jetzt funktioniert das hier alles nicht mit dem Streaming.
Na dann lass das.
Jetzt kommt aber nicht leise Punk, oder?
Doch, es kam danach. Einzel? Danke schön, ja. Waren das Angst vor Punk, oder ist das...
Leute, die das total begrüßen. Es gibt Leute, die dann immer sagen, ja, das ist ein bisschen krass, ne? Und da wir ja irgendwie das allen recht machen wollen...
Ne, ne, weil ja Punk bekanntlich die Subkultur des Kompromisses ist, haben wir einen kleinen Kompromiss ausgearbeitet. Vorschlag zur Abstimmung, er heißt Leisepunk. Jetzt bitte ganz leise, auch wenn ihr pokt, bitte ganz zärtlich, vorsichtig poken, ja?
Genau.
Aber es darf gepokt werden.
Also es ist nur alles leise und ich hoffe, ihr versteht jetzt noch, was wir sagen.
Das Lied heißt Leisepunk.
Das ist so super, da hören wir jetzt mal rein, das ist einfach so großartig.
Das ist auch neu bei Punk.
Leise Punk, leise Punk, für meine Kumpels vom Ordnungsamt. Jetzt sitze ich hier beim Tesschen Tee und fang Softie-Pogo an. Mein Mittelfinger rimpelt den Daumen ganz ungeniert an.
Ja, wirklich sehr charmant, muss man wirklich sagen.
Hab da auch verpasst. An der Stelle könnte Roddy jetzt mal schön reingrätschen.
Was, was, was?
Na, du hast doch hier eine Ankündigung noch. Wo wir jetzt sowieso schon bei Konzerten sind. Du bist auch so ein leise Punk.
Ich bin ein Laut Punk.
Ja, Mittel-Laut Punk. Am Samstag in Rekentin.
Samstag, sag mal mit Datum, heißt nämlich relativ.
Ist da auch was von Ratiofarm?
Ah, verwirr mich doch nicht.
Also am 5.
Brandenburg, das ist in Brandenburg.
Sag doch erstmal was.
September. Spielen wir da mit der Band in der Akademie für Suffizienz.
Und die Band heißt?
Martin Dieselhorst Vierer.
Genau.
Das geht ja schon, okay.
Meine Band heißt Martin Dieselhorst Vierer. Auf der Webseite martindieselhorstvierer.de kann man mehr erfahren.
Kannst du da mal bitte hinbrausieren.
Das ist ja das mit, ja. Na ja, das ist doch, also wie soll ich sagen, das ist doch episch.
Was?
Der Name als auch der Inhalt.
Aber wie weit ist Rekentinen bitte von Berlin weg?
Schon ein bisschen.
Gibt es da einen Super-Charger-Station?
Muss ich nochmal bei Tesla nachfragen.
Gibt es irgendeinen besonderen Anlass oder war euer Booking da so? Also wurdet ihr da angefragt?
Wir wurden da angefragt, weil wir da vor sieben Jahren schon mal in der Scheune gespielt haben, als das Ganze noch nicht Akademie spielte.
Das ist eine Akademie mit A, C, K, E, R.
Nee, das nicht, aber es ist ein Bauernhaus, ein ehemaliges mit Stall und Scheune und Zeug. In welchem Zustand das jetzt ist, weiß ich nicht. Damals war es noch sehr bauernhausig.
Alle Hörer aus Rekentien. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo das überhaupt von irgendwas in der Nähe sein könnte.
Genau da! In der Mitte vom Neubau.
Ich guck mal, wer sich da auf das neue Google-Logo starren muss.
Wieso guckst du denn auf Google?
Na, ich gucke auf Google Maps und die Karten noch nicht. Wieso?
Apple Maps hat es doch auch.
Na, Apple Maps gibt es nicht im Web.
Aber du hast doch Apple Maps auf deinem Computer.
Ja, aber da muss ich dann das Programm starten und dann muss ich da Apfel F drücken und dann muss ich ja Return eingeben und dann muss ich fünfmal den Namen anders eingeben, bis Apple Maps das findet.
Also solange das Maps-Programm schneller startet, als mir Safari ein neues Tab gibt, ist alles in Ordnung, finde ich.
Also eine Stunde und 39 Minuten.
Auf jeden Fall, da gibt es mindestens zwei Sachen, die hier von Google Maps angezeigt werden. Es gibt einen Geldautomaten und es gibt etwas, das heißt Dietrich Scharpenberg-Leichwöcher.
Also es ist im Nordwesten, irgendwo zwischen Wittstock-Losse und Wittenberg.
Pritzweig, na da muss der hin eigentlich.
Zwischen Pritzweig und Perleberg, naja. So, willst du nochmal erklären, warum eure Band Martin Dieselhorst Vira heißt?
Kurzfassung bitte, kennen wir schon.
Okay, ja nicht.
Ich sag doch, ach ja, stimmt ja. Weil es eine Art gibt, ein vierartiges Kabel zu verdrehen, das von den Herren Dieselhorst und Martin erfunden wurde und beschrieben und diese Verseilung, wie man das nennt, heißt eigentlich Dieselhorst Martin Vira. Weil aber die Band, als sie gegründet wurde, waren nur Elektrotechniker, gut, wir sind immer noch nur Elektrotechniker, war das irgendwie halt ein standesgemäßer Witz damals, ob er das immer noch ist.
Also laut Wikipedia heißt es Dieselhorst Martin Verseilung. Wenn man sich das anschaut, kennt man das halt schon irgendwie.
Genau, zwei Pärchen, wobei jedes Pärchen verdrillt ist und dann die beiden Pärchen untereinander auch nochmal verdrillt sind, um dann Nebensprechen gering zu halten. Ja genau, also wenn du so einen normalen Telefonhausanschluss mit vier Adern hast, dann müsste so ein Dieselhorst Martin Vierer da als Kabel verlegt sein.
So viel dazu.
Darf man sich auf alle Hunde tot freuen?
Natürlich.
Das wollte ich ja jetzt auch nochmal elegant einbringen. Das können wir ja am Schluss nochmal spielen.
Na und also Samstag, ja? Also zur besten Sendezeit irgendwo in Brandenburg.
Genau.
Wer Lust hat ins Nirgendwo zu kommen, sei herzlich eingeladen.
Und spontan Flashmob, oder? Also so spontan ist jetzt natürlich nicht nochmal das Plan, aber wenn da 500 Leute plötzlich vor der Scheune stehen.
Ja, aber Flashmobs werden doch immer irgendwie geplant.
Und Roddys T-Shirt fordern.
Und den Rest.
Mal schauen.
Wollen wir uns noch über langweilige IT-Themen unterhalten? Also ist ja eigentlich nichts passiert. Google hat ein neues beklopptes Logo, was genau scheiße aussieht wie das Letzte.
Boring, boring.
Und Apple stellt irgendwas vor, von dem eigentlich schon alle wissen, was sie vorstellen, aber eigentlich weiß man nichts.
Ich finde das Google Logo sieht nicht so scheiße aus wie das Letzte. Ein bisschen unscheißer. Ist jetzt kein Thema. Also wenn man sich über Design unterhalten will, dann kann ich gleich anfügen. Da gibt es ein Kickstarter-Projekt, wo jemand das NASA-Design-Handbuch von 1972 oder wann das ist, neu auflegen möchte in Zusammenarbeit mit dem ursprünglichen Designer, der es mal designt hat.
Warum muss man das neu auflegen? Gibt es das nicht schon noch?
Weil es es nicht mehr gibt. Das ist halt ein Nachdruck. Ein Kompletter. Für mich selber wäre es jetzt nichts, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es Leute da draußen gibt, die das durchaus für einen Leckerbissen halten.
Aber was genau ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, da jetzt der Clou? Diese ganze Typografie?
Genau, die Typografie. Da sind auch Diagramme drin, an welchen Flugzeugen, Autos und Raumschiffen es wo anzubringen ist und in welcher Größe und so weiter. Also, wenn man auf so was steht, ist es sicher super. Ich fand das irgendwie spannend, dass jemand auf die Idee kommt, das Design-Handbuch von der NASA nachzudrücken.
Nachzudrücken.
Na ja, die haben ja schon 319.000 eingesammelt von den 158, die sie haben wollten. Ich glaube, da muss man sich nicht mehr groß mit beschäftigen.
Das muss man sicherlich nicht, nur wenn man das haben will, dann kann man da jetzt noch klicken, weil noch läuft die Kampagne.
Was passt da denn ein Buch?
Wir hauen das nicht als PDF raus, oder was?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wie derbe lame ist das denn?
Aber ich glaube, es ist was für Sofa und nicht für Computer, darum geht es ja wahrscheinlich.
Logisch, Leute, die das irgendwie haben wollen, die wollen es natürlich dann gedruckt haben, aber man kann es ja dann trotzdem als PDF vorfahren.
Genau, du holst jetzt dieses Buch raus, das kann man auch cool oder lame finden.
Dann gleich hier raus, die Themenkarte.
So was will man ja dann auch wirklich als Buch haben.
Schön, innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden sich selbst widerlegen.
Ja, komplett niedermachen. Ich wollte ja nur ein bisschen umstehen können. Also, das Buch ist, nämlich, ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie viel Zeit damit verbracht, weil ich das gestern auch erst erhalten habe. Aber für die Freunde der Berliner Hacker-Kultur, da gibt es ja so die einen oder anderen, die Seabase, so einen sicherlich häufig hier immer wieder erwähnte, auch heute auch schon wieder erwähnte, aber ja, wie nennt man denn das eigentlich? Eine Weltraumstation. Raumstation Seabase in Berlin, wo ja viele Veranstaltungen stattfinden etc. und die jetzt mittlerweile auch schon auf 20 Jahre Geschichte zurückblicken, haben jetzt ein Buch rausgebracht genau über diese Geschichte und haben sich da richtig ins Zeug gelegt. Da gab es nämlich schon so eine Start-Next-Kampagne, glaube ich. Und haben es jetzt mal geschafft, dieses ganze Seabase-Ding in Buchform zu gießen und das ist natürlich richtig schick. Und das kann man für, glaube ich, relativ verhältnismäßig wenig Geld, ich habe irgendwas mit 17 Euro im Kopf oder so, das ist ein bisschen mehr, aber so irgendwie so in der Größenordnung, also relativ wenig, wenn man sich mal hier den Aufwand anschaut, der hier getrieben wurde. Also so richtig fetter Schinken hier mit, keine Ahnung, 208 Seiten. Vielen Fotos und viel sonstiger Geschichte. Und davon gibt es auf jeden Fall noch welche. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo ich da hin linken soll, aber ich glaube, das CBS-Buch gibt es irgendwo.
Das C-Buch.
Heißt das so?
Ja, mit Q am Ende.
Ach, wo steht denn das? Bist du sicher?
Auf dem Rand.
Nein, nein, Buch mit C natürlich. C-B-O-O-C. C-Buch. Äh, man kommt komischerweise aufs Kämpf-Wiki. Ah, Kickstarter war das dann tatsächlich. Ähm, ja, wir packen irgendeinen Link irgendwo hin. Dann kann man das dann irgendwie bestellen. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das läuft. Geht aber irgendwie.
Äh, wir linken mal irgendwo hin.
Wir linken einfach mal irgendwo hin.
Genau.
Bin zu frei. So, können wir uns jetzt endlich über Fußball unterhalten? Ja, finde ich jetzt mal nötig.
Seid ihr schon zu lange im Abseits?
Nö, das nicht.
Passives Abseits.
Aber heute war ja auch ein bemerkenswerter Tag, ne?
Also ich muss sagen, das ist für den Berliner Fußball die bedeutsamste Nachricht seit, würde man sagen, mindestens einem Jahr.
Ja, kann man schon so sehen. Worum geht's? Der erste FC Union Berlin hat einen neuen Chef-Trainer.
Genau.
Nämlich Sascha Lewandowski. Und jetzt sind wir alle ganz hoffnungsfroh, dass es hier mit dem Aufstieg auch bald klappt. Aber bevor ihr jetzt Angst habt, dass es jetzt so einen reinen Fußball-Podcast bekommt, eigentlich ist das Ganze ja nur der Anlass, mal über so eine andere Krankheit zu reden, nämlich über Streaming-Apps. Du hast so einen Sky-Account.
So einen Sky-Go-Account, genau.
Ich benutze so einen Sky-Go-Account mit. Also ich benutze das häufig, bezahle aber nicht dafür, glücklicherweise.
Also dieses, dieses, äh, das Ding mit diesem Fernsehen im Internet, das ist ja jetzt schon irgendwie auch so ein bisschen, wird das ja so langsam Realität.
So ZDF-Mediathek.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich, ist das ganz witzig, weil diese Pay-TV-Geschichte, die wurde ja schon vor einiger Zeit eigentlich so digitalisiert. Das ist ja schon lange nicht mehr analoges Pay-TV, so wie damals noch, so ganz früher mit diesen Decoder-Karten und so. Aber es hatte lange Zeit nicht die Features von digitalen Medien, sondern es war immer noch genau so aufgezogen wie Fernsehen. Und also damals als mir jemand, da war ich mal irgendwo zu besuchen, die halt in Premiere hieß das damals noch, und die haben mir so erklärt, dann meinte ich so, ja und kannst du jetzt den Film auch nochmal später gucken oder was auch immer? Und dann, wie, später gucken? Oder kannst du sagen, ja die Serie jetzt, die Folge jetzt? Also da musst du gucken, hier ins Heft. Das war wie Fernsehen. Ich saß davon, okay, da hat irgendjemand was nicht verstanden. Und mittlerweile ist es ganz witzig, wobei es geil, wenn du dann selber guckst, da beim Fußball, da machen sie auch mal Eigenwerbung, was sie jetzt nicht für tolle Features einbauen. Und die sind immer noch so 2015 dabei, so, ja, also, gibt's jetzt auch auf Abruf? Oder wann immer sie wollen, wird jetzt irgendwie so als das Feature verkauft, als würden die Leute. Mit dem Record dann auch mit Festpad und alles hingestellt, der dann quasi für dich Fernsehen guckt, damit du's später nochmal angucken kannst. Oder echt da, also da wirklich am Kopfkratz ohne Ende, ne? Naja, mittlerweile, wie gesagt, sie stellen jetzt mehr und mehr auf dieses On-Demand um, weil das ist ja auch total naheliegend, das so zu machen. Aber, ja, also mit dem Streaming, das ist halt auf jeden Fall noch auch irgendwie Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst.
Naja, so ungelöst ist das ja gar nicht. Es gibt ja ein paar Anbieter, die das ganz gut hinbekommen. Ich finde, Netflix macht das mit seinen Apps ganz gut. Die finden das ganz gut abgebildet.
Das Ding ist ja bei Fernsehen, da hat man auch schon mal vor ewigen Freak-Shows drüber geredet, das Einzige, warum man jetzt überhaupt noch so richtig Fernsehen wollen würde, ist ja live. Weil das gibt's in Streaming zwar schon, aber selten in Gut. Und das ist zumindest jetzt so ein Grund noch, oft für Fernsehen, wobei das halt jetzt so mehr oder weniger ersetzt wird, aber das ist halt bei Streaming immer noch so das, wo es meistens nicht so geil ist. Also Live-Events streamen, weil Netflix wird ja Content von der Platte und die haben halt auch überall ihre CDN-Knotenpunkte, wo sie halt terabyteweise Content liegen haben. Jetzt, als sie in Europa gelauncht werden, haben die auch so Truckweise oder Containerweise Rechner mit Content einfach hergeschippt und in die Rex geschraubt. Um dir dann wirklich so eine schöne, smoothe Streaming-Experience zu geben. Und beim Streaming scheitert es ja auch oft einfach am Ablinken, dass das total überschätzt wird oder z.B. unterschätzt wird. Und bei Sky muss ich ja sagen, also DVB-T ist ja quasi auch so eine Art live-digitale Streaming. Dann gibt es ja von den Öffentlich-Rechthlichen für Live-Events schon auch immer mal einen Livestream. Und die Telekom, die macht ja hier auch Mobile-TV, gibt es ja auch so eine App da auf dem iPhone. Und die haben auch so eine Sky-Kooperation, die kriegst du sozusagen auch, das Sky-Bundesliga-Programm hier auf dem Mobile-TV. Aber überall ist die Qualität richtig scheiße. Bei Sky war ich eigentlich das erste Mal relativ beeindruckt von so einem Fernseh-Live-Sport-Events-Stream, weil zum Beispiel Fußball ist so ein ganz besonderes Problem, oder Sport generell. Grüne Wiese, wir kennen das ja alle, die Encoder-Fragmente, wenn der komische Rasen da so hin und her wabert. Und bei Sky, als ich das das erste Mal gesehen hab zumindest, dachte ich mir, wow, okay, ich kann das hier Fullscreen auf so so einen fetten Full-HD-Fernseher, den Stream gucken und ich hab das Gefühl, ich kann einzelne Grashalme auch unterscheiden noch so, ja.
Bei Sky jetzt über das Kabel? Tatsächlich.
Die Qualität ist da schon beeindruckend gut im Vergleich, gerade so was zu DVB-T oder was die Öffentlich-Rechnlichen zum Beispiel sagen.
Schicken die auch für dich jetzt Full-HD?
Und zwar ungefragt. Also es ist ja diese merkwürdige Geschichte, also erstmal, ja, das Bild ist glaube ich ganz in Ordnung, aber man muss erstmal dahin kommen, diese App. Das ist ja fürchterlich. Sie startet irgendwie in 20 Sekunden, dauert die, bis sie startet, da muss man sich irgendwie ganz komisch durchklicken, wo jetzt das aktuelle Spiel ist.
Ja, auch die Web, also ich gucke es immer nur über einen Web-Browser auf dem Desktop, da ist die Navigation, da hab ich jetzt schon meinen Click-Fahrt. Ja, wir nutzen weniger, hat weniger exploit. Und verbraut weniger CPU, ist das Gefühl, aber andere Karte. Aber die Navigation, die haben das Internet auch noch nicht so richtig.
Bevor der Stream startet und bei Live-Sport willst du sofort dabei sein, dann guckst du erstmal Werbung an, die nur exklusiv für dich eingeblendet wird. Ist ja nicht so, dass man danach in der App guckt.
Aber das ist nur bei der App, im Web ist das nicht so.
Ich kenne nur die App. Da guckt man sich erstmal Werbung an, was demnächst alles auf Sky kommt.
In einem Bezahl-Account wohlgemerkt. Und du kriegst das auch immer, wenn der Stream abgebrochen ist. Und du das Ding wieder neu startest. Und du dringend irgendwie, ja scheiße er war jetzt gerade vorm Tor und jetzt muss ich gucken und schnell. Und dann erstmal Bauspar, Fertrag.
Das ist doch das, was du wissen willst, kurz vor der Torchance.
Eine Beleidigung ist das. Dafür müsste man den Leuten auch einfach mal diesen komischen Sales-Droids auch einfach auf die Messe, wo die stehen, den Tag, da darf ich ihnen mal mit dem Mech treten, als Ausgleich.
So fünf grundlegende Sachen, die missachtet worden sind. Dann ist es ja so, du guckst es ja auch unterwegs irgendwie, da hast du ja die Auswahl zwischen Bundesliga HD und Normal-Bundesliga, so irgendwie SD-Auflösung oder so im Fernsehen. Das ist praktisch für die Leute, die auf ihrem Receiver zuhause nicht 10 Euro extra für HD bezahlen, die gucken das eben sehr pixellig. Wenn du das aber unterwegs auf der App guckst, kriegst du, egal was du anklickst, immer den HD-Stream ausgeliefert, weil du ja auch ohne einen Tarif hast, wo du irgendwie für eine halbe Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden dabei bist.
Aber jetzt kommt, wie heißt das Netzneutralität Ding Ding Ding, wenn du jetzt diese Mobile-TV-App von der Telekom benutzt, dann geht das glaube ich nicht von deinem Datenvolumen ab, ne? Aber da ist es halt nicht HD auch, wahrscheinlich dann.
Aber gut, aber die, also abgesehen mal davon, die einzige Situation, wo ich geringere Qualität haben wollen würde, ist, damit ich meinen Tarif nicht so sehr belaste. Aber genau da liefern sie nur HD aus. Und dann so ein Ding, wenn irgendwie Finalspiele sind, wo dann irgendwie in die Verlängerung gehen kann und das Elfmeterschießen kann, dann überlegt Sky, ja 90 Minuten dauert so ein Spiel, wir haben eine Pause dazwischen, noch ein bisschen Werbung davor, und legen eine Maximaldauer für diesen Stream fest. Wenn das jetzt in die Verlängerung geht und Elfmeterschießen kommt, dann haben wir das nicht eingeplant, dann wird der Stream einfach beenden. Wo man dann sagt, Verlängerung, Elfmeter ist nicht so spannend, kann man auch darauf verzichten.
Meinst du, die übertragen es gar nicht oder muss dann wieder die App neu starten?
Nee, der Stream ist beendet.
Es wird nicht mehr übertragen.
Du hast ja da diesen Programm-Guide und da steht drin, dieses Stream läuft bis 22 Uhr. Und wenn dann aber die Verlängerung bis 22, 30 geht, kannst du es nicht gucken. Im Fernsehen kannst du es gucken, aber nicht mobil.
Also, ja, das ist aber tatsächlich... Tatsächlich scheint es dann dazwischen auch dem Desktop, Browser-Stream und der App noch Unterschied zu geben. Das ist ja auch wirklich bizarr dann, weil...
Okay, mag sein, aber das ist so meine Erfahrung.
Ich glaub dir das, weil auch diese Mobile-TV-App ist ja auch das totale Wegglauf-Ghetto von einem User-Interface. Ja, wie gesagt...
Da muss ich ja nicht mal drüber reden, so schlecht ist das.
Und ich mein, wenn die Telekom das nicht hinkriegt, geschenkt, haben wir nicht anders erwartet. Aber Sky ist ja immerhin jetzt, sagen wir mal, ein internationales Unternehmen, die kommt ja nicht aus Deutschland jetzt primär. Da würde man ja erwarten, dass die vielleicht gerade aus dem Mutterland des Fußballs kommend da vielleicht ein bisschen andere Ansprüche haben, aber offensichtlich nicht. Das ist bestimmt noch das alte...
Mutterland des Fußballs fährt noch mit Diesel-Zügen irgendwie nach London.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ne? Erfinder der Lokomotive. Da sind wir gleich drauf hängen geblieben.
Und ich würde mich ja so freuen, wenn die in der nächsten Woche Apple TV mit einem App-Store vorstellen, um irgendwie die gesamten Mediatheken, die es so in der Welt gibt, irgendwie installieren zu können. Und wenn Sky das auch macht, werden sie es wieder versauen.
Nur wenn sie es selber poamieren dürfen. Bisher hat das Apple ja irgendwie alles immer kuratiert und da sind ja auch ein paar ganz gute Sachen bei rausgekommen. Ich meine, ich guck das nicht, aber diese ganze Basketball... Ja, entschuldigung, nicht Basketball. Baseball-Sache ist ja auch schon eine sehr interessante Vision darüber überhaupt, wie man sich so enhanced Fernsehen so vorstellt, weil es kommt halt nicht nur so das Bild und du kannst dir mal eine Tabelle im Videostream anschauen, sondern du hast halt die ganzen Daten zu den Spielen, Spieler, Statistiken etc. Auch alles drin und kriegst sie quasi programmatisch...
Die Amis sind da total davon auch. Alles hatte ich vorhin schon vorher erzählt hier, als der Olle Dirk Nowitzki da mit seinen Mavericks in den Playoffs waren und dann die Meisterschaft gewonnen haben. Da hab ich ja auch mal die Playoffs nachts, das ist ja dann immer um 4 Uhr morgens oder was man einschalten muss, mir die Spiele angeschaut und dann dachte ich auch so ok NBA, zeig mal, wie kann ich jetzt die Spiele sehen? Weil ich hatte jetzt schon so beschissene Erfahrungen, wenn du hier Fußball live im Internet gucken willst, und du hast kein Fernsehen oder was auch immer, so on-demand ist als Konzept schon mal überhaupt nicht vorgesehen. Sky hatte das ja auch mal 15 Euro für ein Champions-League-Spiel, eins. Auf jeden Fall da bist du halt hingegangen.
Wie ein Hollywood-Film, ne?
Da hatten die halt auch so wie ein Stadion-Ticket, passt das gleiche, super HD. Bei NBA war das halt auch so, die hatten korrekte Preismodelle, das war sofort irgendwie hier klicken, PayPal los, zack vom Feierabend, jetzt geht's los, und eben auch überall die ganzen Daten, alle möglichen Sachen aufbereitet, Highlights, was auch immer du haben wolltest aus allen Kameraperspektiven. Da dachte ich mir, ach, warum? Warum? Ist doch nie so schwer. Schaufelt den Scheiß einfach ins Internet und macht's einfach für die Leute zu bezahlen und es wird funktionieren. Und weil Sky ist ja noch besonders bescheuert, du kannst ja den Fußball nicht alleine buchen. Geht nicht. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich wär jetzt nur Bundesliga, ich bezahle 15 Euro im Monat, lasst mich in Ruhe und gib mir jetzt HD-Content. Nein, du musst noch das Fernsehprogramm und das Movie-Paket noch und das HD-Paket noch dazubuchen und bezahlst dich, bezahlst halt 50 Euro oder 40 oder was auch immer im Monat für Scheiße, den du gar nicht sehen willst.
Ja und vor allem die meisten Leute interessiert ja vielleicht noch nicht mal die ganze Bundesliga. Du willst einfach nur deinen Verein sehen und fertig. Das würde mir ja vollkommen reichen. Einfach nur die Spiele davon und bitte auch in einer ordentlichen Qualität, aber halt auch mal gerne in der niedrigen, wenn der Screen jetzt eh nicht so viel hergibt und der Mobilfunk vertragen.
Oder den User das wählen lassen vielleicht.
Aber dem Benutzer ein schönes rundes Paket zu schnüren hat doch beim Print auch immer gut funktioniert.
Das ist einfach bekloppt, weil die sich einfach eigentlich alles selber die Butter vom Brot nehmen.
Ich hab hier gerade mal geguckt, was mein Fiber-Anbieter hier an Zeug ins Kabel pumpt. Also irgendwie, da gibt's keine Ahnung. Es gibt irgendwie auf dieser Glasfaser irgendwo nebenher, schieben sie dann noch die ganzen Fernsehdaten rüber. Und dann kannst du da irgendwie so ein Antennenkabel anschließen und hast dann den ganzen Kram irgendwie auf dem Antennenkabel. Wir haben es aber bisher nicht benutzt, deswegen. Aber irgendwie gibt es hier auch jede Menge Sky-Kram. Sky Bundesliga, das ist das, wovon du redest. Da steht aber nicht HD.
Ja und vor allem, die können auch nur live. Aber wo ist der, ich bin 10 Minuten zu spät, aber ich will trotzdem das ganze Spiel halbwegs zeitnah machen.
Das kannst du noch machen. Aber das, was sie nicht haben, ist, dass du am nächsten Tag noch gucken kannst. Also ich glaube, nächster Tag genau und dann ist es halt auch raus.
Dafür haben sie wahrscheinlich dann die Rechte nicht mehr.
Es wird deplombeziert wahrscheinlich, oder?
Das ist recht auch vergessen, auch für PayTV.
Na gut, da kann ich mir zumindest bei Union, kann man sich da ja aushelfen, weil da gibt es ja quasi so einen Haus, internen Fernsehkanal, den sie auch ganz interessant bespielen. Also es ist auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt vom Community-Aspekt her sehr interessant. Also einerseits sind halt die Sendungen, also die Spiele sind nicht live, aber sie sind unmittelbar danach anschaubar. Und dann aber auch bis, weiß nicht, in alle Ewigkeit. Keine Ahnung, also man kann da ziemlich weit zurückblättern. Ich glaube, es sind einfach alle Spiele.
Aber vom Spiel gegen Leipzig gab es keine Trainer-Aufarbeitung mehr.
Du willst deinen Trainer zurück haben. Und was ja jetzt gerade erwähnt ist, sie machen dann halt auch so Community-Bespaßungen. Das heißt, sie machen dann so Interviews mit den Spielern, mit dem Trainer, Hintergrundsachen, berichten so von den Sonderaktionen.
Und auch zum Beispiel ganz viel.
Das machen so einige. Und einige wenige leisten sich da wohl auch eine eigene Infrastruktur. Ich habe da jetzt keinen wirklich großen Überblick. Ich weiß nur, dass das, was Union benutzt, noch von zwei anderen Bundesligisten benutzt wird. Das heißt, es macht dann halt irgendeine Firma hier in Deutschland. Und na ja, es ist auch so ein bisschen... Da könnte man auch mal so ein bisschen beigehen. Da geht noch mehr als zumindest schon mal ein interessanter Trend. Also das, was bisher immer nur von der Sportschau übernommen wurde, sich jetzt einfach total diversifiziert. Und sich dann halt irgendwo in Apps abspielt. Und warum auch nicht? Ich meine, es ist eigentlich am Ende, werden Leute insgesamt mehr für den ganzen Kram ausgeben, weil sich das einfach mit dieser ganzen Pauschalbespielung... Und hier hast du so einen allgemeinen Kanal, wo du den ganzen Tag vorne sitzen kannst und dir Werbung angucken kannst.
Das wär jetzt echt noch so ein Feature, wenn du PayTV hättest und hättest keine Werbung. Das wär auch... Das ist eigentlich die größte Lebensenttäuschung in meinem Medienkonsum.
Was ist denn mit... Gibt's noch Premiere?
Nee, nee, das ist ja Sky jetzt. Und auf Premiere gab's auch schon Werbung, so ist es nicht.
Auf Premiere gab's Werbung?
Gab's auch schon, ich glaube, immer so eine Bierwerbung hier und da mal vor so einem Sportevent oder so.
Ach so, bei Sport, da hast du ja sogar den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, da hast du ja dann auch noch irgendwie den ganzen Schnaß.
Aber das ist krass, weil das wird halt auch immer mehr. Und selbst beim Pay-TV, da kommt dann hier diese Scheißwerbung, wo der Rahmen irgendwie so reingerückt wird und dann frisst dieser Schweinsteiger da aus so einer rein schlecht reinmontierten Chipstüte irgendwelche Kackchips dir in deinem Fernsehbild, was dir dann auch noch teuer, also ich jetzt in dem Fall nicht, aber mein Kollege teuer bezahlt. Und wenn ich denkst, ey, hallo Teilnehmer, also was ist hier los?
Ja, ich bin da ordentlich viel zu haben für diesen Teil der Vermarktung, aber offensichtlich kriegen sie von diesen Firmen nochmal so viel Kohle in den Hintern geschoben, dass du das mit deinem Monatsbeitrag gar nicht ausgleichen kannst. Wo ich mich dann aber auch wieder umfrage, wenn die zahlen...
Warum zahlst du dann überhaupt noch für den Scheiß?
Ja, das natürlich sowieso, aber auch so wie die Rechnung an sich dann ausgeht. Also ich zahle hier sozusagen n Euro.
Und du zahlst ja auch nochmal das Filmpaket mit.
Ja, jetzt krieg ich irgendwie meine fünf Chipstüten dazu auch noch mit reingemacht. Was glauben die, was sie pro User an Chipstüten so verkauft bekommen, dadurch, dass sie einem da nerven? Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ticke ich auch einfach nur falsch.
Sie müssen pro Jahr, glaube ich, eine halbe Milliarde abführen an die Bundesliga. Das muss ich erstmal reinkriegen über Abos und Chipstüten.
Ich glaube, Tim meinte, wieviel die Chips-Hersteller an Chipstüten verkaufen müssen, um ihren Beitrag an den Schweinsteiger wieder reinzukriegen.
Das tage ich nicht auch bei jeder Werbung. Das ist im Kino auch so. Darum gehe ich auch nicht mehr ins Kino, weil ich einfach auch keinen Bock habe. Erstens wird das immer teurer, dann eine Tüte scheiß Maiskörner heiß gemacht und so einen Zuckerdring. Du bezahlst ja fast 10 Euro mittlerweile im Kino.
So eine Mini-Fackung M&M's 4,50 Euro. Nee, danke.
Dann kommt so ein Typ, quatsch ich dir noch, ins Ohr wegen einer blöden Eistüte und dann kommt eine halbe Stunde Werbung plus Trailer. Trailer würde ich ja noch vertragen, aber eine halbe Stunde Werbung, wirklich?
Das geht gar nicht.
Geht alle weg.
Übrigens, ich muss jetzt jetzt kritisch mal rein, weil wir sind ja beim Fußball, da darf man reingrätschen. Blutgrätsche, Blutgrätsche.
Wenn wir noch bei Werbung bleiben können.
Nee, weil ich war im Kino und hab den Film Victoria geguckt. Ist ein in Berlin gedrehter Film, dauert 140 Minuten und ist ohne Schnitt, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ach, davon hab ich gehört, der war doch bei der Berlinale, glaube ich, der totale Hit.
Weiß ich nicht, aber sollte man gucken. Da ist hier dieses Who Am I? Hacker-Film irgendwie und so weiter, das ist langweilig, den muss man gucken.
Wo kann man denn das gucken?
Ich hab den in einer Kulturbrauerei geguckt, da spielen die den komischerweise sogar im großen Saal, obwohl der jetzt nicht allzu groß ist. Da gibt's halt später hin, Mann.
Man weiß ja nicht genau, wie viel Werbung es ist, vielleicht ist es ja auch nur 20 Minuten.
Ja, dann brauchst du halt vorher noch eine, merkst ja das. Oder fragst den Typ einfach. Und so schlimm ist das jetzt mit der Werbung auch nicht.
Mich nervt das Kolossal.
Ich will da klicken, meine 1,50 zahlen und fertig. Nein, für einen Stream des Films.
Ja, dann musst du noch warten. Dann kriegst du für 0 Euro bei Pirate Bay.
Nee, ich will ja auch gerne was für bezahlen. Aber mein Gott, wie viele Leute könnte man damit... Also ich weiß auch nicht, das ist auch... Das Leben dieser Videoleute ist auch wahrscheinlich ziemlich schwierig. Ich meine, die produzieren so viel. Gerade so Doku-Filmer und so.
So Doku? Es gibt Filme über so Doku-Filmer.
Nee, was weiß ich. Es gab ja hier auch jüngst dieses Projekt, so Podcast-Filme machen. Wollte ich halt auch mal gucken, was da schon vorher gelaufen ist. Ja, da gab es auch andere Filme, aber die gibt es dann halt irgendwie nicht im Netz. Ja, aber das lief ja dann auf irgendeinem Festival. Und weg ist es so. Und dann freu ich mich halt auch, okay, wo, wie, was.
Na, manchmal gibt es dann noch eine Webseite und dann kannst du dann für relativ teuer Geld noch die DVD erwerben.
So was.
DVDs gibt es auch immer noch zu kaufen.
Ja, aber eigentlich, ja, eigentlich will man das dann halt, weiß nicht, wie man es haben will.
Ich will...
Mit einigen Modellen klar, aber vor allem, will ich halt unmittelbar sofort direkt in hoher Qualität ohne Scheiß. Ich bezahle auch gerne, ja, sofort.
Neuer geiler Film kommt ins Kino am selben Tag. Auch HD-Stream sofort mit Subtitles, Sprachspuren, whatever, yeah, yeah, hier, was auch immer. Aber dann kann ich es zu Hause gucken, ich kann noch mal Pause klicken zum Pinkeln gehen. Und ich kann mir zurückspulen, ich kann auch mal ein eigenes Eis aufmachen. Super.
So wie Apple TV das eigentlich macht.
Na ja, warten wir mal den neuen Tag ab.
Nur mit der Ausnahme von der Victoria läuft das nicht und der läuft das auch nicht, wenn es in den Kinos anfängt. In den USA haben die jetzt nicht so geil ein Deal gemacht. Also sie wollen ja da hin, sie wollen ja tatsächlich diese Home-Releases jetzt auch zeitgleich mit den Kino-Stars machen und dafür bezahlen sie dann Geld an die Kinos. Das haben die durchgesetzt bekommen. Weil die Kino, weil die Kino sich auf die, ja meinen sie halt. Also keine Ahnung.
So und?
Ich glaub's nicht, aber...
Kriegt Kaisers Geld, weil nebenan ein Rewe aufmacht? Weil sie gehen ja alle zu Rewe und...
Der Vergleich funktioniert glaub ich nicht.
Warum nicht?
Rewe, Kaisers, Kino, nee.
Kriegt Kaisers Geld, wenn ich mir mein Zeug nach Hause liefern lasse? Von den Läden, wo Kaisers sich...
Ja, wenn du bei Kaisers bestellst schon.
Kaisers und Rewe ist das selbe. Kino und Zuhause ist was anderes. Darum geht's.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Die Kinos kaufen ihren Content auch nur von Hollywood.
Nee, das wäre so, dass wenn du bei Rewe dir was liefern lässt, dass dann der Kaisers Supermarkt Geld kriegt.
, weil du zu Hause selber kocht. Die Welt ist kaputt.
Das ist wieder so eine Scheiße auf Leistungsschutz-Rechtsniveau.
Man versteht es nicht. Ich wünsche mir, dass es für diese Kleinstfilmer und ambitionierten Filmer einfach schnellere, effizientere Möglichkeiten gibt, ins Netz zu gehen. Eigentlich auch für Musik auch.
Es gibt ja schon so etwas wie YouTube an sich.
Da gibt es halt noch nicht die Pay-Taste.
Das ist nicht die Bandcamp für Videos.
Aber ich glaube, es ist ein anderer Markt. Musik ist halt was anderes als Video.
Musik ist mehr so runterladen, haben, 1000 mal spielen. Video ist schon einmal geguckt, und dann interessiert sich das auch zwei Jahre erstmal nicht.
Also zum Beispiel früher, als sich Leute DVDs gekauft haben, da dachte ich mir immer so, warum denn? Also die allermeisten Filme, die guckt man doch wirklich nur einmal. Das ist ja wirklich die extreme Ausnahme.
Ja, und dann verleihst du die DVDs und leist die aber von jemand anderes andere DVDs dagegen aus.
Eine Paywall oder so eine Pay-Option? Na ich rechne damit, das wird auch sicherlich irgendwann kommen. Absolut. Wenn die das schon fordern. Da müssen sie aber vorher noch ein neues Luvo.
Also ich mein bei Bandcamp find ich das ja immer ganz witzig, wenn ihr dann oft genug streams, wenn ihr das zum Beispiel beim Incredible Herrengedeck macht, dann kommt ja irgendwie, it's so ein kleines Pop-Up, it's time to open your heart and your wallet. Kommt so ein Herz in die Brieftasche, dann kannst du aber auch No Thanks klicken, dann kannst du glaube ich noch weiter streamen.
Wo kommt das?
Bei Bandcamp, wenn du halt zum Beispiel bei Herrengedeck jetzt so zehnmal hintereinander das Album durchstreamst, dann kommt so ein kleines Ding drüber, it's time to open your heart and your wallet. Oder irgendwie so, war irgendwie ein ganz putziges Textchen.
Wisst ihr, wie viel Prozent vom Internet irgendwie von Netflix kommt? Von der Bandpreise?
Zwei-stellig?
Ja, wie viel?
Vom gesamten Internet-Traffic irgendwie 60 Prozent?
Nee, aber 37 Prozent ist von Netflix, weltweit.
Der Rest ist Spam, oder?
Ja, in den USA ist es glaube ich schon fast die Hälfte.
Echt?
Na ja, wenn es halt mal jemand richtig macht, dann rollt er den Markt auf. Das ist doch irgendwie keine neue Feststellung.
Und irgendwann wird es dann, den Hollywood auch nicht mehr interessieren, ob dann da so ein Kinopleite geht oder nicht, dann kriegen die auch kein Geld mehr.
Das ist mit Tesla doch das Gleiche. Wenn mal jemand richtige Elektroautos baut, dann verkaufen die sich auch wie warme Semmel. Hast du es mal angeguckt? Der BMW i3 steht mit 180 Kilometer Reichweite auf der Website. Und du denkst dir so, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das ist so...
Wozu baut ihr dir das Auto, wenn es 180 Kilometer Reichweite hat?
Weil es ein Startauto ist wahrscheinlich, oder? Ist doch so ein kleines Ding, ne?
Ja, da fährste von der eigenen Garage auf den Firmenparkplatz und wieder zurück. Dafür brauch ich kein Auto, dafür hab ich BVG. Also das ist doch Quatsch.
Nicht wenn du irgendwie Pendler bist und in der Pampa wohnst.
Wie weit ist dein Arbeitsweg in der Stadt?
Müsste ich nachmessen. Also ich käme mit 180 hin. Aber trotzdem. Aber trotzdem. Nein, aber gerade in der Stadt brauch ich das Auto jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Um in die Stadt zu kommen, man wohnt ja nicht immer in der Stadt.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht drüber diskutieren. Wenn jemand ein ordentliches Produkt abliefert, dann verkauft er das halt auch.
Aber lass mich raten, der E3 ist ein bisschen billiger als der Tesla?
Ich glaube, du kriegst 3 I3s für den Tesla. Aber was ja bei Netflix noch spannend ist, die Reichweite addiert sich.
Bei Netflix ist ja noch spannend, die haben ja so viel Marktdurchdringung und offensichtlich auch Kapitalfluss, dass die halt jetzt ihren eigenen Content produzieren, ihre eigenen Serien, ihre eigenen Filme und sozusagen der ganzen Content-Mafia da komplett aus dem Weg gehen. Und das ist wirklich eigentlich der eigentlich disruptive Pfad, weil die damit so die ganze komische Verwertungskette, die dafür für Region-Codes und diesen ganzen anderen Schmons einfach verantwortlich ist, den können die halt nur aushebeln, wenn sie eigenen Content haben und die haben einfach so viel Kohle, dass die sich jetzt die Leute heranschaffen, um geile Serien, die sogar Emmys oder was auch immer gewinnen, selber produzieren und dann dieser ganze andere Scheiß einfach nicht mehr.
Und Amazon macht das auch schon, die fangen auch schon mit ihren eigenen Serien. Da gibt es eine Serie, die heißt Bosch, die ist eigentlich auch ziemlich cool. Also ich fand sie ziemlich cool und das geht jetzt ab demnächst. Also ich glaube, da muss Hollywood auch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, was macht Apple als nächstes? Eine Radiosende haben sie ja schon.
Die Gerüchte gab es diese Woche.
Wie meinst du, es kommt auch noch ein Apple Fernsehsender?
Ja, dass die selber auch in die Produktion reingehen, dass sie sich halt sowas kaufen, na klar.
Warum auch nicht, wenn man Geld hat.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die haben zu viel Political Correctness und all den Scheiß irgendwie auf dem Radar. Ich glaube, das weiß ich nicht, nee. Ja, zu viel Disney.
Zu viel No Titten.
Ja, also im Pixar-Kanal würde ich auch schon mal klarkommen. Schauen wir mal, was da...
Ja, Kinderkanal können sie bestimmt.
Ich bin gespannt jetzt so mit dem neuen Apple TV-Teil. Ich weiß auch noch nicht so ganz genau, ob das mehr so ein Fernseher ist oder mehr eine Spielekonsole.
Dieses Event ist wann? Ist dann genau unsere Sendung am gleichen Tag? Tag danach? Tag davor?
Nein, das ist nächste Woche Mittwoch.
Nächste Woche Mittwoch? Ach, stimmt, das ist schon nächste Woche?
Wäre tatsächlich zeitgleich gewesen?
Hätten wir letzte Woche unser Show gemacht, aber so weit hast du ja nicht vorgeplant.
Doch, habe ich, aber wir haben ja jetzt alles in eine Woche verschoben. Deswegen passt halt jetzt nicht.
Oder wir machen einfach nächste Woche wieder eine.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt jetzt Kino gucken und dann sofort danach. Ich meine, es wird ja zwei Stunden laufen, dann könnte man erst um neun anfangen und live und das funktioniert alles nicht.
Wir können das die anderen Podcasts machen und wir machen das dann in Ruhe und ordentlich, so wie man uns kennt.
Mit Kapitelmarken!
Premium Kapitelmarken!
Ach du nur, ich bewerf dich gleich mit Kapitelmarken!
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum Apple seit Jahren diesen Markt so unangetastet lässt. Also, dieses Apple TV hätte ja...
Schon längst.
Ich verstehe es nicht, warum sie das nicht machen. Alleine da ein App Store drauf zu bringen und...
Ja, vielleicht denken sie sich halt Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten, ne?
Vielleicht ist es auch so ein vertraglicher... Welchen Markt?... Konglomeration.
Welchen Markt?
Der Medien-Abspielgeräte fürs Wohnzimmer. Schreitstrich unter das Ende der Spielkonsolen.
Also es kann natürlich sein, dass sie da vertraglich drin hängen, weil...
Na, Apple TV, ich meine, sind ja...
Ja, aber sie haben ja keinen Third-Party-App-Markt auf der Apple TV.
Doch, sie haben einen.
Der ist bloß nicht offen.
Genau, warum machen sie das nicht? Sie haben die Entwickler-Community, sie haben seit Jahren die Leute dazu gebracht, auflösungsunabhängig zu programmieren.
Seit Jahren ist gut.
Seit iPad Mini? Und davor haben sie es... Wie lange angekündigt?
Seit iPhone 6 eigentlich.
Ja, aber beim iPhone...
Ich glaube, iPad Mini wird doch zuerst, oder?
Ja, aber das hat ja die gleiche Größe wie das normale iPad, pixelmäßig.
Stimmt.
Also, dass sie Videos anzeigen können auf ihren Geräten, das ist ihnen sicherlich nicht entgangen.
Ich hab da dieses YouTube angeklickt.
Nee, was ich sagen will, ist...
Das Apple TV ist insofern eine Herausforderung für Apple, so seh ich das, weil das User-Interface noch nicht klar ist. Wie interagierst du mit einem Screen aus der Ferne? Und dieses hoch, runter, links, rechts durch Menüs, das trifft so vor 90er-Jahre an Namen und Realitäten, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, das letzte Mal eine DVD mit Krasertasten bedient.
Da gehst du doch total am Stock. Und alle Fernseher da draußen auf dem Markt sind alle Scheiße.
Und Apple macht es jetzt so wie bei Blade Runner, ja?
Zoom in.
Wir wüssten nicht, wie wir es machen.
Left, left, left, zoom in.
Kennst du die Szene?
Left, right, left, right, up, down, up, down, wie war das?
Na ja, wenn sie mir dann jeden alten Schinken auf HD vergrößern können, das wäre ja schon mal was.
Ja, mit um die Ecke zoomen. Aber die nehmen Sie dann für ihr Appletee?
Ich weiß nicht, was sie machen.
Ich sage nur, das Problem ist nicht gelöst. Und bevor sie halt anfangen, Apps für alle sozusagen aufzumachen, dann müssen sie auch dieses Ding mit der User-Interaktion fertig gedacht haben.
Ja, da ist viel dran.
Das ist ein Punkt. Das andere ist, dass dieser Fernsehmarkt, ich meine, wo ist das Geld?
Wo ist das, wo Apple sich selbst sieht?
Fernseher verkaufen ist es bestimmt nicht. Wir haben jetzt jahrelang immer wieder gehört, jetzt bringen sie einen Fernseher raus, jetzt bringen wir einen Fernseher raus. Der Fernsehermarkt ist ein Scheißmarkt. Keiner gibt viel Geld aus für Fernseher. Du zahlst ein paar hundert Kröten für deinen 50 Zoll Fernseher. Da gibt es keine Margen, da gibt es auch kaum Premium-Marken, die in irgendeiner Form Traktion haben, die ein paar Dies gab.
Das letzte Mal, als ich auf den IFA war, da gab es irgendwie drei oder vier Hallen, wo halt Fernseherhersteller waren und du bist da reingelaufen und hast genau gesehen, das sind alles die gleichen Displays, die sie verbauen. Das sind alles die gleichen 3D-Brillen, die die Leute aufhaben. Und irgendwie die Schöpfungshöhe der Hersteller untereinander ist null.
Aber ich spreche auch nicht von einem Fernseher, sondern ich spreche einfach davon, von der Set-top-Box. Genau, eine Box unter einem Fernseher. Ah, unter einem Fernseher, der nicht von Apple kommt, sondern die Box kommt von Apple.
Ja, aber damit hast du natürlich ein Problem für das User-Interface. Ja, weil wenn du erstmal durch das User-Interface des Fernsehers durchgehen musst, um überhaupt an das User-Interface ranzukommen, ist schon mal problematisch. Aber darauf wollte ich jetzt nicht hinaus. Ich wollte darauf hinaus, wenn du dich fragst, warum Apple irgendwo was nicht macht, dann würde ich einfach mal versuchen, darüber nachzudenken, wo ist das Geld?
Das Geld ist in der Uhr.
Wir reden doch jetzt über Fernsehen, oder nicht?
Nee, wir reden darüber, warum Apple das nicht macht. Sie haben sich anscheinend eher für eine Uhr entschieden.
Nicht das Geld von Apple, sondern da, wo Apple Geld holen könnte.
Das ist ja ein riesen Markt, wie wir gerade sehen. Ich meine, wenn Sky eine halbe Milliarde Euro für Bundesliga abdrückt, dann ist ja offensichtlich da eine Menge Geld zu holen. Wenn sich solche Exorbitanten Geld an... Aber die Frage ist, wer verdient das?
Ja, aber Sky ist Inhalteanbieter. Sky ist ein Inhalteanbieter. Und Apple würde ich jetzt nicht in dem Markt sehen. Zumindest nicht mit einem Apple TV.
Es ist auch die Frage, ob bei Sky das Geld landet. Das Geld landet ja vor allem erstmal bei der Bundesliga.
Vor allem ist Sky ein Inhalte-Weiterverkäufer. Letzten Endes. Weil sie selber keine Inhalte produzieren.
Und das könnte zum Beispiel Apple auch sehr gut machen.
Das tun sie ja mit Musik. Da sind sie ja ein Inhalte-Weiterverkäufer.
Die Bundesliga könnte sich Apple mal eben mit der Popelkasse reintunken. Und das geht dann noch über das Marketing-Budget. Und sie müssen gar nichts damit verdienen.
Und es gibt eine Apple TV dazu.
Ja, wenn die jetzt so Apple TV mit Covso und dann ist da irgendwie Bundesliga dabei. Aber da rauchen die jetzt auch nicht hinaus, weil auch das ist nicht ihr Style. Das ist Microsoft-Style. Und dieses, wir geben dir noch ganz viel kostenlos, damit du unseren Scheiß kaufst. Und damit das dann irgendwann sich vielleicht für uns rentiert. Das macht Apple auch nicht. Apple sucht von vornherein ein Business-Modell und ihre Rolle in diesem gesamten Konglomerat von Anbieter, Sender, Übertrager, Programmmacher, Delivery, Abo, Werbungs. Also diese ganze Konstellation dieses Marktes schiebt viel Geld rum. Und Apple ist auf der Suche nach ihrer Rolle, wo sie a. ihre Expertise am besten einbringen können, nämlich geiler Hardware, geiles Software, geiles User-Interface. Und b. sich in einen Geldstrom einklinken können, ohne dass ihnen auch irgendjemand den Hahn zudrehen kann. Das ist ja auch das Problem, was sie immer so mit Hollywood und so weiter haben, dass diese ganzen großen, wie nennt man diese Companies, halt diese Hollywood-Companies, auf Biegen und Brechen natürlich versuchen, sich ihren Markt so abzusichern, dass da ihm bloß keiner die Butter vom Brot nimmt. Und genauso ist es ja auch beim Musikgeschäft. Da hat Apple bloß frühzeitig durch nen Move sich ne sehr starke Position erarbeitet, weil Apple niemand zugetraut hat, dass sie überhaupt so ne Rolle jemals einnehmen können. Danach sind sie ja auch alle sehr viel zurückhaltender geworden. Man hat gesehen, wie lang das mit diesem Streaming gedauert hat, bis sie da mal die richtigen Deals rausgehandelt bekommen haben. Und beim Fernsehen wird das sicherlich, und bei der ganzen Filmwelt wird es sicherlich ähnlich sein. Also wo ist das Geld und wo kann man das machen? Und ich glaube, das ist das, was sie abwarten. Wo sie einfach sagen, wir haben Zeit.
Nichts läuft uns weg.
Das, was die anderen machen, sind irgendwie ruinöse Geschöfte. Jetzt kann man sehen, was hat jetzt in letzter Zeit gut funktioniert? Netflix hat wohl ganz gut funktioniert. Also es ist zumindest ein sehr erfolgreiches Produkt. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut die finanziell so dastehen.
Aber die haben sich auch aus einer Nische heraus relativ gute Deals gesichert, weil sie keiner ernst genommen hat, glaube ich. Also wenn ich mich recht erinnere... Die DVD-Verleiherei da. Genau, die haben ja DVDs verschickt am Anfang.
Aber nicht nur, sie hatten auch schon Streams.
Aber haben die nicht auch on demand diese DVDs überhaupt erst gebrannt und dann verschickt? Irgendwie sowas. Also ich glaube, dass die... Dass die Movie-Studios, die nicht auf dem Plan hatten, als jemanden ernst zu nehmen ist, und zack sind sie jetzt plötzlich in der Schlüsselposition da an der Stelle. Daher haben sie sicherlich auch ein paar Sachen einfach richtig gemacht, die die anderen offensichtlich immer noch nicht hinkriegen.
Vor allen Dingen ein Bezahlmodell, was auf Akzeptanz stößt. Und wenig Bullshit sozusagen mit einherbringt.
Ja, das ist auch so was, dass die alle irgendwie arbeiten, den Bullshit-Faktor hochzuhalten.
Wie zum Beispiel Sky. Du kommst dir einfach nur verarscht vor, wenn du dafür bezahlst. Das ist wirklich eine Frechheit, das Leuten gegen Geld anzubieten, monatlich auch noch. Und da ist Netflix natürlich schon mal eine deutlich charmantere Option. Also wenn alles, was Internet, Streaming und Medien so wäre wie Netflix, dann wäre die Landschaft schon mal um einiges angenehmer.
Aber da kann man lange drauf warten, fürchte ich.
Also ich guck gerade mal, was sie hier irgendwie für Kohle machen, Netflix.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Gewinn oder Umsatz?
Na ja, sowohl als auch. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich die Zahlen hier richtig verstehe. Total, Streaming, die haben ja irgendwie so vier Gruppen und ich weiß nicht. Aber Summary Results Below oder was?
Guck doch auf Wolfram Alphammer.
Die machen doch da eigentlich immer eine ganz gute Netflix.
In der Metaebene wird das kurz ruhig.
Alle klicken sie. Keiner redet mehr.
Also Netflix, da steht tatsächlich nicht, was die so an Wirtschaftsdaten haben.
Das ist ja interessant.
Prübe hat gehandelt oder wie?
Three months ended, six months ended, also... Die machen 1,6 Milliarden Umsatz im Quartal, also im letzten Netz.
Und du meinst, das ist nicht so viel?
Na, Umsatz ist erstmal Umsatz und der Income ist ja entscheidend. Und der Operating Income liegt hier so bei... Was ist das? Warte mal, jetzt muss ich gucken, dass ich mich hier mit den Zahlen nicht vertue. Das sind doch genau Thousands. Das sind 26 Millionen Net Income. Das ist ein Scheiß.
Von 1,64 Milliarden bleiben?
26 Millionen über. Also die arbeiten richtig kurz auf knapp.
Na, die schieben ja auch die ganze Zeit erstmal in Wachstum noch. Und in Produktion und Filmproduktion und so.
Nachsteuern, so Operating Income liegt so bei 74.
So wie Amazon seit schon immer, ja?
74 Milliarden.
Und das ist jetzt, das ist nichts.
Ich meine, das macht Apple in 20 Sekunden.
Ja, Apple ist aber auch seit wieviel Jahren im Geschäft und hat sich das wie lange arbeiten lassen.
Nein, aber der Punkt ist, obwohl die, ich meine, was hatten wir da gerade für eine Zahl? 30 bis 50 Prozent des Traffics des Internets. Also eine hohe, weiß nicht wie viele Customers sie haben, aber sicherlich nicht wenige, weil wo soll der Traffic sonst herkommen? Und sie spülen da eine ganze Menge Geld durch. Plus das Geld, was sie verdienen, das schieben sie hinten raus, alle wieder an die eigentlichen Eigener von dem ganzen.
Sind also nur Durchlauferhitzer.
Die sind Durchlauferhitzer und das ist bei den Audio-Buden, bei diesen Streaming-Buden, Spotify und so weiter, ist das genauso. Weil die einfach mega krasse Deals haben. Ich hab mich mal mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten, die da...
Warum steigt Apple da ein, wenn da nichts zu holen ist?
Die sind im Moment ein, wo was zu holen ist.
Wenn Spotify schon nichts verdient, wie wollen die dann noch verdienen?
Weil sie ihnen vielleicht ein Angebot machen können, was ihnen andere nicht machen können. Ich meine, schau dir zum Beispiel Apple Pay an. Das war doch einfach mal der Brüller.
Letzter Zeit nicht mehr so. Redet da kein Schwein mehr drüber.
Weil da jetzt kein Schwein drüber redet, heißt das noch lange nicht. Ich meine, das ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken, was sie da machen. Sie verkaufen dir einmal ein Gerät, haben die Software fertig und ab da verdienen sie an jeder Transaktion mit.
Wenn man da so die ganzen Seiten liest, auch die Business-Seiten, dann sagen die, dass das eher, was da so gemacht wird, das ist nicht so eingeschlagen.
Ja, was ein Business Insider. Die haben doch alle gar keine Zahlen. Apple sagt doch gar nichts darüber. Es gibt doch überhaupt keine Informationen von Apple. Das sind alles Mutmaßungen und könnte vielleicht, und so weiter.
Du wirst ja auch nur heißen. Woher weißt du denn, dass es eingeschlagen ist?
Ich sage dir, dass es insofern eingeschlagen ist, dass kurz nachdem Apple dieses technische Modell vorgestellt hat und gesagt hat, so machen wir das, alle das hier zu machen. Ich meine, Google hat seinen Scheiß-Wallet sofort weggeschmissen und durch Android Pay ersetzt, was technisch exakt dasselbe ist. Weil sie halt eingesehen haben, so muss man das machen. In dem Moment war Apple schon mal ein bisschen weiter und hat vor allem hunderte von Millionen Geräten mit Fingerabdrucksensor da draußen. Und bei Android hast du das halt einfach mal null. Oder quasi nicht so. Und Apple kriegt halt einen besseren Deal bei den Banken als Google, weil sie halt sagen können, wir gucken mal, wir haben hier irgendwie eine super secure Box. Die ganze Malware, die fliegt irgendwie auf Android-Büchsen rum. Und wir haben eigentlich unterm Strich kein Problem.
Wir sagen, wir übernehmen die Garantie.
Und wir kaufen euch das Risiko ab. Wir garantieren dir, dass deine Fraud-Zahlen runtergehen, weil unser Authentication-System diesen Fraud verhindert. Es wird auf einmal keine Kreditkarten-Nummer mehr hinter Clear übertragen. Die Kreditkarten-Nummer verlässt dein Gerät nicht. Sondern es wird immer nur ein Pro-Transaktions-Token durchgeleitet über eine komplett verschlüsselte Geschichte. Und das Ganze ist halt mit Fingerabdruck oder Urkontakt ist es halt irgendwie abgesichert. Klar, kann man sich jetzt alle möglichen Szenarien vorstellen mit. Und ich zieh dein Telefon in deiner Supermarktkasse aus der Tasche und zwing dich mit einer Knarre im Rücken irgendwie, dass du da jetzt draufdrückst, damit dieser 5,70 Mark Betrag...
Ja gut, das ist ja nur ein Vorfall, der skaliert ja nicht. Die Fälle, wo ja die dann 100.000 Karten abzocken, ist ja irgendwie eher ein Problem.
Genau, und das war sozusagen ihr Proposal. Und dadurch haben sie sich auf einmal in den globalen Kreditkartentransaktionsmarkt eingekauft. Mit 0,000% pro Transaktion. Bloß das wird einfach skalieren. Und wenn jetzt erst mal am Anfang alle Fanboys hingelaufen sind und wir müssen das jetzt alle mal ausprobieren und ich kauf jetzt 20 mal das Ding und jetzt haben sie irgendwie so hohe Zahlen und danach normalisiert sich das wieder. Das Ding wird kommen. Das Ding wird auch in Deutschland kommen. Und wir werden das alle benutzen und es ist dann einfach so. Und irgendwann wirst du dich wirklich fragen, warum du jemals mit einer Plastikkarte in deiner Brieftasche durch die Gegend gelaufen hast.
Ich bin gespannt.
Denn es bezahlt schon lange nicht mehr mit Plastikkarten.
Wann?
Bargeld und QR-Codes.
Aber du kaufst auch immer am selben Laden Burger. Das wäre auf Dauer langweilig.
Oder im Friedenrichter.
Und die Burger sind schlechter geworden bei Room77.
Irgendwie, ich war da letztens da. Das ist nicht mehr geil.
Naja, um das nochmal auf diese Fernsehdebatte runterzubringen. Ich erwarte, dass sie halt irgendwann, und vielleicht ist der Zeitpunkt nächste Woche ja schon gekommen, vielleicht auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, aus diesem Apple TV ein Gerät machen, was das sozusagen per Evolution weiter treibt. Und dass sie vielleicht über so ein App Store-Modell und ein neues User-Interface-Modell und auch über einen neuen Deal, wie sich Streaming oder Content-Anbieter in diese Plattformen reinpluggen können, darüber ihre Kohle machen. Und sie werden mit ihren Geräten der Deliverator werden für diesen Kram. Im Prinzip sind sie das jetzt schon. Die haben ja 10, 20, 30 Kanäle. Da kannst du da Bloomberg News usw. machen. Das gibt es da auch schon alles. Du kannst da einen Baseball darüber anschauen und gäbe es da eine Bundesliga-App, die es halt nicht gibt, aber gäbe es eine, würde das eben greifen.
Aber dann reden wir doch über das Gleiche.
Ja, wir reden ja auch über das Gleiche. Du hast dich ja gefragt, warum tun sie da nichts? Und meine Antwort ist, die tun da seit Jahren was, aber die großen Vorhang machen die erst in dem Moment auf, wo das Paket auch komplett ist.
Ja, Steve hat es ja mal als Hobby bezeichnet.
Genau, aber sie konnten bisher noch nicht ein Gesamtpaket anbringen, was auch App Store usw. macht, und sie werden jetzt halt eine Kombination machen aus Deals, einem Angebot für Third-Party-Zuspielungen, so ähnlich wie sie es bei iTunes mit Musik machen. Also nicht komplett frei für jeden, aber schon sehr viel durchlässiger auch für kleinere Labels. Für diese ganzen spezialisierten Kanäle, sowas wie einen FC Union Berlin TV, könnte sich da vielleicht genauso rein deckeln. Und es wird natürlich verbunden sein mit iPhones, mit iPads usw. Es wird ein Universal Outlet sein, wo Apple TV einfach nur ein weiteres Ding ist. Aber alles, was derzeit auf dem Apple TV ist, existiert derzeit noch nicht auf dem iPhone. Und das ist was ich auch denke, dass sie dann irgendwann einen, so wie sie jetzt Apple Music rausgebracht haben, einen Apple, keine Ahnung, wie sie es nennen, Cinema, TV, dass es wegkommt vielleicht von dem Gerät und Apple TV wird ein Software-Dienst, der dann halt auch auf dem iPhone zu verfügen wird.
Sie bringen iTunes auf die Apple TV, was dann auch den Movie und den Fernseh-Store macht.
hoffen wir es nicht.
Irgendwie sowas. Oder was es auch sein kann, dass es alles total anders ist.
Das kann es nicht.
Sehen wir ja nächste Woche Mittwoch. Was haben wir noch auf der Liste?
Jetzt noch etwas Kleinet.
Kleinet hier. Irgendjemand wollte noch etwas zu Apple Music.
Nächste Mal.
Ich wollte noch etwas zu Bitcoin erzählen.
Das ist doch schön.
Ganz ruhig, ohne dazwischen quatschen. Habt ihr gehört?
Wir haben eh alle, keine Ahnung. Wer spielt jetzt hier den Frage?
Nimm das Mikro mit.
Hast du Bluetooth-Headset?
Ich hör dir zu.
Es fragen mich oft Leute, welche Wallet ich denn fürs iPhone empfehlen kann. Ich hatte eine Weile lang die... Sie reden über Bitcoin. Ich hatte eine Weile lang die Blockchain-App von blockchain.info. Das ist zwar schon so, dass die Bitcoins dann nicht bei denen liegen und die von denen verwaltet werden, sondern man hat die schon irgendwie selbst. Aber irgendwie Blockchain-Info ist auch nicht mehr gerade so angesagt und die haben auch noch so ihre Lücken. Ich glaube, da wurde alles irgendwie im JavaScript geregelt oder wie auch immer. Ich weiß nicht, wie die es genau machen, aber es war komisch. Und man will auch keine Wallets benutzen, wo man das Geld nicht mehr selber verwalte, sondern wo das andere machen. Und man will natürlich auch keine Wallets benutzen, wo die gesamte Blockchain auf dem iPhone liegt. Ich glaube fürs iPhone gibt es sowas auch gar nicht. Ich bin mir jetzt aber nicht so sicher. Das will man alles nicht. Deswegen gibt es dann eine neue App, die heißt Bread Wallet. Den Source-Code dafür gibt es auch bei GitHub. Ist auch sehr schick gecodet. Also ist mit Touch-Code schon eingebaut. Und der Typ bemüht sich, dass er irgendwie alle fancy Features, die immer gerade so kommen, auch immer schön umsetzt und das sauber macht, ohne dass es überladen wirkt, dass es trotzdem sehr sehr simpel gestaltet. Und das Coole an der App, im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu der Blockchain-Info-App, zu der Blockchain-App ist, dass, obwohl man nicht die gesamte Blockchain da haben muss, der trotzdem das verifizieren kann. Und zwar gibt es ein Protokoll, könnte man das nennen, das heißt SPV, Simplified Payment Verification. Das heißt, die normale Bitcoin-Wallet, die man auf dem Rechner hat, also auf dem Desktop, die guckt halt in dieser riesen Datenbank von 30 GB immer nach, ist das Geld schon vergeben oder nicht und muss halt die ganzen Datenbank sozusagen da haben und checken. Und damit das halt, weil das auf dem Telefon nicht geht, machen diese SPV-Apps das so, dass sie halt ins Netz andere fragen, die halt die Blockchain da haben, über spezielle Calls, die dann bei Bitcoin irgendwann mal eingeführt wurden im Protokoll, dass es halt, dass diese Calls einfacher gehen, weil früher gab's das wohl noch nicht so richtig und fragen dann hier, stimmt das, dass dieses Geld noch nicht benutzt ist und da fragen die so ein bisschen mehrere rum, ist ja auch durch die Blockchain ja signiert, das heißt, die können sich auch mit, glaub ich, einer Antwort schon zufriedengeben, weil die Signaturen halt noch stimmen. Und das erleichtert schon mal halt diese App, dass sie halt überhaupt eigentlich lokal gar keine Daten da halten müssen. Also keine Blockchain mehr, keine 30 GB, sondern nur noch die App und ich weiß nicht, ob die ein bisschen was durchcashen, aber wahrscheinlich nicht viel. Und das andere Feature, was jetzt eigentlich noch viel interessanter ist, ist dieses Bread-Wallet nutzt eine sogenannte HD-Wallet. Das ist eine hierarchische Deterministik-Wallet. Und zwar das Problem bei Bitcoin ist, wenn jetzt hier der Huckel hat 50 Bitcoins und der Huckel hat aber Schulden. Und der müsste mir 10 Bitcoins rüberschieben.
Schön wert.
Dann würde er halt so eine Transaction irgendwie rausschieben mit seinem er nutzt jetzt noch die normale Bitcoin-Wallet. Dann werden die diese 50 Bitcoins, sagen wir mal, hat die als einen Coin. Bei intern ist das auch. Ist das so in Coins oder wird von Keys verwaltet. Man könnte das jetzt mal so als einen Coin betrachten, als eine Einheit. Dann gibt er die raus, davon gehen 10 Bitcoins an mich und 40 gehen wieder an ihn zurück, aber an einen neuen Key. Das heißt, sein Key ändert sich. So. Und wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen weiterdenkt, also der Vorgang ist erstmal ganz normal, aber angenommen, der Hucke will natürlich von seinen Bitcoins, will er auch halt einen Backup machen, falls irgendwie sein Rechner abhanden kommt. Wenn er jetzt einen Backup machen würde und würde dann diese 10 Bitcoins an mich weiterschieben und diese 40 an sich selbst wieder zurückbekommen, dann ist diese 40 Bitcoins, die er kriegt, die sind ja in einen neuen Key sozusagen gepackt, dann wäre sein Backup nicht mehr, würde nicht mehr diese Bitcoins verwalten, sondern das Backup wären die alten 50, aber die sind ja ausgegeben und die 49 sind nicht im Backup drin. Deswegen gibt es bei dem normalen Bitcoin-Wallet so eine Prägenerierung von 100 Keys. Das heißt, wenn du einen Backup machst, dann hast du schon den nächsten 100 Transactions, die da noch kommen können, hast du schon mitgebackuped, damit das genau nicht passiert, damit dein Backup auch eine Weile hält.
Sehr geschummelt.
Ungefähr ist das klar verständlich?
Ich muss noch mal ein bisschen nachfragen.
Bitte.
Also, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich es richtig verstanden habe, aber was ich meine verstanden zu haben. Diese App, die implementiert jetzt vor allem erst mal dieses SPV.
Ja, das war ja das erste, was ich erklärt habe. Das war jetzt von vorhin, ja.
Das macht nicht das Spread-Wallet, sondern das Spread-Wallet macht nur das HD-Ding.
Nee, das Spread-Wallet macht beides.
Macht beides, okay. Und dieses Simplified Payment Verification, auch dafür muss es nichts vorhalten. Keine Blockchain und auch sonst keine Keys und Passwörter und so weiter.
Also wie gesagt, es kann sein, naja doch, du brauchst schon deine Keys, um an deine Bitcoins ranzukommen, aber du brauchst nicht die komplette Blockchain.
Aber wo liegen die Bitcoins? Oder schon auf dem Telefon?
Ob, ja, du gibst, beim Starten, also das erkläre ich, das ist die zweite Stufe, die ich gerade erkläre, da mit diesem hierarchisch-deterministischen Wallet, da bin ich sozusagen gerade da weiter einzusteigen, da kommen wir dann gleich hin.
Ja, ich meine jetzt liegen ja meine Bitcoins auf dem Rechner. Wenn ich die aufs Telefon, also muss ich sie wirklich auf das Telefon kriegen? Oder ist das nur noch so eine Art Remote-Kontroll?
Nee, das ist kein Remote-Kontroll, sondern meine Bitcoins liegen jetzt gerade hier auf dem Telefon, weil hier auch ich sozusagen die Keys dafür eingegeben habe. Aber ich würde sagen, weil du fängst jetzt von hinten an, wenn wir das hier zu Ende erklären, dann kommen wir gleich dahin. Also das mit dem Backup, das war wichtig, ob ihr das verstanden habt? Okay, also wenn diese keine Keys vorgenerieren würden, dann wäre nach einer Transaktion das Backup hinüber. Deswegen generieren die 100 Keys vor, damit Huckel ungefähr 100 Transaktionen machen kann, bevor der letzte Key nicht mehr im Backup ist. Dann müsste man wieder ein neues Backup machen. Deswegen generieren die Huckel vor. So, aber weil das ja nicht ewig hält, ist die Lösung schon gar nicht so schlecht, aber auf lange Sicht ist das halt auch nicht das wahre. Deswegen gibt es diese Hierarchical Deterministic Wallet. Und bei der ist es so, dass man am Anfang einen Key eingibt und alle folgenden Keys, so wie diese 100 bei der Standard-Bitcoin-Core-App, alle folgenden Keys werden von dem ersten Key generiert. Das heißt, du brauchst eigentlich nur den ersten Merken. In dem Fall sind das zwölf Wörter, die man sich merken kann. Zwölf verschiedene, die einem angezeigt werden, sagen, das ist jetzt dein Key. Den merkst du dir. Und wenn mein Telefon jetzt verloren geht, dann gehe ich an irgendein anderes iPhone, installiere diese App, gebe diese zwölf Wörter ein und bang, sind meine Bitcoins wieder da, weil der diese Keys wieder neu erzeugt. Und auch egal, wie viel Überweisung ich mache, wo immer neue Keys entstehen, das sind immer sequenziell sozusagen von diesem ersten Key entstanden. Also hierarchisch deterministisch. Man kann immer wieder diese ganze Key-Kette neu erstellen.
Und zwölf Wörter eingeben?
Also wenn du zum ersten Mal deine Wallet, sozusagen mit dieser Bread Wallet erstellst, dann zeigt der dir zwölf Wörtern oder sechzehn, ich glaube.
Und die enthalten vollständig die gesamte Information?
Das ist dein Key sozusagen. Dann ist das Seat sozusagen das Seat für deine Key-Kette. Das ist sozusagen deine Keychain, so könnte man das sagen. Also alle folgenden...
Aber das würde jetzt sozusagen reichen, du sagst mir diese zwölf Wörter und dann hab ich irgendwie dein Geld.
Ja, das ist so. Das ist noch witziger. Der hat mir die halt angezeigt und sagt, hier ist dein random, deine zwölf Wörter. Ich so ganz schlau wie immer, wollt so Screenshot machen. Da sagt er, zack, ich hab jetzt die Dinge mal gelöscht, weil Screenshot ist nicht. Dann hat er mir neue angezeigt, weil ich durfte keinen Screenshot machen. Der hat dann gemerkt, dass er einen Screenshot gemacht hat, hat die Keys weggeschmissen und hat mir neue angezeigt.
Apps kriegen mit, wenn ein Screenshot von ihnen gemacht wird?
Fand er auf jeden Fall nicht witzig. Ich hab ihn dann ausgetrickst, weil ich hab Geld überwiesen, dann konnte er den Key nicht löschen, weil war ja Geld drauf, war auch ein riskanter Move, weil hätte ich den doch löschen können. Hat er aber nicht. Und jetzt hab ich doch einen Screenshot. Ich hab's mir dann aufgeschrieben später, aber... Falls dieses Feature sorgt dafür, dass halt dieses Backup-Problem, dass das halt nicht mehr existiert, weil mit diesem Key, mit diesem Seed sozusagen, kann man ab da alle weiteren Keys generieren. Deterministisch halt. Und dadurch ist das Problem gelöst.
Irgendwie hab ich das mit dieser Verifizierung, für die man sonst irgendwie die ganze Blockchain braucht.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen was anderes.
Aber macht das die Sache nicht unsicherer, wenn du quasi aus dem, ich nenne mal ersten Key, irgendwie alle weiteren generieren kannst?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Weil der nur noch diesen einen Key braucht. Und dann hat das halt. Aber ob er nun diesen einen Seed von dir klaut, oder bei der normalen App dir deine Keys gerade irgendwie klaut, oder die ganze Wolle-Datei ist dann auch egal. Und wenn du das nicht mehr willst, dass dir von da jemand klauen kann, dann erstellst du dir halt einen neuen und du überweist alles darüber. Und dann ist der ja sozusagen tot, und dann ist da ja nichts mehr drauf. Schlimmer ist es eher, vielleicht ein Problem, dass jemand dir noch Überweisungen an deine Bitcoin-Adressen macht, die mit diesem Key generiert wurden. Und die dann ja danach immer noch irgendwie ankommen. Und der Attacker davon, die Keys dann hat, da weiß ich aber gar nicht, ob das bei dem normalen Bitcoin nicht auch ein Problem ist, oder ob sich dann das drunter wechselt. Da müsst ihr nochmal drüber nachdenken oder nachlesen.
Aber theoretisch könntest du natürlich, wenn du das Gefühl hast, das ist komprimitiert, könntest du 100 Überweisungen machen. Und dann sind die alle verbraucht.
Nee, wenn du denkst, du bist komprimitiert, dann machst du dir sofort eine neue Wallet frisch, die niemand hat und überweist deine Geldworte.
Nein, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt eine Adresse hast, wo noch Geld ankommt aus irgendeinem Grund, du könntest ja 100 Überweisungen machen, dann sind die 100 Keys, die mal in deinem Backup drin waren, alle verbraucht und dann werden ja per Zufriedener...
Weil es jemand in deinem Backup geklaut hat, oder?
Genau. Und wenn du aber diesen komischen hierarchical Key hast, dann kannst du ja aus dem Seed-Key ja immer...
Da kannst du das nicht machen...
.endlos neue Keys generieren.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn du irgendwie komprimitiert bist, dann willst du dein Geld woanders hinschieben.
Jaja, gut, klar. Aber wenn du erfolgreich komprimitiert bist, dann hast du eh keins mehr.
Dann ist es eh sofort weg. Der Vorteil von dieser Bread-Wallet ist, du kannst die verlieren. Du installierst sie einfach neu, gibst deine 12 Wörter wieder ein und boom! Dann ist dein Geld wieder da. Gleichzeitig ist es sehr schmal programmiert. Es braucht fast gar keine Ressourcen. Dieses SBV ist irgendwie ratten schnell. Der macht kurz eine Sekunde lang ein paar Abfragen ins Netz. Lässt sich bestätigen, ob der Geld angekommen ist oder nicht. Oder ob das alles so okay ist. Es ist einfach sehr schmalbandig und sehr elegant programmiert. Der ganze Source-Good liegt auf GitHub. Ich habe den Eindruck, es ist ein richtig guter, anständiges Stück Software.
Und jetzt dieses SBV ist ein Protokoll?
Ja, eigentlich ist es erst mal nur... Es ist so wie Firewall, würde ich jetzt erst mal sagen. Es ist halt ein Name für eine Art und Weise, ohne dass man diese Blockchain nicht haben muss. Aber es gab irgendwann, und das ist auch schon wieder 2-3 Jahre her, haben die halt in Bitcoin, in ihr Protokoll was eingebaut, damit dieses SBV einfacher möglich ist. Und deswegen könnte man das Protokoll nennen, aber ich glaube, das war mal nur eine Idee.
Okay, aber wenn du mir jetzt einen Bitcoin überweist, mit deiner Bread-Wallet. Ich gebe dir jetzt irgendwie eine Bitcoin-Adresse. Mit wem redet dann diese Wallet?
Das ist ja die einfache Seite. Da musst du eigentlich meinen Bread-Wallet überhaupt gar nicht überprüfen wollen, sondern ich schicke ja dir Geld. Das heißt, der connectet da irgendwo an irgendeinen, der einen Bitcoin-Note laufen hat, schickt da die Transaction durch und bang, dann ist die raus und da verteilt sie sich überall hin.
Das ist so wie immer sozusagen.
Das ist so wie immer, genau.
Und das Empfangen ist knickiger.
Das Empfangen ist wahrscheinlich auch so, der connectet sich irgendwo hin und lässt sich halt bestätigen, dass da Geld gekommen ist. Und weil diese Transactions oder dieses SPV-Protokoll, das ist halt auch signiert, das heißt, der muss jetzt nicht hunderttausende Fragen, um sich da drauf zu verlassen, sondern er kann halt wenige Fragen und das ist dann okay.
Okay, aber kann man das ja nicht auch irgendwie auf dem Rechner für seine Podcasts normalerweise haben?
Gibt es bestimmt auch schon irgendwelche Apps, die das so machen, aber wenn alle nicht mehr eine richtige Full-Node oder eine Full-Bitcoin-Node fahren, dann gibt es keinen mehr, den du fragen könntest. Also ein paar brauchen wir schon noch und wenn das auch nur noch drei sind, dann kannst du dein Geld auch gleich bei der Bank liegen lassen, weil dann haben die dich sozusagen bei denen in der Hand.
Ja, aber ich meine...
Also die Leute, wenn ihr auch BreadWallet benutzt, wenn ihr irgendwie zu Hause einen Router habt, der sich sowieso langweilt, dann lasst dann nebenbei irgendwie ein Bitcoin-Note irgendwie full featured laufen. Das kostet jetzt irgendwie fast keine Bandbreite, kostet nur 30 Gigabyte. Ich meine, wenn du laden gehst, kriegst du jetzt 6 Terabyte Platten hinterhergeschmissen. Also 30 Gig ist mal gar nichts.
Hinterhergeschmissen ist jetzt vielleicht übertrieben.
Ja, vielleicht sind es 40 inzwischen, keine Ahnung.
Also ich hab hier 60 Gigabyte in meinem Bitcoin.
60? Dann hast du bei dem Wechsel von dem alten auf den neuen nicht aufgeräumt und du hast noch die alte Chain da liegen.
Wie räume ich da auf?
Da musst du so ein paar Dateien löschen. Die nicht.
Nein, ich weiß. Ein paar Dateien und welche?
Ja, das können wir nachher gucken. Ich weiß das nicht aus dem Kopf.
Ja, das sind alle gleich.
Aber ich kann, wenn du so einen Alarm machst, kann ich mal gucken. Vielleicht haben ja andere Leute das gleiche Problem. Was jetzt kommt, ist natürlich ohne Garantie, weil wenn das schief geht, ist euer Zeug weg, macht Backups usw., erkennt den Drill. Muss ich mal schauen. Also ich hab bei mir noch einen Ordner, der heißt Blocks, einen Ordner, der heißt Chains Date. Und was hast du da noch, was nicht Blocks oder nicht Chains Date ist?
Na, da liegen erstmal noch mal so ein paar Block 001-Dateien auf dem selben Level.
Weil das ist jetzt alles in einem Ordner, der Blocks heißt.
Okay, und alles, was außerhalb ist, weg?
Na, nicht alles, aber wie gesagt, Blocks und Chains Date hab ich.
Die Block-Dateien auf jeden Fall.
Ja, die können weg. Kannst ja auch aufs Datum gucken, wann die zum letzten Mal geändert wurden. Dann siehst du es ja schon, die müssten auch mal zwei Jahre her sein oder so.
Na gut, aber das sind dann so vielleicht 8 GB. Dann hab ich noch einen Ordner, der heißt Database, aber der ist nur 1 GB groß.
Ja, den hab ich auch schon nicht mehr.
Ist aber heute um 23.27 Uhr jetzt mal geändert worden. So ganz unwichtig scheint er nicht zu sein.
Von wann ist dein Bitcoin?
Bitte?
Von wann ist dein Bitcoin kleint?
Von wann der ist? Wie meinste das, von wann der ist?
Na, welche Version?
Ach so, ja, das kann ich dir sagen. 011.
Das ist eigentlich aktuell. Da weiß ich nicht, warum du noch einen Ordner hast, der Database heißt.
Tja, ich hab eine wahrscheinlich Datenbank und du nicht.
Weiß ich ja nicht.
Ja, aber ich sehe ja, was hier getouched ist und was nicht.
Also ich hab in Blogs, hab ich 54 GB drin und in der Chain-State hab ich 1,1 GB drin. Das heißt, die Blockchain ist gerade 45 GB groß.
Okay, bei mir sind es 50. Wahrscheinlich hab ich einfach mehr Geld als du.
Kann sein. Das wird sein. Die ganzen kleinen Mini-Transactions, die kosten natürlich Platz. Nee, aber da ist ja die Blockchain drin. Was da drin liegt, hat gar nichts mit dir zu tun. Deswegen. Aber diese komischen Blogspunkte oder Files, die da noch liegen, die kannst du wegloppen.
Verstehe. So, das heißt, deine Division lautet, zumindest für Mobile-Payments könnte diese Bread-Wallet und alles, was genauso polemiert ist, jetzt so ein Lightweight-Bitcoin-Wallet sein?
Ja, das gibt's auch schon länger. Ich hab das halt nur ignoriert, weil ich dachte, ich hab erst mal diese Blockchain-Info-App, die das da für mich macht, aber dann bin ich doch irgendwann mal umgestiegen und dachte, ich will die jetzt nicht mehr, weil dieses Blockchain, auch diese Webseite von, das performt alles irgendwie nicht so gut und das ist sozusagen politisch nicht korrekt, wie die da die Bitcoins verwalten und man will die halt, Bitcoins grundsätzlich will man die selber verwalten und diese Bread-Wallet, die sorgt dafür, dass ich da 100 Prozent Kontroll hab und niemand anders. Also egal, wenn wer Pleite geht oder Scheiße baut, meine Bitcoins liegen bei mir und nicht woanders. Und bei diesem Blockchain-Info, da war, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, aber es war komisch, wie die das verwaltet haben. Also die haben dir auch E-Mails gesendet, wenn irgendwas auf deiner Wallet angekommen ist. Also, indem sie sich halt, die hatten deine Adresse mitverwaltet, weil du das da online irgendwie da machst. Ich weiß nicht so genau, ist zwar ganz nett, aber es war wohl nicht ganz safe. So viel zu Bitcoin.
Will noch jemand irgendwas beitragen? David, bist du schon eingeschlafen?
Machst du dir einen Schlusspunkt.
Was? Das war ja das Camp mit einem Familienabschnitt. Wir werden ja auch alle Eltern und alle Väter. Und als zukunftsgerichteter Vater...
Wie, du hast auf dem Camp ein Kind gezeugt?
Als zukunftsgerichteter Vater liest man ja abends seinen Kindern was vor.
Das haben auch schon die nicht zukunftsgerichteten Väter.
Da guckt man ja natürlich als zukunftsgerichteter Vater im iBook Store mal nach, was es da so gibt. Da gibt es nämlich ein Buch, das nennt sich... Nein, das nennt sich Die Geschichte vom Robin dem Robinbaby. Das ist so schön, weil das ist auch kostenlos. Da kann man sich als Eltern runterladen. Man liegt neben seinem Kind im Bett und liest es vor. Dann kann man es ein bisschen animieren. Dann steht da hier, verschlafen blinzelt Robin in die Welt. Die ersten Sonnenstrahlen kitzeln an seiner Stubsnase. Dann sieht man auch kleine Robben. Das ist auch ein bisschen süß animiert. Dann geht die Mutter von Robin tauchen und sucht Fische. Robin spielt mit den Möwen. Dann blättert man hier so durch. Hier sind Möwen. Dann lässt es sich fallen. Dann trifft er den Wal. Dann liest man das so vor. Das Kind freut sich.
Das ist alles animiert.
Das ist alles ein bisschen animiert.
Das ist ein modernes Eibuck.
Genau, Zukunfts-Eibuck. Dann verabschiedet sich. Dann spielt er hier Bowling mit den Pinguinen. Dann geht es los. Robin ist völlig in Spielen vertieft. Da tauchen hinter ihm kanadische Robbenjäger auf. Als Robin die dumpfen Schritte bemerkt, blickt er sich um. Beim Anblick des Stahlknüppels wird er starvorschreckt und beginnt vor Angst zu schluchzen. Dann steht da so ein böser Typ mit so einer Blut in den Achsen und zum Stahlknüppeln. Und dann, am Abend, kehrt Robins Mutter mit den Fischen von der Jagd zurück. Doch Robin ist nicht mehr zu sehen. Dort, wo sie ihn zurückgelassen hat, ist der Schnee blutrot gefärbt. Robins Mutter beginnt bitterlich zu weinen. Sie weiß, dass sie ihren Sohn nie wiedersehen wird.
Und so endet die Geschichte.
So endet die Geschichte. Und dann kannst du sagen, so mein Süßer, jetzt schlaf schön. So, und die Mutter ist da ganz traurig. Der Schnee ist blutrot gefärbt, sieht man auch alles schön. Und dann kann man umblättern und sagen, dann steht da 400.000 Robben, er eilt dieses Jahr, dieses grausame Schicksal, aber das kannst du ändern. Kaufe Robbins Geschichte jetzt mit einem guten Ende für 1,79.
Nicht schlecht.
Man unterstützt dadurch eine Tierschutzorganisation, das ist vielleicht noch mal hinten ein bisschen Altruismus, doch noch neutral. Aber so ganz vorbereitet ist man da nicht drauf.
Und du hast das erste mit dem roten Schnee deinen Kindern vorgelesen und später entdeckt, dass du es hättest anders leben können.
So viel zum Thema Freak-Show.
Und die wissen genau, dass man das weine Kind nehmen kann, dass man ganz schnell die 1,80 Euro ausgibt.
Genau, damit das Kind endlich lebt.
Das ist ja voll fies.
Das heißt, die Geschichte von Robin dem Robin-Baby.
Unglaublich.
Findet man das nur, wenn man mit dem iPad sucht?
Gute Fragen, die gibt es doch eigentlich auch auf dem Mac.
Also, keine Ergebnisse.
Nee, ist auch nicht.
Vielleicht schon zurückgezogen worden, von Apple gesperrt worden.
Wir haben es herausgenommen.
Trotzdem toll die Idee.
Wie heißt das bei diesem komischen Vlog?
Das wäre doch ein Refinanzierungsmodell hier für die Freak Show.
Es gibt nur ein gutes Ende.
Nee, die freie Version hat halt immer ein scheiß Ende.
Und kein Previously.
Nee, und dann irgendwie, wenn ihr wollt, dass wir uns aber in der Ende nicht alle anschreien und Scheiße finden.
Aber ich fürchte, die freie Version ist die mit dem guten Ende.
Die freie Version ist fünf Stunden und die gute Version ist irgendwie Kondens zweieinhalb.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass sich am Schluss alle anschreien.
Werft ein. Nee, ich überleg grad, was könnte denn bei der Freak Show so ein richtiger Pain sein, wenn ihr wollt, dass wir, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass wir unqualifiziert über Android und System-D und so weiter sprechen. Oder, nee, genau, vielleicht vier Stunden Google, IO. Nachlese.
Das ist dann für die Kikigeeks, die sich mal richtig bestrafen lassen. So, Robin, Baby, jetzt guck ich mal, ob das hier mit dem iPad zu finden ist. Das wär natürlich auch geil. Ich hab nur Ronny, das ist Robin, Baby. Das kostet all 5,99. Also irgendwie funktioniert das alles nicht. Kann sein, dass es schon wieder zurückgezogen ist, aber die Story ist trotzdem lustig.
Vielleicht find's ja noch wenig.
So, ja, der Rest ist alles Kleinkram. Ich finde, wir sind durch. Wir waren schon wieder so lange, wie wir sonst auch lang sind.
Hast mich sehr gefreut.
Ja, mich auch.
Wurde auch mal Zeit. Nochmal Applaus für die tollen Previeslies und die harte Arbeit, die du investiert hast mit den Notizen und der Handschrift. Jetzt, wo du weißt, dass du die Kapitelmarken exportierst.
Du kannst die genau ja und wir sagen auch tschüss war ja ja ja dann Rinnje hauen sagen wir hier schon mal hier autorisieren damit das nicht alles bis in die Ewigkeit und die Mitternacht treffen im Room 77.
Aber was ist denn da los? Die sind die Bürger sind echt schlecht geworden.
So, die waren früher geiler.
Achso wir müssen ja noch streiten am Ende.
Also mit so einem Thema muss er jetzt echt nicht kommen.